good i'll be right back real quick hello i'm i'm the band
leader no i got a chance wow i'm alive
yeah yeah guys i'm the leader the band leader i went live
uh-huh dad was like i heard you get to dictate what right
now oh my goodness that means uh it's i'm gonna sabotage the
man please kid i'm yeah it's over fan spider-man guys you
think it was a bad idea to stream it no right no it
shouldn't affect me no you can request to join and you have
to put in the password yeah no it's it's it's auto sensor
don't worry i'm ordering i need i'm ordering coffee and food
right now i'm actually hungry i need to order i mean it's
gonna be a while till we're missing
coffee right now first time you're too welcome welcome um i
don't know if sound guy is alive is just like as alive right
now honestly sound guy are you alive are you here do you
exist booby bash some coffee i ordered this again i sort of
his penis ball farts okay got it got it food has been
ordered and a drink too we're we're so locked in we're so
fucking locked in guys we're guys guys believe there's a
seating yep I still have two lifelines on Sunday whatever
happens whatever happens we have two more lifelines on
Sunday guys whatever happens No matter what if the worst
comes to worst, it's okay But but that but it's not going to
the worst is not gonna happen because we're so locked in We
got this the worst is not going to happen.
Oh, what's going on guys?
How we doing?
I'm not gonna be reading the chat too much.
I'm in Bougar bash.
We're winning potato Yeah, let's see Too much left thing.
Can we go down?
Can I feet go down?
Dallas and the and VR Dallas on our should we rename our
team Dallas are me potatoes on oh my gosh it's just okay my
brain is just there's fumes coming out right now but that's
okay do not worry about that um you some cars take a while
to get started and you some cars have smoke coming out of it
when we first when you first tried to start it guys do not
worry do not worry okay uh birthday merch is out now all
right let's see
yeah which does that warm up do not worry about it do not
worry about it
i cannot confirm or deny if i have warmed up today do not
worry about it wake up wake him up is technically warming up
you think about it you know because we're using energy I'm
already using my muscles my arm muscles and my hand muscles
thank you so much and then get out of the bed that's
practically warming up yeah my stream earlier was my
pre-game for this tournament you're right you're right it's
only guys griefing my practice during sessions it's only
been six hours since my last warm-up guys so it's fine
you're not worried about it it oh okay we're so locked in
okay oh okay i think we're really good at that mantis shit
by the way oh yeah and you like man out black cats man
mantis like not as much as a man and then you're a bad
mantis unless we if dive is really we just got 10 mantis
whatever kid that's really sticky he's a pro player well
he's like 500 yellow higher than me well okay if dive i'm
just saying if dive open in that mirror we have to play uh
like well i don't know if we have to play dd how much do i
get like five hours i think that's all right pretty good
don't worry i have a lot you i have a lot of sleep hours
stored in you know in reserve so it should transfer over i
slept so much yeah two days ago they can't so that sleep
that should transfer over and not yet so that sleep should
transfer over to today is what all of your that's how the
body works guys oh i want to eat so badly right now they're
gone oh my stomach's like why didn't you eat i was like
you're not you're usually not awake at this time doki sorry
how dare you demand for food you're usually not awake at
this time doki that's not how the body works how you know
are you a doctor or some yeah that's right i only take
medical advice from doctors
exactly oh tummy hungry i know you i know my body he said r
he said r you ready all right we're ready all right yeah i'm
ready let's go let's go so take the cup on spider i mean the
Of course they bought it.
It's time.
I'm like, what?
Touch it.
Bro.
All right.
Oh, you mean body.
Guys, I think you should.
I'm here.
I am here.
Is Jalen here?
Ralen's here.
Right?
I'm here.
Can you guys hear me?
Yep.
I'm here.
Yeah, we can hear you.
Yeah.
I was going to flounder.
I don't think so.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm here.
So legit.
I'm like one of the lowest ranks in the game.
In this one.
At least.
I don't know what sound guys at the sound guys are at off
guys so let's hope to again humble celestial player bro I'm
not going to be playing all into these guys especially with
like guys you guys are my sound guy for now I'm on Mac duty
because like I'm not changing any of my discord set my obs
settings only because like that these are that's like my my
peak my prime uh settings for kind-hearted uh relationship
with collabs I don't think she knows he's I don't think he
he's not muted but before like vtuber collabs that's me back
a really sticky is quiet i really sticky right now in one
minute my volumes are no ways though preferably a woman
preferably i don't think he what what conversation is this
man having what is he talking about low puffs maybe netty's
well listen not for real bro so i don't think you know
you're unmuted tournaments are also different from the
tournament today like uh this is boker bash which i'm i'm no
you want to be on it he's still he still doesn't know we're
sorry i thought i had a new button what's good i was i was
listening he's still he's yeah he's still going do you think
you want to all right all right okay guys guys you guys you
guys are honorary sound i'll message the audio oh any mods
here?
Mods.
This is your new job now.
This is your new job right now.
Fix this.
Fix the sound.
Congratulations.
You got promotion.
No increase in pay.
But, oh my god.
Oh my god.
All my mods are off by too.
I don't know.
I just know my sound guys are at off by.
Oh my god.
Are all my mods also at off by?
All right.
They're just gonna ban.
They're gonna ban gimme.
Okay.
Good.
You're still here.
You as the one mod that didn't go to off guy tell me how who
to adjust my two guys my two guys who to adjust we just play
black guys i think i probably i think i should probably dd
you can't even lie ziggie all right yeah you can do that no
come on we gotta we gotta fix this so we could hear us hear
me obviously i'm the most important person in this in this
lobby right now yeah just make sure you can you Are you
okay?
I'm gonna, uh, Tato a bit up.
Captain Yimiro.
All right.
All right, Tato has been up now.
Our captain has been- Or I could ban cap right now.
All right, what else?
I should have to get you out.
I think you can ban you.
Why just ban Gambit?
I can just ban Gambit right now.
Should I do that?
What else?
Oh.
It's all right.
Yeah, you can do it.
You can do it.
Guys, what else?
Olive is also kind of low.
Okay.
all right nice what else guys what else oh is my coffee in
here i ordered a little rap too with my little coffee let me
just play like or these people they're rivals players they
play a lot of rivals they're a lot a lot of rivals one of
them streamed 24 hours of rivals two days ago and i was like
jesus christ bro that's passion that's passion right there
he's also 14 so he has a lot you can fuck up his body as
much as he wants before i think before he regrets it I think
they still think that I'm a dead bull on track.
He is allowed to fuck up his body until...
I think Momo still thinks I'm a dead bull on track.
Age catches up with him.
Yeah, this guy's 14.
The guy that sounds like a little, like not a little boy,
but the guy that sounds like he hasn't hit puberty yet.
Surprisingly, I don't know, he's not a girl.
He's pulling a human.
You're playing with a child?
No, I think he was.
Hey!
Why do you make things happen?
weird why are you making things bro is in middle school
right now okay it's like comfort pick or i should have been
maybe banked it's like it's like capital group there i think
yeah a real a squeak squeaker alert why you gotta make
things weird why
hey bender shy wow child labor um what are child laws here
uh and rivals evil okay it's just this and then flake dd and
i mean olive can work the map hit i can living bullet not
you uh they might be like that's true i think maybe he's
homes i don't know i i'm not gonna assume his life mostly
might be homeschool it's summer vacation i know it's like
guys we guys we haven't been to school for so long we forgot
summer vacation we forgot about summer vacation infinite
ammo we need infinite ammo is you gotta care that he might
just run at us You never know, girl.
I was like, wait, you're right.
I was like, wait a minute.
We forgot about summer vacation.
Am I lying?
No, everything is fine.
It's okay, I know his rollout this one up, okay?
Shit.
No, shit.
Alright.
I'll meet myself the moment.
Okay, I think we should I think we should look.
I think we should look.
I think we should Poth left side, like us.
Yeah, I'm gonna go left.
maybe it was me thank you damage boost everybody and then we
three two on the hit and i'll shoot the back line yeah i'll
get you don't be afraid to like yell at me to tell me what
to do yeah yeah fine just you just play mid there's a fur
bubble mo mo's already in top left yeah mo is your rink you
slam mo mo can you slam yeah okay i have a trap they're
below us they're below us I can get back up.
Yeah, I can shoot.
I can shoot.
I'm waiting for the vehicle.
Mumu's on.
I figured out.
I got them.
Yeah.
Can you get out?
They're all one.
I got you.
I don't have,
I don't have, uh...
We need to get out.
I don't have any more leaves.
Yeah, I didn't have more leaves.
Can you help me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No more leaves.
I saw we can win.
I saw the kill.
No.
My bad.
Manta's.
He killed Manta's here.
She's here.
Wait, wait.
Come back fast.
Yeah, yeah.
They got Manta's.
Just throw a hit on the Luna.
I can help.
It's just the punishers like shotgunning.
Yeah, punish your top left.
Punisher top left.
Don't have Snippic on you yet.
Okay, got it.
I'll put him.
He's one.
Pun 1 HP.
Pun 1.
I don't have leaves.
Where's the point?
I'm summoning Luna.
I'm gonna back up.
Yeah, yeah, I'm in.
Headshot.
Okay, I'm gonna go.
Okay, I'm gonna go back.
Oh my god, I got frozen.
Cap is legit one on point.
I'm mad.
I can do it again.
I'm gonna hit three, two, three, two.
I'm with you.
We have point.
Just chill, just chill.
I can do it again soon.
I can do it again.
Three, two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna hit with you.
I'm gonna hit all.
We have Cap on backline?
Cap on backline?
I'll buy an backline a bit.
I'll buy backline.
Just chill just chill.
We come on.
You running at us, we need it up.
We're behind.
He can be paddy kicking me.
Paddy kicking me.
It's okay.
Reset reset reset.
You can ride them with man's assault.
I'll cap him.
I'll ult here.
Third left side again.
Yeah.
We're up one shrink.
We damaged.
We damaged your star.
Punisher's close.
I can't go anyway.
We use Mantis I'm gonna our place I need health still I
don't know where the I'm in.
They have no bubble I can't make main I need you we can
summon again in three I can take punch his left side punch
the left shoot the bunny I need help I need help I need help
I need help I kill the pony pony dead I'm gonna have to ult
first give me a knock walk I forced mantels I'm TPing touch
touch I can't touch I can't get touch ok good good good
Yeah, I'm not playing I'm not gonna play DD to that I just
said I was so trapped I can't play the game.
Oh, we need a patty kick more.
We play.
We just played this cop.
Yeah, we have both the portals.
Yeah, we can start with Mantis alt first.
They use Mantis.
They'll have honey, they'll have everything but Mantis
pretty much.
I'm just gonna rip it when we go in.
i'm just gonna try and stand next to my luna more just save
bubble for our um mantis soul see if they're gonna have el
soul and my goal we're i think they have we have to support
each i think it's just we're just warming this is our warm
up first game is warm up i don't know how many games there
are but first game is warm yeah just mantis mantis first
another one i am ready
That's sync up.
Everyone just has to sync up right now.
Left side, left.
Where are they?
Their main, their main.
We look for a slam whenever.
When they're sports.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Old main, old main.
Let's go.
I don't have...
I'm not trapped in.
I'm shooting the cap.
I'm hitting the cap.
Kearney, Kearney, Kearney.
All right.
I have a soft slam.
I don't know.
I alted.
I alted it.
shoot him i can push i can push him i can push him i can't
push him i can't i can't i'm pat i'm shutting top left yeah
that's good they used uh cap hole and punish trolls yep
that's good so it's on both both trance l salt both trank's
l salt my goal okay just keep playing height they're top
left they're top left yeah yeah yeah focus whoop left don't
let them off for free yeah yeah but I need help guys I'm
gonna do one I'm gonna go for him I'm gonna go for him
I dropped, I dropped, I dropped.
You dropped, you dropped.
You're gonna have to hold fine on me.
Yeah, we need to drop him, drop him, drop him.
Come here, come here, come here, come here.
I saw the other one, I saw the other one.
Funny, funny, funny, funny, funny, funny, funny.
He's one, he's one.
Yeah, yeah, he's gonna die, don't worry.
Just chill, just chill, just chill.
Shoot him back, shoot back, shoot back, turn back, turn
back, turn back.
Break it, break it.
No more, no more, no more.
No more, no more, no more, no more.
Go cap, go cap.
Nice.
Good job.
They're made.
Good comms.
Good comms, bro.
I'm playing top left again.
Setting top left.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can we try?
I think they're going to be made.
They're going to be made.
Yeah, they're going to be made.
They're going to be.
I'm running my leads recharge.
Did they?
No, he's also.
No, they did not use anything.
They used also.
Oh, they did?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, they did.
Cat's setting up height here.
Look for a hit.
I can shoot.
I dropped.
Captain, Captain are going in.
Captain's going in.
We can use, we can use Luna.
Don't be afraid.
We can flashpoint with it.
Yeah, you can use shift.
Elsa one, Elsa one.
Just stay at point.
Look, Elsa one, Elsa one.
Look Elsa, look, Elsa.
We can use, we can use.
Yeah, bubble, yeah, bubble.
Can we one card?
Can you damage?
Yeah, damage, very damaging.
Nice.
I need health.
I should look.
Nice, nice, live, live, live, save, save, live, save, live,
live, live, live, I'm me, I'm me, I'm me.
I'm, I can heal.
Look out, look out, Lael filin.
No TP,
don't trade, don't trade.
Do not trade out.
They make TP.
I can alt this if you guys want.
Oh, no.
I'm maxed, I'm exed.
Yeah, yeah, no, no.
They use both tranks.
Yeah, we have both supports.
We can just run at them with menace gold.
Listen, path's top left, yeah, yeah, path's top left.
And then we just straight run on the backline div when tanks
walk up.
Go top left guys, go top left.
And if you punny ults, we just run them over and kill them,
okay?
Just halfway.
Are we all here?
We're all here.
Yeah, I'm here.
Hold on, hold on.
I call for the ult.
Wait for our venom.
Wait for our venom and then we go.
First and pour, first and pour.
Path down.
I'm slamming height, okay?
You can go!
Pun, Pun, Pun!
Pun, Pun!
Pun!
Pun one!
Nice, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Walk this, walk this.
Four, four, four, four.
First ring point.
Look at Luna, look at Luna.
Look at Luna.
I got Kahn, I got Kahnit.
Look, I got Kahnit.
Look, he's fine, he's fine, he's fine.
He's fine, he's fine.
You guys are up.
You look Luna main, Luna's main.
Yeah, I'm gonna look the way.
You're up too.
Luna one, Luna one, he's dead.
Okay, look, look cap,
look cap, look, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, good
trap.
Good point, good point.
Good shot.
shit guys very well played sorry for the slow start we got
this see guys first round it's warm up it's warm up in my
yeah yeah funny so i'll play even they used they used okay
she's so little to me honey might have got a clip but like
it'll be like 70 she might have but our team won the round
that's all that matters we might have to kite a little bit
for no matches they're gonna run at us try to battery Luna
they're gonna run at us with Pony Mantis I think we can try
to we can kite it yeah if they if they double all this could
be hard oh yeah I want you to kite with Magal like bad just
back up and like try to kill the Pony yeah don't even like
look for obviously look for the hit but just we need to live
yeah we can shoot him and kill him through if we like Magal
him correctly yeah a word a sacrifice it's very hard a
worthy sacrifice gonna fucking send in front of him yeah get
away or just like ultimately yeah we're gonna like no yeah
Remember, they don't have CC, by the way.
They don't have CC.
They're round robins.
No, it's getting eliminated.
Let's look for, I want to look for like an early, I'm gonna
flank tap right, and I'm gonna look for like an early slam
on them.
Yeah, I like that.
I have a trap here for the Punisher.
I don't know.
He might go high or some shit.
Go on, go on.
Caps, man.
Caps all height.
Let me, play with my timing, Olive.
I'm ready whenever.
Thanks for the love.
No.
Walk in that cap on all height.
Can you, Agusa?
Ready for you to slam?
Can you slam?
Come on, come on.
Also one, also one.
Oh, I'm going to walk.
I'm going to walk.
I'm going to alt.
I'm going.
Cap point.
I don't have any more leaves.
Don't have any more leaves.
Come play.
Come back.
You can bash that.
Mag one.
Mag, mag, mag, mag.
Yeah.
Also one.
I'm on cap.
Nice.
Good.
We can kill.
Okay, listen, I'm playing the top right again.
They use both.
Wait, they use both.
They didn't eat Mantis with Punisher.
They've Mantis.
And then they can kite their Mantis with Mago.
Wait, wait.
I want to, can we slam and then get the shit out and then I
go for my ult?
Wait, putty one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a mock up.
Yeah, they're also, he's hauled looking.
He's hauled looking.
Just save your bubbles or take.
Save your bubbles.
Yep.
Help Seeky, help Seeky.
I have two of me.
I have one.
No more leaves.
No more left.
Yeah, bubble.
Nice.
I'm dead.
It's a winnable.
Winnable maybe.
No, no.
We lost.
It's good.
We can just run the move with Metis because they—they have
Metis, but we can—we can meds together.
They have Metis.
You can magl up, but we did.
You made me angry.
You want to see for also?
Yeah, or the also, I guess, yeah.
Map's moving, careful.
Let the map move.
Fures on the pine, He might be flanking or something.
Yeah, no he's main.
Yeah, whenever you slam, whenever you slam.
Yeah, crap, when you slam, I don't have leaves right now, so
you have to heal.
Mag low, Mag low, mag low, mag low, shoot Mag.
mag one, mag one.
I want HP still.
I'm hoping for him, I have to help him for him.
Walk, walk.
Fires.
It's big.
Everyone, everyone, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
That's fine.
It's not going back.
We can ask nå up now.
We can make a rego.
Help Joe.
He broke it.
Back up, back up.
Oh, I'll buy back.
Help her man.
I got him.
Elsa, Elsa, Elsa, Elsa, Elsa.
We're down one.
Winnable, winnable.
Shoot the cap.
I need heals.
I just got up.
I'm lucky.
It's fine.
I use, uh...
Mantis and Punja.
Pun Mantis, Elsa.
Pun Mantis, Pun Mantis, yeah, yeah.
And just run with the animal.
no more leaves for now I'm gonna I'm gonna combo with you
know yeah everyone slam you guys can walk I'm ready for some
yeah guys well swing swing swing okay I'm one punch one tell
i'll grab a bubble there bubble yeah no supports no supports
no supports yeah main healing mag one also one also one also
one Get TP, get TP.
I'll say that.
Also dead.
Punn, punn, punn.
I'm down.
We need TP, we need TP.
You die for him.
I'll go next up.
They're down two as well.
They just have one there.
We can build a metasol as well.
I'm 82%.
Touch, touch, touch, touch, touch, touch, touch, touch.
Nice stall.
Nice shot.
Okay, that is vulnerable.
It's just...
The DD is really, really bait, bro.
Holy shit.
Yeah, wow.
Like, I just can't play it in that mirror.
oh i went in you guys one time i went in i got double slept
i got frozen and manta slept and instantly died so yeah it
was like my bad i just can't be on dd there yeah i think i
fuck up it's all right it's just it's best of three we can
throw one game we can oh we can lower i think yeah i don't
know what the sound guys say yeah i just no we that we
played perfectly fine on the second and third we just fucked
up the first map and it made it three more sorry i fucked up
which would lower slight okay lower sticky a little bit i'm
lowering the kid a little bit uh upward all right there we
go black i definitely need more care i think yeah low key
other sound five i mean i definitely need more care because
uh javis curry is just hard diving me and i need more like
peel or pat more patty cake i think yeah okay when i had my
when i had my i was like i know he's gonna dive if i just
throw it on you because i'll heal you but he sometimes just
like out damages it yeah and you might just pass me the
snowflake yeah because during the last fight um literally i
just exploded i couldn't even didn't respond to it.
All right.
Got to do this map.
Yeah, no, Mantis, it's just a must pick.
Yeah, I see the lock-in.
That was completely my fault that first map.
Try to save a leaf.
I had a leaf.
I just literally exploded.
I forgot to pick a map.
I got the sleep out.
Did you tell, like, I legitimately exploded?
Because he got slept because that was my first response.
I want to do.
But I still just wait which one's a convoy full of the
jollia the well i have whatever you want to do i don't even
care i always have a sleep radio whenever the dive was going
but you can't do the explosion you can't hear combustion
it's the convergence i think that's why you i need like like
more patty cake i think hall is the dom because it's a
drusil path is the conversion you think hall is the our
captain's australian oh yeah sorry sorry but they were
talking about the australian debuff and we are not allowed
to change servers or uh or do balance latency because
everyone else is eu like yeah no i just i just trolled but
also this is a mix of european we trolled our first team
comp and this is european and any players they're bad i
could tell they're back i was just freezing me and whatever
i went in like on it was voted on pure democracy because we
have one guy from australia who happens to be on my team
yeah trapped double cc fucking punish me shooting my one
time it was such bullshit i got elsa trapped i forced a trap
right no i'm watching i got i got the fact that like i went
back in to kill this people from eu have only 10 more than
me like i think
Europe have just I have the sweet is Japanese curry European
or NA I swear to God if he's European he better be West
Coast bro you better be fucking West Coast I'm just running
it down okay he's NA alright he's West I swear to God if
he's European he has the same thing as me I swear to God I
don't but i don't need this moxie was on invis wait why all
right i think like they tp'd it they tp back with some all
right that's good to know because i swear to god my coffees
my coffees here my coffee and my my food uh guys this is
warm up uh we're defending we're defending what do we start
two minutes but i think they're ready
no he's australian he's literally the only person on the
asia side i'm warm now i'm warm now on the asia side played
really well i would argue that's we were so in sync on that
second map that second round no the second map was straight
flow state and uh because of that nobody cares killed the
fucking luna hole with animal no no one like everyone's just
like fuck you in particular we're going no balance lanes and
see good i was like do we really need a nerf though i was
just like guys come on guys come on it's not a rerun there's
only two variety streamers in this tournament it's me and
guys come on my chat is like is it a rerun is it a rerun
guys do you really we got that uh stream together okay you
want to do a stream together i have it i'm like i have a
panel on sunday guys come on you're not right you're right
i'm a ball and gun gamer like an hour you're so right it's
just another gun game in my ball and gun my gun ball and gun
channel no nerf them more in fact take away take away their
mouse no no these guys stream rival rivals every day these
are all like consistent rival streamers like it's like every
day is rivals i like that though i like that though i like
that though you know legit same band line by the way it was
this course comedy you're doing my dd's really bad on the
chat doing it my shooter game i'm a little wow i think it's
always during this part i don't know during band phase
waiting for him to go live i'm gonna grab my food i don't
want to wait one hour bum ass also you can do the stream
together invite and just send it in the team channel so
everyone can join who did i ban i've been rogue was that
good do you think so i've been maybe like i swear cap is
better no he's just gonna play rogue though does he play
rogue yeah ban cap no no ban cap rogue is useless unless
they proc him well they about to do that shit rope so that's
not like we just played triple tank if they do that oh i'm
sure all right there we go back one more all right okay we
have triple thing else let me know yeah yeah it's fine about
my yeah we want to ban japanese curry out how bad do we want
to ban rogue pretty badly yeah we can ban right yeah we have
more practice on the other guy or do we want to ban like I
don't know, actually.
I don't think they'll play Mantis game, but I feel like
that's greedy.
Oh, they're fucking lost in this matchup.
They don't know what to do, bro.
Beige, beige, ban rogue, just ban rogue.
You could proc Loki.
I'm not sure.
Yeah, Loki's a good proc.
I, Loki's a really good proc.
We have everything else, bro.
Or, like, do something else.
I'm just thinking.
I'm going to take a bite of my food.
Yeah, and I just ban Groot, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, proc Loki, you can just ban... you can ban whatever.
You can ban like...
Bucky so they can't play Bucky Punisher.
Or not Bucky Punisher, Bucky Elsa.
I don't know though.
I don't know why I'm...
I don't like Gambit looks like Mantis.
I think if they play Gambit Mantis, we should mirror it.
Uh, no, I think Gambit Loki is infinitely better.
Yeah, I feel Mantis Gambit's really really greedy.
okay and just feeds triple tank really badly it's just
they're gonna get their double they're gonna get mantis all
first though because look y'all trade that's what i was
thinking that was the only issue we're gonna get mantis
before we get loki i'm on thing duty man little bro is
igling little bro got kicked out of was mri mrc because he
was too young and qualified but he was too young they had to
they're like sorry bro you have to be this tall to
participate in mri i mean it's like it's it's it's okay no i
think it's mantis now because it's definitely mantis now
it's not the mag it's mantis gambit now because if you do
mantis a gambit loki go go loki will not charge us all in
time what do you who do you want me on i'm
you a little bit not great yeah i think it's thankful this
chair is for big boys and girls did not expect a chance to
be a mag all good yeah i can draw mag you want me a venom i
go yeah i'm yeah or we can if you want to play venom one of
i play both so whichever you're more comfortable one of my
dps is 14 years old guess which one it's not me but you can
hit whatever you want and just call it and it'll yeah you're
Yeah, on this comp there's nothing to die with.
As long as you don't like die in the hit, it's fine.
I care the penny mines, care the penny mines.
All right, we can play a penny.
Max win.
I can play a bit of penny.
I don't play her often, but like, she really isn't that
hard.
You just have to know where to put now.
I'm scouting top left.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll play mid.
Grab it up.
Come on.
They're on thing.
Storm, some time.
I can't hold this corner.
Chozo, Chozo.
There's a storm.
They're ramping.
They're ramping up.
Storm one.
Just back up.
Use class.
Just back.
You can slam.
They all die.
Keep walking.
Storm, storm, storm.
Storm's out.
Storm, storm.
They all die.
Emma
Emma Unlucky That's OK That's okay He's going far low He's
all with my Pun's left side Tina above above Oh That's okay
We're down with That's it We can just show We can just show
We can just show That was my bad We should go I think We
should tank Yeah you can You can slam Yeah I'm tank Go look
for GOes I'm looking Mantis, dude Hold on my trap He's when
He's on Slam I'm gonna keep it out.
I think get out.
Get out.
Just chill.
Please help left.
Help your venom.
It should be good.
I'm back now.
We have to use my card, both my cards just now.
Just stabilize.
I have to step all.
Go.
Go, go, go, go.
Let them try to do something, we'll punish them, maybe.
Look at us.
Sorry, so sorry.
We've touched, we've touched.
I love it.
We have to slam.
Maybe you out.
Help out.
I'm 88.
That's fine, I think we just lose.
We just lose.
Yeah, that's okay.
That's okay.
We just have to carry Pony.
Like, we see him going far left.
We have to watch out.
A game within a game.
I just care for the shotgun.
I have a little here.
Yeah, we should...
Can we take the hide?
Can we take hide like early?
I have a trapped upside.
Pony, Pony hide.
Just go play him.
Go play him.
There's a...
Someone to our left.
Sir, there's behind.
trap on the left just break the high break the height i can
oh whatever oh it's not children shoot him out shoot him out
he's in a tp wait put above, put him off use that vamos come
on guard come on my guard i need care i need go i'm shooting
it we have cod just chill a tpピ we'll go back in two seconds
we'll go back in two seconds i'm gonna die miss him not
Nice, mid stand run!
Kill fun, kill fun!
Fun, fun, fun!
I don't have any.
Shoot fun!
No, no, no!
Good, good.
We're up, we're up three.
Nice, kill all, kill all, kill all.
Kill the dimple, kill the, uh, we'll solo, solo.
Star Lord, please.
Star Lord, punish your Mantis, right?
Yo, take that.
Battery Gambit!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, get all Gambit all.
We have Mantis.
They don't have a trink.
We also have Elsa.
They have ammo.
That's all they have.
Don't get hit by ammo if you just Mantis all.
Oh.
All they have is emerald and untangleable.
Pony left side.
He's probably, I'm not sure he's looking for it.
Can we mark his, sorry, Pony?
No, Pony's main, Pony's main, Pony's main.
We can med solve, we need.
Look at Deadpool with me, Deadpool.
You're dead.
står, storm right, storm right.
We can just walk past the Sarps, walk forward.
Walk forward.
Yeah, walk forward, they're down one main.
You're super impossible?
We are possible.
We should, like, walk into their team, like, kill the money.
Yeah, walking, hit it, slam and back one.
Yeah, yeah, slam the back one.
Guys, look, look, look, look.
I'm a one, I'm a one, I'm a one, I'm a one.
Look at that, chill, chill, chill, chill.
Look back main, look back main, the wizards.
I don't have enough cards.
Down one, just keep punning, keep playing.
Wait, shoot him, shoot him.
We still have...
We're even on tank, we're even on tank.
Shoot the solo, shoot the solo, you're showing.
You can use Renzes, Renzes, Renzes, Renzes.
Look, look, look, don't die through, look, look, look, look,
look, look, look, look.
Look, look, look, sorry, look, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry,
sorry.
They're cutting, they're cutting.
They're cutting.
yeah yeah they use uh they used emma you cancel it he's 50
emma yeah yeah they're gonna have no he fully casted it i
think he's a zero no no he he got canceled he got canceled
yeah i'm gonna try get rid of that get rid of that They have
star.
Pwned in, Pwned in?
Oh no, he's like baiting.
I have no diamonds.
I have no diamonds, I can go for slime here soon.
I have all for star load.
Look at Emma.
You can slam, slam.
Slam!
Can you slam?
I got bursted instantly.
I traded you.
one, take the one.
Slime it back in three, two, one.
Heals.
How far?
Stop pointing if we can.
Gabiwalt.
I have cards.
We have a touch.
We have a Venomol.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Try to Venomol them.
Shoot one.
Run one.
Put that.
Care me.
I'm out.
Help me.
Just chill.
Be Giant Risa.
You can't move Silla, we'll be.
Help Taito.
We need to help Taito out.
I can't, we can't.
Risa, chill.
Head of leaves.
Chill, chill, chill.
I'm for your two here.
They use PUN.
They have Emma.
PUN and Gunn, PUN in the Gunnel.
PUN is down, put him.
PUN that supports with Emma.
They're going to have Gambit soon.
Try to battery or Mantho still put it in a red insult.
Are those birds slam?
Probably slam.
Shoot their Emma guys, shoot their Emma, shoot their Emma,
Emma!
Emma, Emma 1, Emma 1, Emma 1, Emma!
I'm good, okay.
I'm reloading, I'm here.
I'm dead.
Look, look, look, look, look.
Okay, they've got me.
We have Manta's here.
Try to get Manta's, get Manta's, get Manta's.
Okay.
I think we just died here.
Just died, just died.
Yeah, I'm just gonna die.
Good.
Nice kill.
I'm living.
You get me out?
I'm helping you.
I also won, I also won.
Still win this, baby.
Try to throw him in his bed.
He has El Sol.
We have Mets, we have Mets.
They don't have all yet.
I'm gonna put a trap on the left for the bunny.
He's just main, he's just main then.
We're gonna first slam, we're gonna start?
Just get the El Sol, he saw his El Sol.
Yeah, he did.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come at us, come at us, come at us, hit!
You carry them all, carry em all, carry them all!
They have El Sol.
Guys, kill the Embers, Inting, Embers Bounty.
Molten, I'm not in.
Temple, temple, temple.
No, Take a Pull.
I'm in, I'm over here.
I have all here.
Take a Jam singers.
Then I'm in.
The next one.
Are we in?
We need to live- we need to live this.
Reload, I have to reload, I have to reload.
I have all here.
Great gamma shield.
You're going to have to gambit.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I gambit.
And I'm bashings.
It's fine.
We see nine and someone's picked by conjuring.
Here, I'm going to swap.
I can have a pump.
that's so close no venom is carry no venom is good venom is
good yeah i just don't know what we're losing to i think
it's just it's like some like it's like their old cycle i
think it's also because you guys are taking so much damage
in neutral that me and the mantis couldn't uh couldn't
upkeep it yeah yeah i guess i don't know uh i swear but i
know i swear we're supposed but not we just see nine so i
don't know i feel like i legitimately meet i just see i have
to use my cards to heal i can't do anything else i feel like
i i have to heal i feel like if i look away if i do anything
else that's not healing they would that they would fall over
i think it's fine though They would like fall over.
No, I swear the match was fine.
I think Venom is carrying.
So when I say Venom is carrying, you're slamming the back
on, they're all falling over.
Yeah, yeah, it's like, bro, like don't press, like no one
cares about fucking, the scoreboard is like some rank shit,
bro.
Like, you slam and then they will look at you and then we
get to play the game for you.
F more?
But I was just like, bro.
Yeah, you can scout for Bro.
Wait, it's also close?
No, she's high on.
I'm going to mark you out.
Careful, Zip.
I have a trap like, middle of the length you guys.
Elsa's main, Elsa's main.
They're on Stargord now instead of.
On.
South one.
Need care, then go back in.
I pulled the...
Yeah, you can go in whatever.
And we can walk.
One in.
Three, two, one.
On back line, on back line.
Shoot.
Shoot ammo, shoot ammo, shoot ammo, shoot ammo, shoot ammo,
guys.
No diamond, no, no, no.
We'll stop left.
Where are my cards?
Yeah, you can shoot the solid a bit.
Just chill.
Help out.
That's why it's not effect.
My stolid's like feeding on me.
Yeah look look uh Emma...
I was the one.
Start top right, start top right.
No more cards right now.
Look for slam!
philosophical!
Nice, nice, nice.
Live, live though.
Live girl.
Malt dis.
Just stable, stable, live, live, live, sable, stable, stay
blue, Roo"?
Nice, going.
Go in guys.
Look at uh, sorry they're out.
They're out.
Help.
Help Zoo.
Come on, Kira.
Saw's one.
top right source one top right go main go main shoot their
support shoot their support shoot that's on game i'm going
good for you i'm on point uh you go up you can go up but
you're not dying do not die do not die don't die for that
don't die attack they're tping we can just kill the tp yep
i'm looking up wait also out true strange true strange true
strange true strange i think you're so far for me i can't
help tank one tank one out of his Come on.
Oh.
Try, reset, reset, reset.
Okay, we're just gonna move more forward in the right CP.
They might feed.
Hold on.
We have max assault that we can go in with.
I killed solid.
Nice, good go.
Help, help.
I'm close.
Come on, health.
That's good.
That's good trade.
It's good trade.
Help, help, Alan.
Help Alan.
Look, Alsa.
Alsa running it.
Alsa running it down mid.
Gambit half.
They can have solid gambit half.
We can start walking.
Look for a slant, look for a slant.
We're about here.
We get kills.
Who's going first?
Gambit, Gambit?
One, two, one.
I'm worried.
Look out, look out, look out.
Looks like he's room.
I'll see that.
I'll see that.lab behind us.
He can use.
He's going to try.
He's on his own.
Maybe winnable.
I'm lucky.
That was it.
You're ready.
Nobody's stealing Gambit's chance to win.
They used their combo.
Yeah, they used Gambit Star.
We used Gambit Bucky.
I will.
Yeah, let's get Venomol.
Maybe force them up so we can have a better roll.
You guys ready?
Yeah, I'm not there.
I'm not there.
I was not here for it.
Winning?
Yeah, you can go.
Yeah, wait, wait like five seconds.
Sorry, I have a Starlight behind me.
Okay, walk forward, walk forward, walk forward, walk
forward.
Also, else a main one.
That's the one, the old one.
Nice, nice, nice.
We can use, we can use, we can match.
We should start, shoot start, shoot start.
Walk, walk, walk.
Need to walk forward.
Help him, help him.
Change, change.
Start, start, start, start.
Everyone take full and Elsa and Elsa.
Elsa one, Elsa one, Elsa one, Elsa one.
Elsa one!
We win, we win, kill back one, kill back one.
And Wolfels thinks he's in rank, stats saving.
Kill that guy, no dashes.
He's left side, left side.
Just kept going and then we play for our die.
Oh, he used everything.
He used everything.
Bro, he's on Strange.
He's on Strange.
I think we just hit 3-1 and then kill the Strange when we
slam.
Yeah, he has all.
He, Strange has all.
Yeah, they have Strange.
That's like, that's like fake.
Fuck the Strange all.
Just like, we slam and we kill him.
I'll try to hook.
I'll help all the people.
Wait, hold on, hold on.
Let's get called.
We can just get Carmen.
Star's poking around.
Fall's one.
We need to go soon.
You can go.
You can go whenever.
I'm ready.
Oh, I got hit.
I got hit by it.
We're fine, we're fine.
He's one, he's one.
He's one, we're fine.
We're up one.
Shoot, start it.
Nice.
Elsa, Elsa, Elsa, Elsa.
Elsa dies.
Elsa won.
He dies.
I have a starlight on me.
I have a starlight.
Don't die to star.
Don't die to star one, don't die.
Get three, get three, three, three, three.
Get three on.
Yeah.
We don't have any support.
Yeah, yeah.
Get all gambit.
Take damage.
Yeah, move an arm.
So set up for hit.
Set up top.
They have all soul guys.
They have all soul.
Two, one.
Shoot the howsha.
I'm trying.
Look at them!
I got you, I got you.
Shoot them.
Shoot them, shoot them.
I pulled SAR, SAR.
Where is he?
SARHED, still.
I can't see him.
All right, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Just chill, shoot him.
93?
I do, 93 but 93.
We can use Gambit when we get maybe.
Yeah, we can wait for Venom.
Venom gets back fast too.
I thought we should just go with it when we get it.
Is that about here.
Wait for Venom, then we go.
Wait for Venom then we go.
He's back soon.
Are you back?
Yeah, yeah.
Can we go?
Yeah, you get rid of it.
Go shoot him.
Shoot him.
Pull.
I'm trying.
You're on the dumb one.
You're found.
I'm looking for a hook.
Walk.
He's so dead.
I can look at my old damage to me.
It's hard.
It's a lot.
It's big.
He also died.
Walk.
We need a walk.
Look to walk.
Shoot through.
Shoot through Emma.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma.
Live, live, live, live, live.
We even match.
Do the solid.
No vermin.
Just help her.
Help her.
Nice.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'm looking for her.
We'll take.
We'll take one.
I got hit.
Yeah, yeah.
It's me.
I'm on table.
Just chill, guys.
Just chill.
It's fine.
I punch safe one.
It looks very cool.
Okay, just chill, chill, chill, chill, chill.
Wait, also on the left?
Hold on, I'm on.
Look for, look for a pick.
Look for a pick.
15 seconds.
I'll stay though.
Venom, you have to touch.
Yeah.
I'm almost back.
I'm walking up.
We need to walk up so.
We need to walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
Also one, also one.
One HP I'm all one as well stolen as well.
There we go sir
I'm trying to I'm trying to I'm Break, break you break you
break it We have Gambit 2!
Get Gambit!
Get your Gambit!
I'm trying to get your Gambit to go.
I got him!
Help Cato!
Yeah, I have TP.
I'm walking.
I'm blocking our kills.
Stay on it, stay on it.
I had to go on it.
I'm on Gambit.
Gambit 1.
I'm on!
NT, NT.
I think we can win.
That's so close.
And so he's receding.
We got a rematch tomorrow, Sunday.
It's so close.
Yeah.
I think, all right.
We can, we can VOD that.
We win that.
It looks so easy.
Don't tell them this.
I forgot C existed until the second half.
They didn't, nobody noticed.
During VOD reviews, they're gonna notice.
Like, during VOD reviews, they're gonna notice.
Regardless of the style.
as long as you're calling your hits to us bro you're doing
well yeah i think you did fine i feel like like the stats
look bad because in that comp you can't stay in for very
long they're gonna notice in vaude reviews 27 deaths when
you slam um we just kill their front line like that's what
we're doing the entire i okay okay i have a perfectly good
excuse for this captain is always bad to the point where i
forget he existed when they support all we just i have match
there's like three two to three times where he just didn't
match and it was just bad but that's i'm just saying i will
say my excuse is that gambit is bad so many times i forgot
he existed and then i forgot about his team up because i
haven't touched his team moments i to be fair i touched his
team up yesterday but like i'm just i think so i think the
support is so strong I confess so you see to like after your
hit you just need to live that's all it's okay we can
because we can consistently keep the tempo in like because
if you're alive I mean obviously if you're alive I forgot
that's my tempo I have a perfectly good excuse I forgot
it's okay I know now I don't now I'm not It's the first
game.
It's the first game.
It's completely my fault.
First game.
Yeah, this is just our warm-up team, guys.
It's our warm.
The next, we're just gonna win all the other teams.
No, but like Ashley.
That was actually, that was actually- Yeah.
And we lost.
Because we're confessing anything.
I didn't use my C at all during the first half, guys.
I'm just confessing right now.
Oh, dear.
Just need like constant reminders.
I always forget on Luna too.
Honestly, bro, just chuck that shit down main.
actually is so op it's just yeah i've been spanned every
ranking i keep forgetting he exists sometimes yeah
especially like when we're um like the second point there
when we're at the very end of it you can just cut off that
entire choke with it it's so broken yeah that would be huge
say no i'm not even trolling bro it looks like i was magic
bullying magic bullying that's all right look i confess yeah
like last i'm gonna go to hell now for that my god for this
i would I won't go down.
And if I'm on green ping, I swanked that also, I hit the M
on my screen, I hit two.
On my screen, I hit two.
Now, not everybody in their chats are gonna be like, why
did, they didn't pick me, by the way.
I got him because I was the last person on the wheel.
Yeah, yeah.
I was like, peak.
I just happened to be the last person on the wheel.
That stall here was so bad.
I swear, he doesn't get a single kill out of his ult.
It's like, it's impossible to play.
If I didn't buck your air here, I think, I think we're fine.
Like, I should have just killed this guy.
They just saying the mistake we say.
Have you committed?
Yeah.
I don't know.
We are against.
We're against Necros.
I don't know.
Why are we against all the European teams?
We could backline.
Right off the bat.
That's about it.
Same team.
We could backline.
I wasn't picked last.
The wheel.
The wheel spun on me.
Same as trying to play as we could backline.
Respectfully.
This this drafting system was an option.
we were selling people please don't don't think too hard
about the implications um but we were selling we were
selling players and like they were spinning a wheel to see
which player is going to be bid on and coincidentally i was
the last person on the wheel so i didn't have to be bid on
at all so some people like you know i don't think my
self-worth would have handled it which thank God.
You gotta watch what I was doing on the first map.
Straight killing everybody.
No, my self-worth, my self-worth will not take this very
well if I was bid on.
Because some people, it was like $3,000.
How does she hit?
Each captain was given $3,000.
Like what?
They one shot him.
And then- Yo, one shot.
Yo, what?
Got it.
And then, uh, and then some people went from 300,000 and
other players were $1 or $20,000.
$20.
But no, I swear against this next team, by the way, because
I was the last person on the wheel.
You played him about it?
100%.
Yeah.
Oh, is Sticky still too loud?
All right, I'll lower Sticky a little bit.
I don't know if any of you guys can't hear me still.
Guys, he's passionate.
He's 14.
Let this man be passionate.
It's fine.
It's still group stage.
That, that, that, I know I keep saying it, but this is the
best.
How much was the child playing?
It was a wheel, too.
because it was yeah we got we have the least scrim
experience you know what i mean we have the least scrim
experience and it's like it was a wheel as well it was there
like every fight is closed potato really really really won
it's losing by like three fights every game it's like
whatever yeah so like that's all you have to know he was
like cheering mo mo jumps in and one tap someone we see nine
like bro like this shit is like we can iron this shit out
and take it home like 100 yeah i'm cursing tato with losses
until he hits the live button who said that bro applesauce i
knew it was him applesauce bro he's no applesauce it's five
am bro i'm gonna go live to 90 people by the way i'm going
live to five people it's you and nixon vale and wait a
minute our captain's not streaming do you know streaming was
mandatory for this tournament it was in the rules yeah i
can't believe it our captain's not even streaming it was
that i don't know majority of these tournaments are uh
require you to stream so i assume it's usually it's a
mandatory you're like please stream the tournament
because it's to add to their the view count stuff so they
can have more of these tournaments because rival is the only
the biggest reasons is that they want you to add to the view
count statistic so yeah I can't believe it our captain's
Australian Eddie bro Momo's death count between the two maps
bro Momo was running it down no he was I was on his team for
the J3 tournament that's kind of just what he does you need
to play he's play also more bro how did Craigie almost have
more deaths than Momo well okay to be fair he has a solid
team up so it's like yeah fucking run it there was like a
few times where you got res i'm surprised i i would be
yelled at if i didn't stream that's all i think you should
be able to they should you could just do that you could just
not stream if they buffed that i think that's i get the 25 i
get the beer count pass invitation which i don't know i
don't know if it's star you know what type of invitation
yeah like She fucking Bucky's legit no-scooter.
And then Blackmag needs to get, like, taken out back, like,
those types of...
Yeah, bro.
Invitations where, like, you get invited.
They slammed out, Torch?
Like, oh, and I'm like, yeah, the few count invitations.
Minus one dash, minus one grapple, minus 50% gold.
There's a word for it.
I don't remember what it's called.
Where you're invited.
Thank you to nerf Bucky's.
Yeah, no, don't say that.
No, don't say that.
It's like, you get one headshot and they fucking explode.
It's just bullet-sized.
invitation we shot like i have to see i shot the emma
they're usually really mad they're not mad i'm saying is a
take bro like that's what i was saying on the woke up see
that sounds a lot better the pretty privileged invitation
sounds a lot better just left to die man just like look at
this kill on the tank i'm gonna leave i'm gonna leave the
hard heroes to olive the the token influencer invitation
It's like, I gave it away because they- I'm gonna have to
like- I'm the token- It wasn't here that I keep tapping
tank.
Slash YouTube Marvel Rivals representation.
Your ship hit the fucking dagger right here by the way.
Nobody follow up.
Yeah.
I don't know where I keep tapping tank pool.
But I gotta find that shit because that shit has bags under
it.
Sometimes people like that.
They like it.
Like people who are sleep deprived.
You're just sure it's right here that I accidentally- Yeah,
like the sleep deprived aesthetic.
Oh yeah, sorry, I was unmuted.
You're good.
Wasn't here.
I got the info.
I didn't remember when I unmuted myself.
Gotta find the shit.
Bucky's broken.
When I unmuted myself, what did I unmuted?
Oh, he's too broken.
Oh, it was here.
It had to be here.
When I look at America's big...
No.
Simple mind.
I don't even know which ones.
He was super chat.
Thank you.
How long was I unmuted for him?
So you made it up.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
These guys are higher ranked than us.
No, I swear I didn't.
It was our last team.
It was our defense.
It's supposed to be harder.
Wait a minute.
Yeah, I swear.
I swear we can win.
We can win these fights somehow.
Yeah, we definitely can.
Like very scrappy.
We seem to be a bit more organized.
Was it here?
Yeah, it was definitely here.
Oh, wait, they're already pulling up.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
They're already in.
Cool.
No, it wasn't here.
i made it up
oh just uh i made it up i think i muted the moment i went to
grab grab mine oh yeah also i'm pretty sure he does not
streaming because he will he will dc i mean to be fair he is
200 ping i think him streaming would be a debuff right now
zo slams in it look at their whole team like honestly they
just all run and zoe that guy's just a free ass kill should
have just left earlier every single time yeah it's more like
you get the aggro and get out that's kind of your job yeah
it's just surviving that's like the that's that's the job
really because like you get a that's why i was like maybe
that's why they're letting him not to stream it's enough
like i said they would get they would get like people they
would be like please start your stream dokey bird i was like
i don't want to trade like please start your stream dokey
Because...
They're like, why do you think we invited you?
I already did!
You did?
I already did.
Nah.
See, the higher the ping, if they can't...
If he can't hit shit, they can't hit him.
That's the trade-off.
Token influencer.
Why aren't you...
Yeah, why don't Bucky O'Air?
That would have been way better.
Yeah, we did.
ship hit the dagger i wanted to i tried to pull him so he
wouldn't i'm happy to be here yeah i mean i was trying to
poop i'm so i'm i'm just happy to be getting no craggie's
head is like a magnet he just got shot and dead oh wait
actually getting slimed out bro let me see his screen like
he's just he's shooting he's shooting where'd he go where'd
he go so far we look we shot the same tato we were like
shooting the same shit yeah we're doing good like that's
what i'm saying that's the hardest that's the hardest that
that's a very hard team and it's very close and like bro
we're gonna pick and we're gonna roll these guys right guys
all right yeah we're gonna we're gonna pick and we're gonna
slow down all right sorry guys uh yeah i worked message let
me say how to
work message done and be productive.
Boop.
Copy and paste that Japanese message to my translator.
Tato went live.
We don't know Nihongo.
I only did.
Me no Nauru Hodo Nihongo.
Alright.
It's okay.
They're gonna have a venom player.
It's definitely the highest ranked backline.
They have both been like a pro Mufels and Kath.
Kath was in ignite woofos is a uh he did really well in mrc
multiple times and almost made ignite so they basically just
have two pairs on their backline though all right that is
probably not yeah i know who naru ho don't is the highest
rank practically but i think my backline's better i don't
think he realizes he's unmuted it's okay me too that is
that's the hard part about being a streamer hot mic i'm back
on your dude talk my hot mic is the word is the hardest part
all right wait let me let me close your stream uh sick you
yeah okay so we're playing for gambit right we want yeah we
can we can play for whatever i think yeah we should ban cat
first i don't want to play against cat yeah play for gambit
yeah play play elsa i want to play for elsa triple tank i'm
gonna proc elsa first i'm gonna chill i don't know because
like he's gonna play dd how many plays dd i want us to be
able to peel that with like an elsa i want to play thing
thing rogue mag is a good comp against dd yeah 100 we want
to try to play for rogue do they have any good rogue players
um they aren't that i know okay this is the best part of
being the lowest ranked well technically i'm not even the
lowest you see like the lowest rate players we just listen i
don't have to use my brain for see them play it either so we
can't be the worst part is that my brain also needs to
remember it to i'm on uh we're not playing about how they
can ban it pretty sure after you should ban it low key and
play yeah play that when we when the game starts i think i
don't think they'll ban mag i don't think they're smart you
need i don't know not smart enough to participate in this
that knows about that by the way yeah i played and ranked
with him it's the only way he would He definitely called
that shit.
I gotta look back to Javad 100% called that.
Nixon Vale is in chat saying my draft is brain dead.
Sorry, Nixon Vale.
Getting scrims is brain dead.
This time I will know how to press C, guys.
This time.
I swear he's just purposely sabotaging us.
Bro, I just explode so fucking fast.
Like, I cannot.
I think, like, if we have to face a gambit, Mantis Mirror
with a Star Lord, I can't mirror the gambit all.
I'll just fucking explode.
I don't think I'm going to be playing a whole lot of
memories, but we'll see.
Yo.
Like, the numbers on their DPS, how did Momo have that?
Literally.
Casualties protect.
I don't even know how I can survive that.
Holy shit, that's max win.
12 deaths.
15 die.
I'm going to get cough drops.
Like, I swear, I swear, I literally just...
50% of them was just one tap.
then blows up well it's only if there's a mirror there's a
mirror i'll bring up i'll be like hey there's a gambit star
lord mantis mirror i really think man we should mantis first
over the gambit star lord because i will explode all right
you're gonna witness human combustion again
I feel like that's been the pattern.
I just explode every time.
It's just the way it is.
If we want, like, I don't know if that's brain dead or not.
If they're going to ban it, I think it's fine.
I don't know if other teams are going to pick up on that.
I mean, what else are they going to ban?
Yeah.
Name my one trick.
I think that's fake, bro.
I think every time I've died, it's so fake.
It's through human control.
These people don't know what they're talking about, bro.
Play rogue thing, mag, and they can't dive up.
Also, where is it?
Impossible, I think.
I think.
I'm banning the Black Hat character, right?
I mean, yeah, let's do it for her.
Oh, yeah, never mind.
I was going to say, are we allowed to have coaches in with
us?
Someone in my chat said the Pinoos chat's like a war zone
right now.
Cheepa.
Why?
They did ban your elves first.
Oh, shit.
do exactly what we're gonna do are people already crashing
out because that's what's going on all right you got that
gamble dokey no that's right yeah yeah yeah i remember the c
button this time it just takes one it takes one round every
time it's just one round so we're gonna play bucky triple
tank because that was just banned yeah
that's all it takes it's that one round where i just have to
remember for sure it's weakened yeah i know yeah it's like
you know what i just realized bro black widow was open holy
bro you're forgetting that black widow is in the game bro i
swear i don't know bro she doesn't exist in my brain half
the time like i just forget she's a playable character
everyone forgets about that character well so i think it
might have been rogue protect on the last one yeah maybe a
rogue protect if they've been mag it's perfectly fine i'll
just play like strange because it's even better okay this is
a rogue protect for sure if they're doing i'm ready we
brought rogue oh and then are we okay with a strange band we
can't portal but i kind of wait wait why why would you be a
strange i don't know i like strange bands if we have like a
faster comp we can always get back faster but Just just for
the sake of it.
Just because I hate that kid.
I'm gonna ban that guy just bad him Strange if you want like
straight Didi no?
Didi?
Yeah, didi.
Yeah, it's like I just like strange.
Strange over.
Yeah, no, but I think that guy in particular, but I swear it
should be fine with our cult Wolverine.
Wow, okay No, fuck my Wolverine.
Pick your hero.
Shit.
We go like, um,
are the reasons i just hate him
i just fucking hate him that's my reason you can sit
wherever yeah you can sit wherever and just jump to them
broken fuel as well and then our mags gonna walk around the
map and fucking kill people with me this is like the shit
main heal dude there you go i don't know how Let's just say.
Easy scop, damn.
Alright.
Let's go!
Type shit!
Okay, um, we should probably just go height and fight them
on the height, and then I think like, we need to like poke
out the magic and shit on the top right.
Oh, I mean, we can just sit there and wait for them to hit.
Yeah, We could just sit there, grab the magic, kill the
magic.
Are you on Gambit Team Up or Mag Team Up?
Which is probably what we're just doing.
I'm on Gambit.
Alright, Gambit.
Battle Scouts in 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Alright.
You can just land yourself if you think you're gonna die.
Whatever the magic goes in, just peel that.
Yeah, and use your Gambit Team Up and just sit in it in the
magic corner.
I'll use my Team Up first.
And then if you have to, we'll use...
Just go main, go main and just take...
Hey, you guys go main, you guys.
Go main, go main.
Yeah, I'm just walking high to match Madrid.
They might be TPing.
Yeah, they're TPing.
It's on our high.
We can go point.
We baited them on accident.
No point.
Or back up the point.
Shoot through Dino.
Make their wall card.
Change one.
Rage.
Dino's on.
They're gonna have heal pulls.
I have no cards.
Just shoot.
Keep shooting Dino in the face.
We can lay up when they show up the wall.
Can I put out?
He's waiting for me to come.
He lived now.
Let's live now, let's live now, live now.
Sure, sure.
Shoot the shovel.
Oh my gosh.
Shoot the magic.
Yeah, I don't have any cards.
It's alright.
It's fine.
We got...
We got 25 point anyway.
It's fine.
Gambit coming back from all.
I swear you shoot the magic, little game.
Yeah.
I have many faces.
Don't let this guy play.
They're top left.
Walk them out top left.
Walk them out.
So Tate, the Bing slam lasts so long you just do it when
they're engaging like that.
Just in the middle of their back arm.
Someone's close to last.
Someone's like follow.
Here, their magic might go into.
Shoot them down.
I'm gonna drop.
Alright.
Walking forward.
Just walking.
Dropping.
Here's their magic going into.
They're just sitting main.
We spawned my Gambitle.
Yeah, yeah.
Can we shoot Sopo?
I'm doing that.
I put my seed in.
Shooting him.
He's on.
He's on, he's on.
Live, live, live, live.
I'm grabbing Sopo.
Kill Sopo, Sopo, Sopo, Sopo, Sopo, Sopo, Sopo, Sopo, Sopo,
Sopo.
Dino, Dino, Dino, Dino, Dino, just kill the Dino, kill the
Dino.
Dino copy.
Yeah, I'm here.
We need it.
I'm Gamba after this.
You need a Gamba.
I got it, I got it, I did it, I did it.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
I might be dead here, I'm dead here.
You only have low-key heals.
Hit that one, hit that one, hit that one, hit that one.
You're getting chased by magic, chase by magic.
Magic AF.
Just live, live, live.
Live, zo, live, zo, live, live, back up, back up, back up.
I'm coming back now.
Take TP, take TP.
That's okay.
Do you both support all three on both sides right or no?
I'm at left side.
I'm playing off of those TP.
I'm playing off his TP.
I'm supposed to get in all.
There's something he's getting on.
He's getting on.
He has it.
Any heals?
Do you touch with TP?
Yeah, yeah.
Touch with TP.
We can get, we can land.
I'm cat.
I need help.
Just loot a point.
No, no, no, no, no.
Only Loki heals.
Any, any care on point possible?
Yeah, I can't.
That's fine.
Okay, swap our comp.
Triple tank's not working.
Yeah.
Oh, but we were on triple tank.
I didn't even know it.
Yeah.
Well, I swear I seen another gun, bro.
No, I dropped down a hole in purpose because I knew I was
going to get fucking combusted.
If Elsa was open, this would work because we would have...
Yeah, whatever.
But fuck has happened a lot of stuff.
I think Rogue is really good here.
That's why your damage was so low.
I was like, nothing is fucking dying.
But no, I dropped in the hole on purpose because I was like,
if I'm in the hole, they don't know where I am.
The moment I ulted, like, everyone ran straight at me.
I did press C.
I pressed C multiple times.
I just saw like 20 people run at me.
I think like 30 people showed up.
from the sidelines i think it's good and then i was just
like goodbye
try to you have to try to peel those as much as possible as
well just their magic i'm just gonna save c for no tp no tp
tp take it Knap, knap, knap.
Careful.
Koppy Mac.
Oh, yeah, he was not living that.
Go point, go point.
Go point, go point, keep running.
They're just gonna fall for his.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna put the C in here.
Dino's already one each free.
Dino's one each be on point.
Dino's one and she's one.
She's still one.
Dino's still one, Dino's still one.
Magic present.
Magic one.
Down there, right?
They have a death hope.
They have, lose it up.
I need care, heavy- bald.
I'm trying to, I'm trying to.
I quit and do anything about it.
No, that's my fault.
Oh, that's okay.
Get out, Zo.
Get out.
Oh,
you're running!
Triple.
They're set up top.
They're set up top left.
They're trying to get support.
They're all here, all here.
I got crammed.
Get the magic.
Yeah, I got some.
Evo, Evo, it's big, it's big, let's support it.
We live, we live, we live.
I can't do yours, but Popo's running it down on me.
Shoot the shot pool, shoot the shot pool.
I don't know if I can save, I got hit.
Yeah, I don't know.
I'm supposed to be doing this.
I do what I love here.
Bro, like, they're just like full 1 million HP, bro.
I'm picking Ella and I'm shooting their dynamo.
Yeah, I swear to ass, but like, they just 11 million HP.
Come on, like, win when they jump in.
They're top left, they're top left.
Yeah, they're all set up top left.
I can get all here.
I'm just waiting for everybody.
I'm waiting for Sticky.
You should walk up first.
That's ridiculous.
Okay, you can go.
Three, two, one.
Gamma one, Gamma one.
He's one.
They're a canvas one.
Oh, chasing him.
That one.
Oh, my.
I got it.
We're not suckers, no supports.
Look, you went a ball.
Oh, magic kills, so look, look, look, look.
Mago, their Dano's won.
She's their Nano.
Nano one, Nano, from the Blue её.
Nano actually won.
We're here.
Supports are here.
That's it.
Look, stop fool, stop fool.
Support pool is gonna have what's again.
She's Nano, Nano, Nano!
We have, we have Match exercise.
This one.
Shoots are on
Good can't get us all you have it I messed up I don't want I
no one help me help me help me someone touch yeah I'm
getting on but that's the most I can get on we or TP wait
for everyone She's low.
She's low.
I'm chill.
Can I chill?
I have one.
Yeah, we could be.
I got him.
Look!
Look, like, look, Luna.
Look, Luna.
Look at that.
Magic one, magic one.
Magic one, magic one on point.
Double one.
Double one, double one, double one, double.
Look at magic.
We're chasing it.
Kirby behind.
Hey, Gambit, yeah.
Um, they're gonna have...
They're gonna have Gambit, Mara, soon.
Made to battery off Gambit all.
Go take damage.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just stand here, take damage.
They don't have a lot of foes, but...
They're TP.
They might be TP.
They're...
No, they're walking.
No, they're walking tall.
I want to match top level.
No, we care.
Taking some damage right now.
I don't know if I can grab ult sometimes.
Olive, you can take damage, top level.
We're gonna have Gamble.
93.
No, they have Diamond.
They're gonna get Supple.
Take damage.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We need it.
We need to get it.
Go with it.
Supple.
Supple, Supple, Supple.
Oh,
I couldn't help you.
I'm dead here.
I was like, we're not gonna try it out like that.
Nah, that one was brain dead.
Yeah, that is... that's a dupe for gum.
I mean, like, every fight he has, a support pool is crazy.
Yes, it's okay, guys.
It's just... it's just seeing me.
You see it.
It's okay.
They're showing us all the strats for Sunday.
Yeah, wait, actually.
Wait, no, wait, actually.
Actually, they have a support pool strat.
They're just showing every strat they can.
And we're just sandbagging so they can't copy us.
It's not coping.
We're not...
We're just not revealing our strats, guys.
It's fine.
What do you guys want to play for next map?
Yeah, think of the positive.
We're just...
I'm thinking.
Yeah, no.
The last place is not the easier matchup.
I don't think we're good at Gambit.
Not necessarily just you.
Our team isn't good at Gambit.
We're just not... I don't think we're like...
Do you want a bad night?
I don't know.
I just don't think we're practiced on Gambit.
It's not even the hero.
just us like as a team as a core so i think we could try to
ban gambit they just have they just have an infinite cycle
of things to run out of us with you know what i mean yeah
you know actually i think the biggest problem was the
support the support pool i mean it's the strat they have so
yeah i mean they actually are revealing their strats so
you're saying i suck
And play like a normal 2-2-2 Gap.
I swear they...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think that's true.
I think just banned Gambit.
It's okay.
He's 14.
Get off triple support.
Get them off triple support.
It's 14.
I'll destroy him when he's 18.
It's like too oppressive.
I'll wait.
I can't do...
Guys, guys, he's 14, guys.
well map we can go hold jolly again i think that's good yeah
i'm fighting yeah always always a good map for us we like we
like double gun and guns are really good on that on the
jolly also this team plays dino and
guns are really good against dino and the map is like really
bad for dino so we're sorry it's okay guys we'll just we'll
but I'll wait drops the Google document I'm joking I'm just
it's all just the joke it's all just the joke I'm just
fucking around that should be what we go for I think we
don't like see that's the problem with the only problem with
us if we don't really have an identity for what comp we like
to play because we didn't scream a lot so agreed no I think
I from tweet four years from now you remember that train
it's like it's just so much brain that guy he's 18.
run at them hold left click yeah yeah bro i'll destroy him
when he's 18.
that's when he's legal because then it looks like i'm
bullying a child i but when i'm bullying a legal adult it's
fine because bullying a child makes me look really bad but
when he's 18 it will look less bad you're still good to
start i won't be long i bet you made it worse it's all good
at least this is like the i mean this is basically scrims if
you think about it this is basically just scrims We're
getting our practice in.
We're doing.
You too.
Real deals on Sunday?
Yeah.
We can practice.
We can, like, get our heroes in tune for that, like, what
heroes we need to play.
Figure it out.
He's not wrong.
I think for me, it's a lot of bucky.
Can't wait.
It's okay.
Today's just warm-up day.
I'm surprised.
It's like, well, I mean, this way.
but more practice at least we get to play more i mean at
least we get to um practice more later but still so this is
a long tournament this is a very long tournament i was not
ready for how long this tournament is i i i opened up my
schedule for it though i think team cohesion we just need I
think that's really it.
I'm just here, I'm just here to have a good time.
Obviously, like, we all want to win, but you some, I've done
so many of these tournaments, I, I don't know so many of
these tournaments, so it's more like, I'm back.
Which hero do you think?
Uh, you get the one.
You win some, you lose some, you know?
I think we keep the black cat ban um DD on this map is kind
of mid we can do whatever if we want to ban that if we want
to leave it open there's a lot about the experience and free
money if they proc gambit first we're banning we're banning
support pool by the way so I think we ban black cat and then
if they proc gambit we can ban support pool and get that
bullshit out they're doing all their strats now too we don't
even know what the fuck our strat is Yeah, I'm not wasting a
ban on that one.
And to be perfectly honest, we don't even know what our
strat is, but they're showing all their cards.
We'll figure out our cards soon, guys.
They're like, it was a poker game and we came back.
We came over with Uno.
We showed up with Uno cards.
All right, Van Supportful, I guess.
I don't want to play against that.
It's bullshit.
Well.
We don't even know what our cops are.
They can't, they can't like predict our, they can't predict
our strats if we don't know our strats.
Proc.
Whatever I mean.
I'm gonna play Hella.
I'm hiring a scrim for in anticipation for us.
Yeah.
Fuck with the Bucky Brock.
Mm-hmm.
I could ban Adam as well.
Well, yeah, I don't think...
I don't know.
I don't think they're going to play DD.
Is that...
Yes.
We have a 14-year-old on our team.
But he is...
One above all, 14-year-olds.
DD is...
Well, Elsa's not in the game, so it is possible to play DD
Venom.
I mean...
I think I'm the only one with the least amount of Scrim
experience.
I swear, if you leave DD Venom open, they're all going to
play that.
players like trial for teams and scrim all the time if they
play spider-man i just have rank experience which isn't
great we can play yeah mantis hella um we could do what's
open let's see we can just play dive back i can stall one
well i mean solid bash that's how it token influencer
reporting for duty and we just you play like you know how
you were playing elsa yesterday in our Yig's path game, you
just play Bucky like you're playing Elsa and we just uh, it
meet.
I'm having fun.
I am.
Just walk around.
I am having fun.
Walk around to kill everybody.
I love walking around and killing everybody.
Sunday is where it actually matters.
Oh, it's here again.
Oh, we're just doing the same maps over and over and over
and over and over again.
That's fine.
Dealing some serious damage.
No one escapes the inevitable.
but i don't care i don't care pretty much i'm going to go
right side to those i'm not risking it it's like an advanced
lineup it's on the right but yeah that wasn't i just saw
those flying in i was like oh shit all right i'm playing top
left you don't just be all right they're on magic i think
they're on venom venom on me venom on me can i help Um,
you're streaming too far, yeah, yeah.
I got you, I got you.
Managing them.
There's a magic under.
Yeah, they're below us, they're below us all of them.
Is it all of them?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got the whole, you got the whole of it.
I'm sticking, I'm sticking mid.
Nice, we can walk a bit guys.
We can walk.
No cards.
Shoot the gambit on the right.
Okay, I'm going.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You can swing my map.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I got you.
Three, two… Mantis ISO'd.
Conterre No, they had a DPS.
You'll be fine.
All right, I'm just ivan.
I'm over for Kiki cards.
Yeah, random should have come south left.
I'm not up there, by the way.
They have a DPS fortune.
Magic, smash it.
Magic left side, magic left side.
On you, sweetheart.
перв, shoot Platymed out.
Like, shoot venom out, shoot venom out, shoot venom, venom!
Okay, okay, okay.
Venom out, venom.
He died.
He dies, he died.
Semic, man.
Three, three, three, three.
Oh, he's dead, death.
He's one, he's one, he's one, he's one.
Yeah, I don't have any...
You can win still.
I'm gonna TP.
Just live, just live.
I live, I live, I live, I live, I live, I live in touch, I
live in touch.
I have, I have a crit.
Just play back, play back, play back, kill him, kill him,
kill him, kill him, kill him, kill him, kill him, kill him,
kill him.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, magic, magic,
magic, magic.
I'm all here, I'm all here.
Mantis, Mantis, yeah, yeah, okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Venom, Venom, I'm on Venom.
Oh, they want to pause.
I have a mantis.
Someone DC'd?
Shouldn't...
Shouldn't it be the...
We don't have admin?
I'm just gonna...
Okay.
Pause the game.
Jesus Christ, they're like screaming.
I think the admin is AFK.
I mean, we have to keep playing if they're not.
I'm pausing.
We're requesting pauses.
Pause.
Oh, do we have to replay this?
No, we don't.
Well, I don't think it doesn't matter.
Oh, Gamma Gamma.
We even...
Oh, kill the Gamma.
Go kill him.
He's on you.
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait.
So what if we kill that Gambit?
What do you guys think?
Okay.
Well, I have cars to cleanse.
I was mid kill.
What's going on?
I bubbled down.
Like...
like the game crash oh someone's game crashed it's not like
the admins game crashed or something no no apparently jimbo
okay well this is necrosis the new host yeah like necrosis
though this guy this guy's got guang guang permission to be
the envy reps legit i wonder if the admins just watching
youtube on the side i'm i can click confirm we all good yeah
yeah kill that gambit He has, that's his last dash in his
red.
Can I get them, man?
Can you fly on this guy?
Wait, who's the, oh, it's Lubu, okay.
I don't know if I live this.
You guys need a hardcore play to live, okay?
I don't know if I live this, so we'll see.
I'm...
Can you dash height?
You have a dash?
Yeah, I do, I do so.
Can you dash to like top, you know what I mean?
Not on there, so like, all top and then you can kill the
Gambit.
He's gonna be on our bottom, okay?
Okay.
No, no, no, we'll kill this guy, I think.
I think Necro is supposed to confirm it.
We're already.
host i think he's discussing strats right now with his team
like okay the admin also dc what how did he dc what i bet
you he didn't realize and then he instantly alt f4 and be
like yeah i crashed guys i he's as an excuse bro yeah yeah
oh my god guys i can't believe i crashed oh my no crash he's
like he's starting soon oh nv refs max win but what they
have met so where's my crosshair at everyone give one give
one give one give it to the game spin nice all right we have
one all right wait we have everyone shut up shut up shut up
they met so Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We don't have anything to do.
I'm saving my C for the dive.
I don't know if we live Animal try to force Mantis and then
we kite with mag and we just live.
Okay, I'll hit when she gets up here And remember your team
up your gamut team up.
Hey, I'm just waiting for I'll use I hope I'll use I hooked
too.
I hooked too I'm behind I used I'm stepping out.
I'm stepping out.
Oh I'm dead though.
I'm dead to this.
We used I use C and my all my cards for it Everyone give one
come on, you don't have this one this one.
This is one.
Same point same point Go faster.
Oh, we don't have we don't have we don't have yeah.
So fast characters Magic one.
Magic one.
Okay, I'm done.
I'm all right now I'm on it.
I'm dead.
I couldn't get it I couldn't Yeah.
I'm going back as well.
No, my God.
They just, when they're not all immortal, this is so hard.
No, no, no, Hulk is good.
Hulk is good.
I want you to stay home.
Yeah.
Let me know when they go in.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna go out of all of them.
You don't you don't have to go in there bylaws.
I can just get Sal.
Insta win the game.
Oh, like their support is lagging.
I'm going left side.
What are their support?
They're bad just lagging.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, it's fine.
For the flowers?arle.
Bye.
No, shoot the venom.
Shoot the venom.
I'm high, I don't know.
Shoot Zach.
Oh, my.
That one's high.
They might need to just hand me.
Do you bubble, we're back?
Do you bubble for him?
Yeah, there's nothing we can do there.
Die point, die point, stop point, stop point, stop point.
It's a really good saw.
Yeah, saw me out.
Runzo.
Help, help, help, help, help.
Yeah, you can kill the one.
I need a saw.
Get my one, get one, get one.
Get one.
Venom on hide.
I can go.
I can fuck out the Venom on hide.
Venom above, Venom above.
They're gonna hit early.
Do you bubble?
You ready?
I'm glad he's inside.
He's inside.
Kill him out.
I can use all my cards.
I use all my cards here.
I'm melting.
I'm melting this.
I'm- I'm- I'm- I'm- I'm- I got exploded.
I need help.
Can you stay fine?
I can't- I can't- I'm trying to help you.
I'm trying to help you.
I'm going to explode in.
I've got it.
Cabot's on the left.
No cooldowns.
Mantis one Mantis one Mantis Mantis Look side look side side
side side Can we go back?
Cool, you know what I have They have Mantis over here Look
at me look at me You kill that guy nice good kill All right,
pick and all just chase me around in full fight bro Use both
drinks again.
Yeah, I'm just gonna silo now.
What about I'm gonna mock the venom left.
I'm mocking venom left I think they have Mantis.
They do they do.
We have to use We can kill three or we can combo.
If we combo we can kill.
That was for sure.
They're walking top, they're walking top.
Just punch her.
Can you give me that one?
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna go in a sec.
You have it.
Don't worry, don't worry.
Just use it.
Use everything.
Can we stop one?
Yeah.
I'm on point.
I'm too slow.
We had to just die there.
Can you TP me at this?
Or Raylan?
Ready?
Okay.
Someone else...
I don't think we can make it.
Yeah, just reset.
Just reset.
We don't make it there.
He's everything.
I feel like going back now if you want.
Uh, Hulk is like...
You seen a bubble or a backlight from the ZPS pull hit?
And then Hulk is really good, I think.
You have to bubble when he's about to dash onto them.
Because if you steal his dash, he's just dead.
He's one!
Yeah, I'll give you.
They bubbled.
Dammit's up there as well.
Venom ult, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, get out of
here.
I cleanse it, I cleanse it.
Shoot him, shoot him, shoot him, shoot him, shoot him, shoot
him, shoot him.
I didn't help me, I didn't help me.
I'm helping, I'm here, I got you, I got you, I got you.
Yeah, mag bank, turn mag, turn mag, turn mag, turn mag, turn
mag, mag, mag, mag, we're on mag.
We're on mag, we're on mag.
We're on, I killed, I killed him, I killed him, I killed
him, I killed one.
Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom.
I used my cards, I used my cards.
Venom, legit, Venom legit, legit, one HP.
dead dead dead i suned three i sent three those are already
sari that's dead he's out he's out look uh he's on taple
he's 77 I'm 77.
they're gonna have gap they might get a gamble first help
her help her serve help me I'm good i'm good I'm good i'm
good 84.
they have Sao he như like saka we need to get them nice kill
nice kill you do it battle anti-fi anti-fi One.
Gamma thud.
Mantis thud.
I have to reload.
I have ult here.
The magic.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You want all for this?
Sorry, I'll be your better.
Keep your banner up.
Just mantis ult first.
Oh, I meant us all first.
Yeah, mantis our first.
You're down.
Oh, we need.
Let's give you...
Do not go with you.
Yeah.
We save the whole trouble.
Give me a kill.
We can use it.
Yes.
It's the magic.
I'm gonna help you all of this.
We can get rid of all of you need down.
I'm gonna be alting now.
I'm going back line.
They're below.
They use everything here.
Magic.
It's been low key fine.
We just moved dialogue all off there.
We don't want it.
Using everything.
Yeah, they used everything.
Both support all.
They literally used everything.
They used both supports mag.
Magic.
Okay, don't stagger.
We're just gonna go with Shiloh on their backlight.
They reduce our side.
With our Venomate.
We all just put it right side.
Everybody come right side.
Everyone come right side.
I'm gonna protect my backlight so they don't die.
I spawn last.
All right.
Just get set up, set up.
We just walk right.
Come with me, Joe.
Come with me.
I'm coming, man.
Going in three.
You do Shiloh backlight too?
Yeah, I'm on.
They both, they die.
They die.
They're both on, they're both on, they're both on, they're
both on.
They both on, they're both on.
They both died.
Lusable, Lusable, Lusable, Lusable.
You're up one.
Sank pull one, Sank pull one.
Sank pull one.
Mag half, Mag half.
Gambit one, Gambit one.
No, no, no, no.
Magic, good point.
Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag one.
Ben, Venom, no, no.
Venom, Venom, Venom.
They're TPing, they're TPing.
Nice.
A little bit late on the...
On the E.
Okay, what we're gonna do is...
Zo, you're gonna keep protecting our back line.
Do a 4-2 split.
Me and Olive go top right.
And then all of you go left side.
I'm so scared every time.
Every time I ult, I'm like, fear.
Every time I ult, I feel like I'm going to have 10 cars
coming.
Who wants to do the penny lineups?
I'm going to be fast and furious, but I don't have a car.
You got it.
I don't know them.
So, Tate, do you know the penny lineup?
I'd be like, every time.
I was like, am I going to get ran up by 100 cars?
Like, you guys notice I keep fucking running away now every
time I ult.
I was like, I don't want to be here anymore.
I don't want to.
Yeah, I'm alerting the horde every time.
So all of you go left out.
And then me and Olive go top right.
Wait, they went off.
They got set off.
They didn't kill anyone, though.
Okay, I was like, bye.
Can someone go rocket and give me a jump pack?
Can you go rock and give me a jump out?
Fast.
And if it doesn't, I will clean these dudes.
It should be enough time.
It takes 10 seconds.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, two, one.
All right, here we go.
Me and Olive go top, bro.
You guys go far left side.
All right.
Uh, Deadpool's up, Karen.
What do you?
I have no bird, though.
I have to play really slow.
Magic up here.
Yeah, I'm shooting.
I'm okay.
I don't have to get poked out.
The magic's okay.
Yeah, magic's okay too.
I have to grab health back.
I'm gonna go back though.
Oh my god, you guys died.
You guys got deleted.
Wow.
Shoot at him, shoot at him.
Get out, get out, get out, get out.
I got him stumbling here.
Take out.
Hey, though, you can go tough, right?
I'm gonna go main.
All right, here we go again.
I think it's too far.
I think we just get poked out because they can heal them up
there and we can't get healed.
Yeah.
Let's go main if we want.
Just go main.
Mantis is their height.
Do you try to slam the mantis?
Yeah.
I'm gonna slam the mantis.
I'm looking at this.
They're looking to hit first.
Venom's gonna hit.
Venom's.
He's anti.
He's one.
Oh, wow.
Oh, we're even right now.
I'm gonna have to get out.
We should stay full, take one nice, nice, nice.
Shoot her back line, shoot her back line.
Shoot mag, or shoot the magic in the mag.
Magic in the mag.
Oh, I need to reload on your...
Venom.
Venom dive.
Magic in as well.
Magic in.
Oh.
I got, we got matching, we got magic.
Great, great, great.
They only have Gambit heals.
I can summon three.
Can you slam?
I have 80?
Yeah, I'm summoning, summoning, summoning.
Walk, walk, walk, walk.
Mantis one, nice supports.
I'll do reload.
I got you, I got you.
I have cards here.
I'm just going to wait.
I'm not using cards yet.
I'm saying wrong.
I have hello.
You should be fine.
You should stall it.
I have all.
Okay.
You can use.
They meant it.
Shoot the mantis.
Outside, inside.
Mantis, mantis, mantis, mantis.
We got клava.
Mantbolt Realty.
I got slammed.
Mantis dead.
We still have Mantis up.
They want to engage.
Okay, yeah, they've got...
Whoops.
No commas.
Shoot poem, we need to shoot tank pooe.
Tank pooe, tank pooe, tank pooe.
Tank pooe, one.
Tank pooe, one HP, one HP main.
One HP main.
I'm here.
Okay, Taito, I think you're muted, Taito.
Well, they have four tanks.
Yeah.
No, one was for TP.
They were on triple and TP.
Yeah, it was TP.
Dude, do you guys hear Taito?
No, I'm not.
No, I haven't.
I haven't.
Sorry, I was just like...
I think he was hard locked.
Wait, was I?
I'm pretty...
Yeah.
You might have been.
I didn't...
I didn't press my buzzer though.
Can you damage just be right side?
I have a free ult.
Can we just push good ult?
Can we just push caught and then go with my ult?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Push car.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Their gambit's top right.
Okay, are we ready?
I'm gonna go in a sec.
Give me damages.
You ready?
Yeah, yeah.
Three, two, one.
They're in temple now.
Gambit, Gambit, Gambit, Gambit, Gambit.
Gambit, Gambit, Gambit.
The old guy just killed the point.
Where did the Venom go?
I'm slept.
I'm trying to come over to help you.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
Yeah, kill those guys.
Yeah, I came back.
Just get on point.
3 on, 3 on, 3 on, 3 on, 3 on, 3 on.
We just go with all Venom now.
Venomals, because they don't have support also.
So we just Venomals, okay?
I'm staging top left.
There's a venom on me.
I'm poking him out.
Yumi, Shirking.
There's a side too.
I'm swimming there, man.
Two, gov-v-v-v.
Shirvin.
Shirvin, shoot me.
Buddy, I'm going to go.
I'm going to go.
Scimmy third, Gamba third.
Mawking, Waking Mementos one, Mementos one.
Scimmy one, Sivvy shield, Schuete.
Just carry Deadpool.
Shoot him.
Shoot back first.
Back, back first.
I need help.
I need your HP.
I got your HP.
Yeah, we got you guys.
Not die here.
Not die.
Deadpool 1!
Deadpool's 1!
We won.
Good job.
I have ult soon.
They're gonna have gamble first, Mimi.
Yeah, they'll have this.
They'll have this.
What do they have?
They're bucking out.
That's better.
Bucking shell lock.
Okay, just get three on.
Just chill.
I'm holding top right.
Oh, when they're here, I can take an angle with you.
I can hold top right.
Can you hit someone top right?
Just keep pushing cards.
Fine.
They have to push into us.
Yeah, yeah.
Just lurk there.
There's two on height.
Yeah, I'm ready.
There's a mag on me.
There's a mag on me on height.
You guys can kill me.
You okay.
I need courage.
I'm out of map.
Map's good.
All right.
Just chill.
Just chill guys.
Yeah, I have to use my...
I have all here.
Do you want to use it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Holy shit.
I'm just gonna go trade.
Just go trade.
Go trade.
I'm on meds this one.
It's okay.
You guys exploded.
So hard.
It's bad timing.
You shy.
They're ready for Rogue to be a widow.
I don't think so.
Okay.
They still have, I think we should walk in with Mantis or
Ikea.
Yeah, they're back at two.
Maybe Sticky just flanked.
Maybe, play for Sticky's or help Sticky's or...
Yeah, I don't think we, I don't think we meant to swing
gauge.
We don't have another.
They're not playing on height.
Okay, okay.
Can you slam back on two?
Hooking, hooking, hooking.
Yeah, I can slam.
Three, two, one.
I love it.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
They double, they double, they double, they triple.
triples oh they just triple ulted don't like they normally
like yeah we have that's fine i think there we don't even
match because it's like a mantis is probably dead in there
yeah yeah no 100 yeah yeah they just triple support ulted we
beat one salacle with venom will win the game triple who is
the third support yeah i was gonna say oh mag okay i have
what we have just listen just develop no like normal give
damage boost zotake jump in venom slam I'm 1500 am it keeps
on they get a stack again me to be really coordinated.
Okay.
We're ready.
Yeah.
Yep.
Yeah, yeah Oh one Oh one oh one oh one someone oh one I want
Yeah, I'm good i'm we're good.
We're good Venom venom venom venom, który venom, can we try
to stagger that time?
no he's that.
Um, we have free.
You're free old to take good luck, bro What just to take
there's a free elm.
Yeah, they have their support I think they have style cult
though, no.
No, I swear he doesn't.
Let me engage first.
Or you can just go with your old and old slam.
Can you damage yourself right?
Sonny, Sonny.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm looking Mantis right now.
I'm just at Mantis.
We'll DPS one, we'll DPS one.
Oh, we're dead.
Bucky one, Bucky one.
We got hard slam there.
You can still hook.
We're still hook.
Have a Bucky on me.
Bucky buy.
I think we got a reset fast here.
Last play.
Oh my god, I kind of...
No.
Just get out, get out, get out.
back following me i thought it was winnable i think yeah
zelda is doing it staggered no that's okay that's okay
i'm gonna have cyle now uh i think tp i think i think 90
percent yeah joe i think you tp i think you tp i think
you're tp i can just take some damage i'll let that back i
reload yeah i have touch we have 13.
i reload i have to reload i i quote it I got you guys.
We can make it back to the GP.
We can make it back to the GP, baby.
We need a saw.
I have it.
Just chill.
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
You jump back in.
Look for a kill, guys.
Close all good.
Fuck you one.
I'm gonna get really good.
Fuck yeah.
Amitad.
Winnable.
Necrust one.
Mid off.
I'll take it.
See point, see point.
Oh no.
Gigi, unlucky.
That's okay.
That was really close.
It's okay.
It was a close game there.
Well, you can't expect to win them all.
Yeah, no, that's the trade-off of playing Gambit.
You just...
Everybody just wants to kill you.
It was just a...
It was just a trade-off.
Because if I fly...
If I go away, if I have to save it to dashes, to reposition
myself.
Yeah.
I don't know how everybody exploded there when I ulted.
I was just like, are we, what happened to us?
I was just like, holy shit, what happened to us?
We just- I'm gonna walk around the house real quick, one
second.
It's not easy making a name for yet.
me for myself and I was like oh they're very good at hard
focusing me
yeah it's almost like a gambit or something I was like
feeling like it's a gambit or something I feel like that
point if I'm getting dove that I just I just leave die i
just i i just i just get get a leave i run away and i leave
i think we leave lobby for this one oh this one all right
just because at least one of us will live you know i think
at this point i have to ditch her
We both die.
Oh, everybody's so sad.
Everybody's so sad.
I can't be thinking of a five.
Give the chips.
Thank you.
I feel like I can't say, I can't motivate them because I am
the, I, I, everyone's so sad.
Yeah, yeah, I'm standing up and shut.
Oh, shit.
Everyone's standing up.
I'm sitting down.
It is also close, bro.
I know.
Little tweaks that we need.
It's okay, yes.
It's the round robin.
We have Sunday, guys.
Exactly.
We need to make note of like the biggest things that we can
do better.
Hmm.
I'm eating food.
Honestly, we played fine until the end of that game we
played really well and we said yeah a bad man assault
because i called it it's my fault so yeah i think that and
then like we should have and then our backline should have
played way far back i think we got yeah we got timing two
gambit ults in the last spot or the last point no yeah don't
you jump to the portal and couldn't get anybody i think we
should have like yeah when i went it's just like you don't
know if you don't like strange jump back to the spot and i
was just like okay i guess only i got gambit ults yeah it's
like you we we can afford to be like super patient with that
you know i mean like zoken like jump through and live jump
back wait for every respawn i think as soon as they went
bucky poke slop and got off dps well i think that was when
we had the swap hawk i should have told you the yeah that's
true it was working until the very end no it was you did you
had a really good primal on first place hulk was hulk as
well hulk was going well and then they just went bucky they
went bucky and shot their guns That was it.
It's okay.
I think I'll be worth doing.
Definitely for me, my weakest is just I don't have stream
experience.
I don't have like a lot of stream experience.
That shit is brain dead.
I guess my all I have is mostly have rank experience.
Well, raise a girl.
All right, there's supports, female.
And everybody else.
Okay, I'm just playing with Rank Brain.
That's my biggest issue.
I go with Rank Brain.
I'm not yet.
He said we can start joining Lopi.
His lobby won.
All right, let's see.
But definitely an improvement from the first game, I will
say.
I feel like I improved from the first game.
hey i did i do practice i've been practicing guys they're
all in lobby all right i'm hurrying where's the password
again is every password different wait what's the which room
is it which room is it it's lobby one all right okay oh
yeah olive too yeah it's me olive and ray wait you can't
find it oh here it is because i remember if they were
non-binary or not that's why i didn't want to assume because
i remember i saw like they in the bios so i didn't i didn't
want to assume the gender you know
i actually have experience um i think the reason why like
i'm worried about assuming genders now um is because when i
was like a minor And, like, one of my friends, online
friends, got really, really mad at like, like, she literally
tried to, she told all my friends, including my IRL best
friend, that I'm a horrible person, and then, like, leaked
my private Tumblr blog, right, used as a bed blog, and then,
like, leaked it to people, and then her friend, one of her
friends hacked my Twitter accounts and everything, and,
like, made fun of me and made fun of my depression
everything um just because like i accidentally used because
like they were like the meta it would work but they're still
discovering themselves it's just they're still discovering
themselves so like i always like like not always but
sometimes i was i mean they're gonna be a dog just because
they have one cap and then so um at one point like they like
snapped and then literally i lost my irl best friend and i
got my twitter account group was gone because we shared a
friend friend group so i i'm like i have like trauma from
assuming people's genders now so like i i don't i i don't
like go straight in being like like i know because i just
have trauma about it and like we were all minors too yeah it
was wild
that's why i was just like i just don't want to assume
anymore
Yeah, no, my old friend sucked for fucking, they're best
friends now, too, after that, too.
I don't know if they say are, but, like, like, she ditched
me as a friend and then became her best friend and
everything.
And, uh, and then, like, um, yeah, no, kids are scary.
Like, because they have no concept of, like, repercussions
and stuff like that.
Like, you know, their children are scary because they're
like they don't know about like consequences of their
actions um and i was a child too so because of that i have
trauma of just of just i don't want to say anything wrong
yeah yeah like legit i got my twitter hacked i got lost my
online friend group i lost my irl best friend and then like
they were like making fun of my like depression and stuff
and everything on my pack twitter account and um um and uh
and also like when i was in the hospital too so they were
making like they were using my twitter account to like joke
about it and i was like i was just like i didn't even know
what happened i woke up to it too because they were
australian so yeah yeah they were australian too so you I
was just like, Australians are brutal.
We should just continue to play what we're playing.
Perhaps.
Yeah, and my Tumblr.
Yeah, my private Tumblr event blog got leaked as well.
Yeah, so they did all of this when I was asleep.
So I woke up to it.
Advantageous for us.
And I think you should leave Cat Open.
And I don't think one of their parents.
I think we should.
found the parents facebook and i told one of them i told the
person that hacked my account i told the person the parents
no i was listening i know i know they're like the parents of
the person that hacked my twitter account yeah i told on
them yeah i think we should do that okay i was a minor we
were all minors
i had to create a new twitter account too because of it
because like what they did
Loki flanked and I killed the whole server on one of those
fights.
I thought I was in net it, kid.
It's like, oh my god, I killed three.
Wait.
Oh my god, hello.
I don't remember honestly.
I don't really remember what happened.
I would like kill Jimbo or kill someone and then just like
trade fucking pick out every fight.
Yeah, I'm ready.
like see do you want to play do you keep want to keep
playing guns you don't try cat what about like low-key i
want to i want to try dive cat i want to product i see why
australians are banning mine from you yeah yeah and england
do and the uk and not just australia and the uk because they
will never expect me to ban elsa because they'll think oh i
want to play it is this a whole game what are we thinking
100 i think it's oh no mag venom good I mean, I think it's
got to be Mag Venom.
Yeah, yeah.
Hulk Venom, and I think they're just going to run at our
backline.
What happened that last game is the reason both our supports
die is because the mag can just shoot with the team up for
free because we don't have a mag.
That is, yeah.
Honestly, I do think...
If we're playing die, we also can consider...
I don't think Miner should be using the Inner.
I think the Inner is a much more dangerous place now.
to what a lot of people grew up on yeah i think like if
you're a zoomer i think like the internet is um or like
younger the internet is a much more not child safe friendly
place than it was when i grew up um because there were a lot
more child friendly sites back then and a lot and i guess
not not a lot of deep web uh yeah then it was always bad but
it wasn't as bad as before there's And then the only
child-friendly websites people have is, like, you know,
Roblox, Fortnite, but even then Roblox, it's very...
We all saw the news about Roblox.
Like, at least Neopets didn't have all those grooming
allegations going on.
So Band Gambit, Heart Cat.
Yeah, I'll be right back.
I'm just going to piss.
At least Neopets didn't have that.
Yeah.
I don't think I want to play Gamma game.
So I do.
I do feel like.
Not again, Panic.
I shouldn't have said anything, bro.
I do feel like.
Whatever.
There are less child friendly websites.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Showtime.
Showtime, baby.
Oh, my God.
But like, why?
Like, you think, like, now even where they're like, oh, we
should.
everyone's playing also every game they should restrict the
use of the internet for children i don't know the internet
is a damn scary place is it because pinu falls in the trap
every fight they're saving quote whoa okay this team is lost
in mind there's way too many what even who's even on this
enemy team
a lot of turn grew up with unsupervised internet access it's
just because like uh wait fuck i was afk what do i meant
it's because like there was less dangerous websites back
then it's also like easier to find like now web a lot of
dangerous websites are easier to find because we have google
and everything um and we don't have we don't have hang issue
we don't have to worry of like you know like as a child the
websites that we know how to get to are like you know
neopets from like neopets like the mcdonald's toys that you
get behind and then uh club penguin also like from word of
matt like from i found out about club penguin for neopets
and then wait yeah where's band captain america they have
canoe does he play another hero tato tato tato you know how
kingsman is a bucky right yeah do we like say again you know
how you could like
100% I'm about to do that shit.
I'm thinking though.
We didn't even see our bad here.
Hey bro!
What else does he play?
I don't know.
What does Kingsman play?
Well he says, yeah, he's like the rank one storm.
Rank one bucky.
Rank one Punisher.
Rank one.
Rank one magic.
Devil dinosaur.
He's gonna play magic.
You're gonna go like a strange cat and they'll ban Venom
here.
He's gonna play wolf.
Did you guys tell them what your second ban is?
No.
I don't know.
We don't need that.
I don't like trim.
I like trim.
Ah.
The real game, they don't give a shit.
Type shit.
No, I've had tournaments where we're allowed to.
It's just more so of like, it's just a gentleman's
agreement.
Because it's just bad sportsmanship and they don't let you.
But I'm not a gentleman or a chill.
Because like every other tournament I've done, if someone
forgets, they allow a gentleman's agreement on it.
I mean, I think we would have like banned...
some day like we play do we play i'm just saying like what
do you mean they don't care we've let that yeah i was just
like how many pts fuck you guys over i'm a comfy on white
box or luna wait you want to wait who are you most comfy on
probably luna i like let me think is adam good here because
it depends what they play really so much there's some stuff
that could be good into yeah it's just like every turn i've
been i feel like they should just tell the fact that gotta
go add try to ask them it depends how much they're it's like
boger bash they would let you it's like an agreement yeah
but we could feel this out see how it goes next round be
helping those i was just like all right if they don't know i
think we need mag you need mag just sit on point legit you
just asked them and you have a team up you shoot people when
they die like every tournament i've done we've asked if
someone forgets in they're like can you battle like yeah
sure i'm i'm helping you from main i'm helping you from me
if you don't want the advantage Yeah, yeah, you could try to
choose your tanks well, prime pressure in front of land,
don't let them.
Man, walk up with some of these ridiculous items.
We're setting up top, man.
We can take guy.
ATV, ATV, ATV, ATV, ATV, ATV.
I need no ATV, I have no ATV in.
We can look for trades, we can look for trades, man.
Yeah, I look for trades.
Yeah, yeah, I can sim.
DD on me.
Can you go Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna,
Luna, Luna, Luna, I have D.
Luna dead, Luna dead.
I'm gonna back on, I'm gonna back on.
I'm gonna get back on.
I'm gonna get, I'm gonna get on.
Would you be on trigger?
Do you be dead?
I need to be at someone.
Do you need to touch?
I can't even touch it.
You can touch it.
You touch it.
I can't.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
They have missed the voice though.
I hear a daredevil.
Oh, I mean, yeah.
I figured that we're gonna do that, bro.
We live?
Oh, I fucked up my swing.
Yeah, that's how I live.
Sorry, reset.
Oh, change is kind of feeding, though.
Yeah, yeah, shoot them, shoot them.
He bugged me.
I'm gonna go top right.
I think they're bottom right or bottom left.
Yeah, careful.
They're all bottom left.
They're hitting him back right now.
I'm ready this time.
Go fast.
I'm scratching.
Strange one.
I'm trying.
I need care.
The strangers legit one does.
They have no supports.
I'm just forcing them for them.
I need care.
I'm trying.
I'm going to get to you.
I need to die, bro.
Cap those.
Cap one, cap one.
Nice, nice.
Good job guys.
Can we kill DT?
Kill him.
Come kill him.
Go kill him.
Just help me.
He's gonna one tap me.
Yeah, you tap.
You kill him?
Nice.
Yeah, good job.
Now we stage.
We stage.
Yeah, can we set up?
Their Luna should just blow up and die.
Like, these chains are so...
Uh, uh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I can get back.
I'm gonna walk up.
Let me know.
Okay.
I'm looking.
Jubilee one, Jubilee one, Jubilee one.
Are you okay over there?
Any care?
No supports, no supports.
We have Captain America on the supports.
Plain life, did you want me?
Yeah, just kill each other.
I'm gonna die out of this.
I'm semi-sticky.
I think I'm right.
He's on, he's on, he's on.
Nice, good shit, Sticky.
I mean, I'm 1 HP.
No!
We can get to you.
We can't get to you.
I got you, I got you, got you.
I'm ready.
I'm, I can stop.
Going top right again.
I'm going top right.
I'm ready.
Wait, Stu, cap, cap, cap, trolling on me.
Three, two, one.
I'm summoning.
I used my shift just now accidentally.
Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna.
Cap one, Cap one, Cap one.
I'm out, I'm out.
I'm out.
I have them patty kick, I have them patty kick.
Magic for a back leg.
I killed one.
Two magic, two magic, two magic.
They have one support.
They only have a cloak, guys.
They only have cloaks.
Just Luna one and I'm sitting there.
That was my bad.
Actually, uh, I think it's good.
We don't have supports.
They have no healing either.
I'm back soon.
They used cap.
Yeah, that's great.
I'm dying on.
All right.
That was my bad.
I thought you guys were behind me when I pushed the magic.
This is okay.
Probably white fox first.
Yeah, we could fox first.
I can hit their back on you.
You're back on your heels.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Black's eating her heels.
I don't know where they're back on now.
Oh, I see an enemy.
I'm sending.
I will.
That cat's one.
I'm not, I'm not pushing up there.
That one, cap one, cap one, cap one, cap one.
That cap is legit one.
I'm looking for it.
I can do it again.
Yeah, walk forward.
Work hard or second.
I can do it again.
I can do it.
I'm walking for it.
She's close.
She's literally.
I'm still in.
I'm outing this.
I'm outing.
I'm out.
Nice.
The cat's slow.
Everybody back on again.
Four, three, two, one, it's gone.
It's gone.
Lunol, good boo.
Oh, I can't live.
We don't have TP?
Can we TP?
I don't think we can.
Yeah, you should all you should all.
Keep being.
I'm dying on.
I'll jump through with Lunol.
Root's always with me.
You'll see what I mean.
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump.
Just cut off.
We can chill a bit.
You should all, you should all.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
Get a kill, get a kill.
we have venom we have close close close close close 1 close
click one push one click one click on M.2 back up back up my
res is done good heal good heal Stok applic captured nice
it's okay is no more no more no more I have strange ult he's
play-out who's there I'm gonna rock the heels here.
That's okay.
We have a res.
We have a res as well.
Yeah, just place a safe res.
The black cat found a res earlier.
I don't think they have anything.
Yeah, they don't have anything.
Point, point, point, point, point.
I'm going to turn.
I'm going to go for him.
I dropped on point.
I'm on point.
I killed the cat.
They have red.
He got my red.
Yeah, I'm all back on you.
Okay, okay.
Three, two, one, man.
I'm trying to.
One, both one, both dead.
They're one dead one.
They need a new heal.
They're gonna have a new heal.
All right Luna needs help.
Please go go go, go, go.
Yeah, I'm uncooked.
I'm not.
Helper's got people chasing them here.
Nice.
They big, big.
Jericho.
Oh my God, big ol.
I blocked it.
Come on,oline.
Camille, Camille, come on!
Nice.
Good job, guys.
We did it!
Beautiful, beautiful.
The magic golem.
You're in good.
You're in.
I played Spider-Man this map.
I think Rocky was kind of working for the dive.
Groot's always with me.
Yeah, I want to play Spider-Man this map for my ult.
He's like me.
I'm going to try to get Ruby.
Good shit.
Good shit on the strange potato.
Thank you, thank you.
Strange, bro.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
I'm in all backline.
the fucking coach aida in my chat right now it needs to i
want you to slam it first get like i was working the sea was
just way too good yeah i got you yeah the team up saved me
and luna oh they was saved me if i was white fox also
because i have all the city all incoming yeah it's just
gonna get frozen beast beast beast one the black cat is
actively hiding my res though so we might not get It's okay,
it's good, it's good.
It might be TPing, care TP, care TP, care TP.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, TP.
I'm the soldier of the team, be careful, careful.
They are, they are, they are.
It's Mickey, it's Mickey, Mickey, Mickey.
Oh my god, they're on point, they're on point.
I killed the cloak as well, I swear.
Oh, I couldn't.
Yeah, yeah, it is lucky.
I'll see, it's big, it's big.
Nice.
Come at you, come at you.
I took one, I took one.
They're good.
They're on point, they're on point.
I killed the cloak as well.
I killed my cloak.
They have a healing.
We're back now.
Help Jado, up Jado.
You can win, you can win.
Stop point, stop point.
Stop point.
We have kills.
Just shoot them.
Just do damage.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm really shooting my orbs.
You're good.
Just shoot your orbs.
You can hit with your orbs.
Yeah, I can stall.
I can stall.
Yeah, I'm just chilling.
I'm just waiting.
Man, can you take one?
Roll back.
Yeah, you ready?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm hitting three.
They're diving.
They did close.
Oh, he has Luna first.
We have Luna.
I feel like I'm pushing for you.
Do good, do good.
I might be dead to this.
I knew damage.
I missed.
I bursted.
Train, turn, turn, turn, turn, turn.
Hook our side.
All right.
I'll swap to White Pock's after a lot.
I'm just stalling.
I'm stalling.
Cash my mobs.
The wolves are right side.
Orbs are still on right side.
That's what I'm saying.
They used way more, we used one ult on these three.
I know him out all this.
I will hear.
I think they've strange.
What?
How does that hit me?
Character's broken.
I'm forcing point.
Not really.
Shoot the strange.
Shoot the strange a lot.
Here's strange ult.
Go looking for a hit.
They're catching him.
Kill him.
He's one.
I'm three.
Magic!
Focus Luna!
Focus Luna, focus Luna!
I'm sending Luna after, okay?
Yeah, one shot.
Sending Luna, Sending Luna.
Magic, magic.
You guys just leave.
They have no support.
Just leave.
Over backline.
Magic it.
Kill the point.
Kill, kill, kill, kill, kill.
Kill, kill, kill.
One more.
I'll count.
Right, straight, straight, straight, straight.
Lock his heals.
Yeah, good.
Nice.
What is this?
You're taking my reds.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
100%.
They're on DeeDee.
Back on DeeDee.
Hit her.
Hit her, Rhee.
I think you can maybe save her all.
That's weird.
Magic is matching me.
I'm still ready to hit whenever.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm going in.
Three, two, one.
Everyone, everyone, everyone, everyone.
They cap up.
They die.
They die, they die.
They live, live, live, live.
I got you.
They backplaws.
I brought Luna.
Hoppa Luna.
He did one, he did one!
Hey, we traded.
Help out, help out, help out, help out, help out, help out.
I'm dead here.
I'm only a white fox now.
This is live point, man.
Love you back soon.
Magic one, magic one, magic one!
Sticky, try not to ult here.
I don't think we can.
Just hold yourself.
Yeah, I'm so mad.
I'm on support.
Run on the wall.
Run on the walls.
Yeah, I'm good.
Sticky can touch innocent.
I'm running on the walls.
Run on the walls.
All right.
Yeah, shut up.
Um, they might have I think.
Cloak all Loki only.
Yeah, you have to mag off the cloak all, Joe.
You have to try to hit the mag out.
He's gonna try to, uh, he uses freeze at the end every time,
so you have to hit it early.
Yeah, yeah.
Before he is.
He's got it.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm gonna go.
I'm summoning three.
All right.
No one.
On cloak, on cloak.
Cloak.
Look for- I might be dead here.
I got Hard joke.
I got a joke.
I'm die.
Bro, the chain is sobering though.
They're gonna spoil.
Okay.
Go TP?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look who's dead.
Look who's TP.
They're strangers in their spot.
Yeah, yeah.
We should be able to take it.
Oh.
He's my HP.
It's a hard turn.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Did you want to support our both man?
Did he's a legit one?
Did he's legit one.
I'm trying to see you.
Watch magic, watch magic, watch that.
I'm gonna hit back.
I need help again.
We almost have.
Almost have.
I just got it.
Go back out.
Hey, yeah, go back out.
It's not working because we know the cat's fine.
Oh, it's close.
It's close.
I'm on the superior guy of character now.
What do they have?
Anybody know Altrak?
They use Cloak Alt.
They use both EPS ult.
They use Daredevil for that.
Yeah, both EPS ult.
I think they have Luna.
Listen, if we bait their Luna alt, we can either kite it, if
it's a bad Luna, or we can kite with Foxo.
or we can like kill through with fox venom that is a very
good kill through down mode i get it too busy saving the
world with your new crew like time it to win the fox bounces
you venom all jump and they should die yeah i think the
battle starts in five four it might be too inconsistent but
yeah no we don't have to do it obviously you could bait with
venom so no match it they're gonna they're gonna take you on
us again oh they're gonna keep catching yeah yeah you got a
strength Just strafe.
Just strafe.
You're good.
Come to us!
Oh, he went backwards!
That's okay.
I couldn't get through.
I can slam whenever.
Saming Luna 3, 2, 1.
I'm Luna.
Let's just die here.
I'm just gonna die here.
Yeah, I mean guys, like with the TP, you just have to
strafe.
And then go the outside.
Oh, that's not me.
I got greedy.
I'm gonna get through the TP, my bad.
There's a game.
I'm going right side.
I'm going top right.
We're all right side.
Let's go.
That's good.
I think they're gonna hit our back then.
Yeah.
I'm gonna support some change.
I'm something supports three.
Yeah, I'm close.
Oh, you.
I couldn't.
Oh.
We trade it back on.
Straight it back on.
It's kind of weird.
Keep on.
All right.
Oh, wow.
I try to use our fox salt when we can.
I got hit by the strange.
I couldn't hit it.
Here's the game.
Yo, I'm like 10 feet away from you.
What does this team up?
I'm ready for hit when I'm over here.
I'm just gonna rip my out here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna use heal scaring.
I can slam in five.
I'm doing it.
Kill the strange.
It's speeding.
Yeah, it's okay.
Cloak's on the altar.
I killed that cloak.
3, 2, 1.
I might be dead to this.
Yeah, I'm dead to it.
Can we just live the magic orb?
Live it, live it.
One is strange, one is strange.
Strange one, strange one.
What?
Let's try this again.
Strange one, strange one.
Nice big.
Cap one.
What?
They're fighting, they're fighting.
Lock in, lock in.
I need help, I need help.
They just kicked everything over.
I got res.
You got res here.
Someone touched.
I was...
It was too far.
That's okay.
That's fine.
Leave Silas by the way.
Yeah.
Hey, left side.
Yeah, left side.
Yeah, yeah.
You could touch point Although, you can touch point.
Yeah.
Support win one thing.
Yeah, yeah.
He just trade back!
Straight back, guys.
We trade backliners.
That's myself!
Ah, they have a quote called you.
Wow.
You can kill 903, metadata one, meta one.
Yeah, they will die.
Running forest!
Did you all die?
Did you one?
Did you want me?
I got the DD one.
It's gonna get health fat.
Great, Maage, trade, trade, trade, trade, trade, trade!
Coming over.
I would, I would rest if you die.
Can one of you touch?
I'll touch, I'll touch, I'll touch, I'll touch.
Okay, I get Nux touch.
I have Nux touch.
Ah yeah!
Magic wand?
Yeah.
Aw.
you just play cloak bro like i suppose yeah they're just
trading backlines and it's working better for them because
they poke want cloak luna or cloak rocket to
the team that we're against plays it better than us that's
my only problem with banning for me it's not even like dude
everybody's so sad it's like that like that's the thing
other teams like full dive everybody's so sad
it's not like we're getting absolutely destroyed 100% you
should have been on Hulk I should have said that on
domination I think if the Hulk is just easier to run like if
you see a situation where they're on double melee or they're
on some full dive shit and they're just on some stupid ass
like you don't if they're on guns all 100% swamped I think
yeah if they're on guns you go mags they're not on any gun
that's like a Hulk angle 1000% I feel
like too like out of Luna there maybe we have all of our
soul bonds we can stay alive better
guys come on cheer up every game has been close guys we're
not being absolutely destroyed it's just one or two mistakes
I agree I feel good about it yeah yeah it's just it's all
been very close games it was I swear I took Luna Why is
everyone so sad?
We're not getting destroyed.
It was just like, whatever.
We just got a ban for full dive.
That's not true.
That is not true.
I've won rivals tournaments and I've placed the last booger
pass.
I got third
Everyone's I'm like guys, we're not kidding.
I've gotten absolutely destroyed before and this is not one
of them.
games have been close yeah buggers said to have to poke so
yeah
yeah why don't we ban where's our coach where the fuck is
our coach oh so where's our coach the coaches can come to
the lobby tell us they also they can't during that range
they have strange running around and killing thing team's
coach in there they're not supposed to be with my knowledge
at least they're not allowed to talk during it they might be
able to just sit there dude maybe they're sitting there and
typing it to them or something because they're they're in
the vc there's seven people in craig's vc oh no i don't know
i'll be right back who's gonna tell Well, not me.
Abandoned by my coach again.
Not me.
I thought we were, he was gonna snitch.
Everyone's so depressed.
This is the most, this team, everyone's so depressed.
I should feel bad too.
I am trying though I am trying my best
I've been playing every day Since I got in the tournament
Alright
There were mistakes I made But I owned up to the mistakes
Like I know where my skills are What I'm limited on Oh
they're gonna hate me I
Ah, they're gonna be like, just a kinky-dokie bird.
The
freaking...
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
We're back here.
One eventually will know how to play on this map.
Alright, let's do it.
Ban face, ban face, ban.
I could just do the same band phase and put Zotayek on Hulk.
I don't think Mag does anything.
Who am I gonna banish from this match?
I think they're still playing for the dive.
Okay, which heroes will get my cosmic favor today?
I'm not handling bad.
I'm letting them do the bad system.
I'm just chilling.
sometimes that's sometimes in tournaments it's just feeling
it out
that's what we get okay i'm back i'm just gonna banditi by
the way sure first bang is to see my guys we can say that
all you want i'm i'm just here for the ride i'm not i'm not
the one handling the bad a lot of them to mock me when he's
on DD chasing me around the whole game I mean yeah yeah if
you want to practice I ban Bucky again the other team has
been practicing a lot I don't know no I think I'd rather
probably Venom yeah the other team has scrimmed a lot from
what I've known from what I've heard you've been scrimming a
lot play Venom Hulk if they're going to play cap I actually
think Hulk is better they're gonna play double melee bro
hulk is gonna shit on that if we can just get a buckyband
here at the end bro we're actually set set for life kid max
win like i think we should go to the back well yeah but like
i feel like when we're on with all Luna cloak you can like
live like especially the cloak yeah so I'm playing the trade
right yep well you're playing them need a scrim boy honestly
is that that's a 14 year old kid is there a double melee
mark there wow he's better than he's better than all of us
is that like blatant stream sniping wait i'm so confused
realize that after the last game but they're they're like oh
they should have played they have trackers on they have they
got the trackers though they're dude wait don't don't that
is the higher bro and when you're 14 and you don't have to
worry about taxes and you live with your parents you can do
whatever the fuck you want or you play thor is really good
here if you know how to play thor i don't know if you're a
thor player yeah we are again when you're 14 live your life
double melee bro anything that's on double melee is just
hard op which
team up is better for luna do you know because i think it's
um well it depends with white fox i like the white fox one
but the item team up i can just keep myself i mean i think
it's better to cleanse and then i'm general no i think the
cleanse is better oh it's the freeze is better okay yeah the
cleanse yeah if they all since i've just seen the atom is
better if you have adam on your team but i'm not creative
that the cleanse is definitely better i think the cooldown's
shorter too i could put the cap and play for the third
support all too see i'm just gonna see you mark my right
click does so take if they're in double melee i just want
you to harass their dps yeah like that's your job if it
doesn't work you can swap i'm not storm oh yeah they're
they're gonna we just hit behind i'm behind them i'm behind
i can hit them shoot i can hit i can hit hey you ready three
three two one oh oh my god storm storm storm storm i got
instant jump one jump one jump one jump one we just too slow
i guess i mean they just they just sped it through it he
just sped for it well yeah that's the storm draft yeah yeah
all right well they're not on dive anymore i don't think i
don't think we should run close that is the weirdest comment
i've ever seen in my life they're using the soul bond with
storm but they got off just a kill us in the last points.
They screamed it.
They definitely screamed it.
I'll just be pushed to that.
Alright, I'm left side.
We know we need to...
Yeah, I'm ready whenever.
We have to wait for a team to walk out.
Yeah, give it a shot.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Alright, let's go.
Okay, 3, 2.
I'm working, cat.
I'm working cat.
There's a cat behind us.
I'm pushing forward.
Just walk.
I took that.
I'll get to you next time.
I'm living.
I'll play my life.
I don't have right click now.
Wolf is fire ahead.
I can hit it again.
I'm fine.
Okay, I'm hitting.
Cap is looking for a dive again.
Wolf one.
No passive.
Cap dies, by the way.
Shoot the cap.
Cap one, cap one, cap one.
Cap one, cap one.
I'm out.
I died too.
Yeah, they're cat.
I'm behind her.
What is this ping?
I'm behind.
Bye.
running running running here's uh beat
i have a thousand credits so i'm ready to get active you can
get active with venom is venom out there luna i can grab i'm
looking at you lock lock everyone lock everyone lock yeah
can you back up okay you're ready uh i'm i'm walking forward
rain i'm 70 again i'm 60 percent
I have to use my freeze.
You did out Doki.
I couldn't.
I will.
Can go back on you.
I'm on Doki.
I can go off though.
Yeah, yeah, I can live it.
I swear they have Cabal though.
We need to kill Cab.
Can you touch?
I can get touch.
I'm throwing my bubble out.
My back on.
It's big.
I can touch.
I can't touch.
Oh, no.
We couldn't touch.
I'm a bullseye.
That's definitely my fault
Alright, we can hold close We're not here we're not here
We're not here We have no vault I have no support Right, I'm
ready to hit back on with all Yeah, I'm ready I'm gonna hit
their Luna, okay?
I'm gonna hit their Luna
I said
Look at captain, Cat-o-o-o!
I'm gonna altered this.
Oh, I could have altered it!
He cancelled it.
We're out of nothing.
We can cover back on.
Walk.
Walk, walk, walk, walk into them!
If the cloak, kill the cloak.
Kill the cloak after this.
Three.
Take it out.
Get out.
Okay, I'm 50.
He only cancelled, so I have 50.
Hook one.
Hook good.
I'm here, Sticky!
I'm here, I'm here.
Yeah, they're gonna fight us.
They're gonna fight us.
I'm gonna fish here.
I caught Spinning you.
I don't know if I can do it.
see you oh my god i'm
gonna do whatever helps no i have to use my right click go
have an emerald i have to reset guys you got to reset like
go back in his form shoot shoot cat cat one cat one cat one
cat one cat one dude i killed I killed the cat.
I knew he was feeding his brain.
I thought I was out.
I'm one HP.
I'm dead.
Cool.
They're not on a DPS.
It's a potato.
It's a massive patch.
You have to hold back.
Someone touch.
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on.
Just table.
Sable us guys, chill.
We're back soon, we're back soon.
Shoot the cab.
It's like feeding his brain sound.
Yeah, gap one.
It's a main three.
Can you save a hand?
I had to freeze it.
I'm looking a lot here.
It's the wrong way, wrong way.
Can we chill?
We have points.
Yep.
We almost have quip gold.
99 but i don't live this i don't live it god
i don't know what to do i'm just i don't know i don't know
we can't build all the time one in five i don't even know
what's happening time to switch things up like i'm there for
the engagements i tried the thing but lost you'll need a
top-notch team to like me and ray cannot build our ults with
what we have right now that's also can you play mad yeah it
has to be mag or tank full could be tank full mag or no not
tank full mag it has to be bad on my man but yeah yeah they
don't have any guns i'm gonna go ahead and clear our top
right if you feel like me or tato do you want to clear i'm
gonna try invis here it was like no way for me to get me and
re to get all i literally all
I left click and I was just like nothing is alt is not why
are we on this map is it did we pick the map why are we uh
is there reason why we're playing this map over and over
again well I mean it's a good map for us we're cool to
material Flake potato flake potato I don't know we've been
losing on this map maybe we just gotta swap how do we know
it's a good map how do you
I don't think I don't think it's a good map anymore
Wolverine bottom right yeah Wolverine bottom right you guys
locked me in I'm looking for slant soon hey wolf is just
like sitting on the back line yeah that's okay three I'm
just shooting mag I'm just shooting mag mag mag mag low mag
low mag low Yeah, walk guys.
We need help.
In behind, in behind.
Cat one, cat one, cat one.
Oh yeah, that's fair.
Yeah, yeah, that's fair.
Yeah, that's fair.
What do you think about running the Adam-Luna so we can keep
ourselves up?
You can do it.
You want to?
Yeah, okay.
Adam Warlock is here.
Fear best self.
Taye-Luna top right again.
We played that well, we just got traded out.
Shumak, shumak.
I'm simming.
Three, two, one.
Cap in, cap in.
Shoot cap, shoot this cap.
Cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap.
Cat in, cat in, cat, cat, cat, cat.
Good bond, good bond.
Cat, cat, cat.
I'm going to swap to, I forgot to swap the area.
They usually like cooldowns.
That's okay.
I'm simming three, two, one.
One that passes.
Pokemon.
All right, I got you, I got you.
Cat right side, cat right side, right side, right side
behind.
That mag is in that spawn dealing with me.
Hold on, hold on.
I got you.
Cat, cat, cat, cat, cat.
Cat one, cat.
Cat blow, cap blow.
Bro, help me out.
Get out, get out.
Move out.
Hold on in like five seconds.
We're out, not cat right now.
Mag low, not low.
All right.
We can bond just all for it.
i'm looking for someone i'm like dying to this yeah i can't
get it i can't get it i can't get it uh yeah oh you get it
oh he's gonna he's gonna roll right ah yeah i gotta fucking
dovis okay they probably helped out yeah
I'm slapping my team up.
That's so sad.
Okay, we're up all.
We need to use our alts now.
We're gonna have cloak all, I think.
Most likely, yeah.
I'm gonna flank right side with my alt, okay?
Okay, you have to try to peel.
There's someone on there.
I'm slamming, looking, three, two, one.
Yeah, I know he's running it.
You need to heal me real quick?
We can magle.
Get that shit.
Someone's up.
Wolf, oh!
Where's the Luno?
Nice big.
Where's Luno?
I killed her.
Oh, you killed her?
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Go, go, go, go.
Good job.
Three on.
They're gonna come out.
They might Luno ult.
When we Luno ult, I want a combo.
Tato, I'll ult.
Okay.
I don't have so much.
It's a bad TP.
Chill.
No grab.
Shoo cap.
Come on, come on.
Yeah, KK, can we even ask you?
They have the strange.
Try to damage.
Damage.
Three, two, one.
What?
I'm molting off there.
Ready guys?
I need care.
I need care too.
Move on, move on.
I still have all.
Can we win?
Someone else swap heals.
I mean, I can't.
I'm not gonna kill anything.
Oh.
Final score.
Zero.
Two, three, two, I don't know if this is our map yet.
I don't know if I should say it.
I don't know if I should tell them.
I was like, guys, I don't know if this is our map.
Maybe this map is cursed, guys.
Maybe this isn't our map.
No one said anything.
too sad on this team if you're too sad you're never gonna
perform better as the whole thing if you go in with a sad
attitude to the next game you're not resetting yourself
you're not like what if i'm trying guys i'm trying to cheer
people up i mean
I felt like we're staying up a lot a lot better with the
Adam Luna like we actually started getting some momentum but
oh yeah I think there we just need to stay the we either
need to like full anti-dive or we need to stay the black cat
because like I don't think anything there's like zero
pressure on my back line besides me it felt like yeah
if they found the answer to dive they will be happy yeah who
is our designated I don't think it would matter bro what I
played it just did not matter
I don't know I don't know what the plan is I wish we had a
coach our coach come in
I think we have to I think okay I think we've played for
dive enough, yes?
Or are we still going to try to play for dive?
Because I feel like we're just getting gapped on this shit.
I don't have to.
I don't know.
Just play guns, bro.
Just play guns.
Still in this.
We just haven't figured out our comp.
Yeah.
It's like ranked game ultimate.
Good.
Uh, wait, what, uh, what's our next lobby?
Uh, three.
But they might not be done yet so we can't join yeah you
play against moxie
so i have a network message
there's a there's a fake ogre bash lobby three just so you
guys know oh sorry i saw that i will i'm about to join that
i know i just joined it yeah yeah we lost
Taddaddaddaddaddaddddddddadddddddddddddddddddddddddddddddddddddddddddd
i'm locked to have a uh
uh sorry i just the work message and important work message
oh i wouldn't are they still like how long till their game's
over the uh third lobby um i don't know
i expected it real quick
sorry guys give me a sec i'm locked in no it's not still the
fake one bro we're gonna get kidnapped in that shit
You go to my stream real quick?
I'm peeping.
Peeping.
Wait, can I see the Luna's POV?
You like that freeze?
Can I see the Luna's POV?
Oh, bro.
You can see it.
No, that's what happens to me on Spider-Man.
On God, that's what happened to me on Spider-Man.
All right, sorry.
Show me the Luna's POV to see if you like...
That...
How are the vibes?
people are really sad yeah that was headshot not now during
the game people were sad
but it's okay guys it's just seeding it's just seeding guys
they're still playing i'm watching space history right now
all right pull it up
all right all
right sorry sorry i had i like some work messages i had to
go through uh
i think it's just a team synergy issue i think it's normal i
think i don't think it's like like yeah like i've made
mistakes and everything but i think we all made mistakes
there like i like i don't know how ryan i could have like
when we had no alt charge there compared to their enemy
compared to the enemy supports like i what can we heal like
there was there was really nothing we can heal in that
situation like it was i was just looking forward and i had
to peel and i'm like i i i don't know what can i heal like
yeah the timing was crazy yeah
i mean they can blame me if they want to i don't mine like i
am the weakest player because since i'm not a rival streamer
and i don't scream so like i i i can own up to it i'll own
up to it because like i'm i don't play against a lot of dive
that's the thing you won't believe it i've just watched a
gambit team up cancel moxie's bucky y'all so it's like it's
like i'll own up to it as the least experienced rivals
player out of everybody since i don't play against dive that
often and this entire team is just everybody here
if they want to blame me that's fine if other chats are
blaming me i'm i'm fine with that because i i know like like
i have the weakest so i can take that
like i am trying though i don't i'm i won't say like i'm
throwing i'm i am trying my best i've been playing this game
off stream as much as i can despite my very busy schedule so
I'm trying to give as much time as I can to this tournament
to my team
yeah like I've used up every resource I can against die
let's see
yeah our sit there's just we just don't have this energy yet
everybody is like super split up
um I don't know I don't know i think scrums wise we don't
know you know what would cheer us up though
yeah no 100 get a hulk
If I don't play Hulk, I'm never getting invited to another
Broker Bash over again.
Yeah,
but like, yeah, this is the best way to cheer up.
I want you to play Hulk, but there's just scenarios where
Mag is just a must play.
I just, at this point, I feel like we should just, honestly,
at this point, I feel like we should just not play that.
Against double melee or against even, I wouldn't say one
melee because then we would have no front line.
and they would just walk at us and our back then would die.
But it's double melee, 100%.
If they're playing some cancer, like, bullshit dive, you
just 1,000% go Hulk.
Wait, they just finished map one?
Oh my god.
It's gonna be a while.
Oh, now it's okay.
I don't know, but I think, like, you know, at this point, we
just fucking...
let it ride just be like like hey maybe the map's cursed you
know like you know just be like what if it's just the map it
would be funny if we won if it wasn't the map you know
sometimes it could be the map
um this is the last game last three last two games um last
team we're fighting i think teams and this is our next game
will be our fifth team that we're fighting i don't know i
have no idea why this is considered our best map we've had
one scrim we
that's why i was like how do we know it's our best map we've
had one scrim
i'm just like guys it's one scrim and we play this map one
time
and yet somehow fate has decided that this this is our map
that's our fate
I think it's also unlucky that we're not allowed to do
balance latency.
So because they're just shit talking.
That's unfair.
They're blaming every other people's chats are blaming the
support I mean whatever.
Just whatever.
I don't think it's a...
I think like...
We just explode.
Like what the fuck are we supposed to do?
I've held my own in like...
Eternity lobbies.
In one above all lobbies.
You just don't have the synergy that's handled that.
It is what it is.
That's why I'm just like, I like, GG go next.
You're like, it's not fair.
Your team has Celestial supports.
It's not fair.
Why did you pick them?
And I'm like, hey, I was, the wheels spung on me last.
Yeah,
easily.
Literally, every time I've, like, tried my best to, like,
run away.
It's not whatever.
It is what it is.
Just let them blame it.
I just feel bad because a lot of these players, there's a
lot of small streamers too, especially my team.
And there's a rare opportunity for them to be in this
tournament as well.
So I feel bad for them because they don't, you know, when is
the next tournament invitation?
Like a big tournament invitation So I really appreciate
Bougar for inviting the smaller streamers, especially for
like big prize money tournaments.
Because, you know, it's hard to get these opportunities as a
smaller streamer.
For me, so this is like, to them, it's like a, to them, it's
like a make it or break it type opportunity.
The only team with no one.
Wait, we can still win the next one.
Don't get down.
I don't care if our vibes are down, we're not going to do as
good.
Yeah, but who do we play?
Uh, J3, I think, or Moxie.
Is that our last one?
No, it's both.
So Moxie or J3.
Like, we have to do both.
Oh, so we only play one more team?
All right, let's see.
No, too much more.
Okay.
Yeah, I thought that was going to be balanced latency.
this morning bro i thought it was like always gonna happen
they changed i think i think all that i think yeah they
changed the last second i think all the eu players like
complained about it
yeah like i was what was i gonna say sorry i had uh
sorry work message
ah so many work messages unrelated to this
all right let's see That's what that's what elite taste just
said.
Wow, think so?
I agree.
No real.
Bro, no, no.
Look at the comp the armory team is playing.
They're playing Ultron, Ultron, Mantis, Penny.
Jubilee!
Jubilee.
Wait, I remember his Jubilee is scary.
Why are both people playing Jubilee?
Okay, first of all, incorrect statement.
Second of all, why is it?
Why are both teams playing Jubilee?
Jubilee is the worst character.
Jubilee is the worst hero in the game.
1000%.
What?
They had to agree on the Jubilee mirror or something.
There's no way they actually are playing that.
They have like an underground like shaking hands.
Yeah, we'll both play Jubilee.
We'll both Jubilee.
Yeah, let's play Jubilee this game.
We can mirror each other.
It'll be fun.
Kingsman probably has more in a size.
Yeah, it's sort of like wild card club stuff.
So I have to respond to it.
Because the deadline is super tight.
Better win against Jubilee than with all the snacks.
super fucking tight so like we have to well you can win on
bad they need my approvals and stuff within like a couple of
hours bad characters but like we should be able to win god
hope
this guy's on penny who's on pennies a cruiser oh yeah he's
looking fine hey hulk i also come on big puffer no big
puffer's locked bro big puffer's legit
well what a big coverage is all he's beating the out of this
guy what the what the shit out of joey the beat the fuck out
of that guy what the fuck oh my god i want to shoot the
strange shield or nah that was that was brutal he just got
shit on the bad all right so are they gonna are they gonna
be able to break the triple support penny fucking setup
probably not it doesn't look like it definitely not
definitely not he's got he's got alt too if he's smart he
just alts in the choke what's going on we're waiting for the
we're waiting for the last team that's really it um the last
team is taking a while because every team has to finish like
failing to be um and they're still they're still working on
it i mean i could do a quick go go king what if i just pull
up a ring see i'm like no it's time about just pull up a
ring just pediote that oh my Jesus Christ don't mind that
but look at this though look at the rank look at my rank
records though don't mind the top part okay wait wait oh
look at this though
I can barely run a quick play.
Well, I should have just ran a quick play, man.
Ooh, we grabbed the cap, J3!
I think everybody was very equal.
Honestly.
Yo, get off of.
Get off of.
I think everybody was super equal in general.
I don't believe in.
I didn't think anyone...
Like, it wasn't like a total stop by anything.
Contra or Mori.
Honestly, nothing was a total stomp.
I just think, like, um...
Oh, shit.
This team's comms are fire.
These comms are...
The little boy is kind of loud.
Let me turn the little boy down.
Oh, they got that in a hotel.
He's dead.
Kishore!
Oh, fuck, Kishore!
I'm allowed to.
This map is really lagging.
The adults are talking now.
Even though he's, like, the IDO.
Kishore, I'm on Venom.
I don't know how much I like this.
I'd rather...
Oh, they said we can join Lobby 3.
Ah, shit.
They just said...
Wait, there's a huge lack of synergy.
Legitimately.
I think everybody is like...
I think the biggest problem is that...
No, they just said in chat.
Tanks need to be more vocal.
The tanks need to be more vocal, too.
Wait, everyone's lagging bad.
Yeah.
We just there's a lot of there's a lot of nerfs on this team
and our one of our main DPS is on 200 ping because they
don't want Valency since he was vetoed by the group
majority.
It's not full anymore
Yeah, join lobby everyone.
Oh, yeah, like I was gonna say I feel bad because like I
said Oh, I mean my team is mostly strong small streamers So
this is like yeah, they want to use this opportunity of
course to like wait no i didn't even have six people in a
minute right now oh oh lobby one lobby three five
and like you know their you know emotions hit harder because
they want to use this opportunity to like you know for
publicity and stuff and you don't know when their next
invitation is to a tournament um unfortunately yes sir for
me i do have the influencer buff um like i don't want to you
know you know i don't want to be like say it but i do have
an advantage just because i'm an influence just because i
have like the viewership uh for tournaments and stuff
because that's mostly about tournaments tournaments is like
i think the only time mostly they want they want high
viewership so they can promote the game in itself you don't
want the adam team up
everybody's ready goodbye my team like that's the only time
triples worth playing is when loki matches open let's see
but we could i don't i'm not i get it i get why like they're
more sad about the results wait this is not the right this
is the fake one there's a fake one i forgot about that um
and the recent loki adam loki adam isn't good because you
don't have a Mantis obviously and then that where why can I
join the Luna Adam Mantis isn't good because Mantis 2 to 2
is better um so I get why I I get why like emotions are yeah
I'm Toki I'm here I'll pull up pull up I'm in to the lab oh
who's oh you're here yeah yeah and it's like I get why there
are more people they're sad you know like I've been in teams
with like because like it's harder to go GG go next because
you don't know when the go next opportunity arises again too
and it's like so you get like a lot of the smaller streamers
harder for them because it's like one of the you know it's
like winning the golden ticket to them especially it's a lot
of money as well like i i even i'm like this is a lot like
you know like even it's like 1k to 5k it's still a lot of
money like um especially it's us dollars it's one to five k
us dollars so like for them like for the smaller streamers
it's harder for them to they can't go for the fives in a way
because it's like um you know if they're in a winning team
they can um if they're in a winning team they can uh uh gain
so much from it from publicity wise well they can blow up a
lot and also it doesn't help that i'm the biggest streamer
on this team and i'm not streaming on twitch as well so like
they don't get the twitter buff from me just because i'm on
youtube um but a lot of the other teams they have a big
twitch streamer that can uplift the smaller streamers here
um and unfortunately i'm not there to stream it on twitch uh
to help the smaller streamers as well.
No, you guys think...
But it's like, I stream all my tournaments on YouTube.
Like, that's not what I do.
Your mom.
Yeah.
So, like, all the other teams have, like, a big Twitch
streamers propping everybody up as well.
Yeah.
And I think I'm the biggest one in this team as well.
So, I think I don't know.
I don't know if anyone...
I don't know.
She's 19 and 4.
But the other team's also playing Jubilee.
Oh, but they swapped off.
oh but yeah doing too much on jubilee could this be a
jubilee diff and she died cool and that mag the mag
character looked up for a frame so she died so i get it i
get like wow i get it but also like i'm good off that um bro
maggie she's so broken that's why i'm like it's fine if they
blame me it's fine there's only two variety every time space
and it's like me and puffer and um i'm with it if they want
to blame me that's fine like i'm still i'll still try my
best i'll still like try and improve um also try and prove
for the the finals uh on sunday no help our lord i'm even
like i'm even like uh i'll tell you there's no no um
canceling my streams for like i'm not canceling but i'm even
like rearranging my schedule just to just to scream with
them and stuff too best to to help as much as i can he's
swapping to everyone's pov and they're all dying he's he's
rigging the games bro he's rigging it he's he's the
mastermind all right boy he's got to die yeah the kid is 14.
he's gonna get two tap by down main by kingsman that's fine
i'm in so many of these tournaments like like if they want
to blame someone it's okay either run it Spunky beaver is
like shit ran it What the fuck It's only because like I'm
just at the disadvantage For being someone that doesn't
stream All he got fucking Grabbed it off the map But I'm
trying my best Yeah I just think it's just the lack of
synergy As a team Because we don't stream as often But
that's what This I feel like this Oh they asked if her
already I feel like since it's I think all games have been
close I just think all games have been close Despite the
lack of synergy the fact that all the games have been close
So like means that we can always improve Yeah, it's such a
long day A war day It's been a war day Yeah, a war fucking
day War But I'm actually fully locking in we need to win bro
I know We're banning the fucking Venom character And I'm
playing character and we're winning character yeah all right
now is a good sentence all right but yeah we got oh wait
olive and tater are so loud all right touch i don't know if
sound guys i'll turn him down no um tato no olive wait they
actually got he swapped off jubilee i turned him down
they're watching the game they're watching um one of the
games right now so we're just waiting broken yeah i don't
think any we went we didn't get stomped i don't like i don't
think we got stomped stomped i think like every game has
been super close in general no laughs no giggles all comms
of uh focusness and winning this yeah the ping is crazy i
mean just war in my eyes no fun i'll be right back in a
second still ready hey no playing on 200 ping as well that's
like gotta be gig award like i'm on even ping like i'm just
chilling and then potato slagging this ball and even even on
a hundred ping i'm like uh i don't know how you do 250 no no
200 is like low key fine it's like 220 when we get in the
game is that the 20 ping 20 ping like no because it goes up
it goes up like exponentially yeah i could see that for red
john on 200 ping that guy's nasty is this why is that your
usual somewhere red john that that guy's looking even though
you sometimes you go down sometimes you go up i've won too
many tournaments last year these hooligans these frauds i've
won too many balance it out hey I won my one in Street
Fighter I won my one on Street Fighter it's all I used up
all my luck I used up all my luck in non-tournament events
no drama so far it's just team sad which is understandable
you know is a what's moxie doing is he good like losing
sucks I don't know what moxie's doing he's probably larping
just like i'm back welcome back ignite the battle
wait wait armory c9 they're jubileo well i guess yeah i know
i tried i tried to cheer people up they swapped off jubilee
for the second round and they instantly won but it didn't
work i guarantee you king's been called the jubilee swap by
the way oh this seems looking like us bro belt to ass yeah
can't wait till we played him to see we have to beat them
bro we have to beat them we have to beat them we have to get
more about to ask bro we uh here we go our all right let's
get those bands we have a i think boker bash never had drama
oh honestly i don't think they've ever had it single that's
why boker people go to boker for uh to organize tournaments
because he's like he's european so he won't let that happen
what if they just moxy They're not going to play like melee
heroes.
No, they're 5,000% not.
They're going to play guns.
Yeah.
So we can gap them on the guns.
We can just hard gap them.
Try that.
Oh, okay.
Okay, and they banned the gun, all right.
They banned the character.
He's European.
He won't let that happen.
What you guys banish first?
Ah, bro, spam, ban them.
Wanda.
oh
okay i think this is european just europeans just don't have
a filter so because they don't have a filter they just they
don't let things slide it's like a team captain character
that i banned next but what am i saving bucky or hella uh
yeah yeah bucky do bucky do buck fuck should have done hella
god damn i think you're gonna ban hella i don't think
they're ban hello they're gonna ban yeah they're not gonna
ban that ban that we just play mantis gambit like low-key
surely they it's one of our better cocks all right bro
they're like wait they might have had mag bro i think they
want to play triple d we can yeah they want to i think they
do as well we can be 100 do i ban mantis then yeah because
we're better at like like who do they even they even play
like loki yeah we're gonna play loki gambit it's like moxy
on fucking you could ban out another dps to make it even
weaker oh no bucky's already prodded nevermind proko hello
sorry i got another word for mac right it's okay they're
doing bad phases yeah i'm gonna play mac i'm gonna play mac
imagine like moxy whips out the black cat i don't see it
being possible am i wrong on that there's no way moxy whips
out black cat right like Yeah, I don't see it being
possible.
There's no way.
What about DD, do they have a DD player?
No, they don't.
I think, wow, I think they lost their minds.
Do I need to play Rogue?
Do we wanna play Rogue?
I'll play Rogue if it's open.
I think I y'all better- I think I've been like, I've been
like Capp or Thore, because Kim Capp's gonna run it down on
Capp or Thore.
I think Capp, Capp, Capp.
state case oh my god no he's gonna go angela it's like fine
now we play i'm not judging wait do i just go i have a widow
right all right just in time well we need a lot of game to
start yeah we need damage um we want me on are we okay are
we committed to triple tank yes make way for the king of t's
i'm focused guys i'm so focused If they're somehow on double
melee is okay, you got the you got the Hulk, bro.
I don't I don't know if they're gonna be on double melee,
bro.
I see If somehow they roll out on black hat.
All right, yo, with they TP Knapp guys.
Alright, here we go.
Don't get Knapp's.
30 seconds before you attack.
Let's just take the second to point.
I don't care.
Here we go.
We can just play together.
We can literally just walk out together.
We can right next to each other so that they can't.
One of us think we can just lamp He's gonna speed us That's
what you speed And on my supports just set up bunker We take
point really quickly Set up bunker We just sit there and
farm a fucking gamble And they're not gonna be able to play
a good dive Because I mean, we have a thing in a row Shit
There's black cat DD open but they have two hits gamblers
Alright, care TP You just go buy them right I guess Alright
They don't take Aegis left side of the map.
They don't cloak.
Cloak, Bucky, Mag, they have Widow.
They don't triple, they don't triple.
They put behind us somewhere.
You can tank pull behind.
I can mock the tank pull.
I can shoot me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tank pull behind.
I can shoot him.
No worries.
Just heal me.
I'll give this up.
He's full out.
You got rinse up there.
Don't turn around guys.
He'll lock things.
Chill, chill, chill.
Need a back.
Yeah, I get out, get out.
I'm coming back.
Can't get free-fited like that.
There's a Widow turret left, Widow turret left.
Live, live, live, live, just live.
I got boot back.
I can kill Widow.
Widow, Widow, Widow, Widow, Widow.
We're not both- Yeah, these kill these guys.
Kill these guys.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
I'm low, I'm really low.
I'm gonna use my cards here.
Alright, walk top left.
Walk top left.
He can't give him the whole map, I just like...
Manko went to vault.
We try to save Limp for Banko?
Yeah, I need you guys.
On the guarantee though.
So null.
79.
Shoot the widow?
Didn't you kill?
It's on me, it's on me, it's on me.
I need his health.
My health!
Hook one.
Rune in.
B2B, go now!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Choo widow, shoot widow!
Attack on!
Blank one!
But a 1.
No, no player.
Mag want a kill.
Mag.
Hang on.
Yeah, I got you.
I got you.
I don't think we're going to use it.
That's fast.
Just kill him.
We can kill him.
We can definitely kill this guy.
Shoot him, shoot him.
Hook, hook him.
Anぞide.
Anzide, anzo.
kill Bucky, go Bucky.
All right, hold up.
You have it.
TP TP TP TP TP TP TP.
TP P and TP.
I'm gonna copy if you need it.
Don't die?
Okay, they stuck.
We have copy.
Don't die with copy.
Try to battery again.
Okay, okay.
I gotta copy near the start of this fight.
Yeah, yeah, we can pre-copy in a second.
Let them mock him a little and then I'll copy.
There's a need to shoot, but I'm not shooting us.
Yeah, I'm not shooting much.
Yeah, you can copy.
You can copy.
Kill the lucky kill him.
Kill him.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
I can't add the...
I'm on point, I'm on point, I might die for it.
I'm on point, I'm on point, I'm on point, but I might die
for it.
I use my...
I'm on my own.
Yeah, I'm good, I'm good.
I'm good.
I use up all my cards.
No cards, no cards.
I'm shooting tank pool.
You guys won't me.
There's a ragopsy.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
Be careful, be careful, Sticky.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Tank pool behind us.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
I need help.
I had to use runes.
Back guys, back, back, back, back, back.
Grabbing dead pool.
Can we mount up?
Shoot him.
I could.
Keep you up.
Come here, come here, come here, come here, come here.
I'm trying to.
I have C.
Kill two, kill two.
He killed two.
Help out.
I'm using all my cards.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, Go for it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag, one.
Mag one.
Two Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
I'm looking, I'm looking Bucky, looking Bucky.
This kill is almost yours.
It's nice.
I'm only 40 though.
Yeah, we don't have, we don't have another in gamut.
They have Cloakal.
They'll let you build.
Just when, when, when they Cloakal, look for like, you know,
look for, um, they're on Wolverine.
They're on Wolverine.
Look for, um, your shadow.
Left side, left side.
Just kill one guy.
Take a few.
Shoot this guy.
He's touch.
He's low.
He's nice.
Grab him.
Just play under.
Uh, you guys.
I didn't use my C.
You have to say point thing.
You kill.
Got you.
I got you.
Look at the wolf.
Help potato.
I got potato.
You got help our teams.
Help our teams.
Maglo, mag, mag running out of....
Mag running out of...
MAG, MAG one!
Mag one!
Oh yeah, there's a point.
He can pass him, I TSP, I'm TSP, I'm TSP.
I need help, I need help, I'm getting run out.
No passage, no passage.
Ah, we're healing, give me so much heals.
Wait, hold on, hold on.
Move on, trade move, trade move, trade move!
We have copies soon.
I kill Gavin, I kill Gavin!
I almost have copy.
I'll give you all a friend to a target.
CLM, the pool, the pool, the pool.
Move on point, help out!
Aivo, Ivo!
I hit it!
Nice big!
I got hit.
It's fine.
Oh, dead, dead, dead, dead!
They're gonna have TP's on.
Mag, mag, mag.
She went out, she went out, she went out.
We did it!
And we win that way easier if like, we're on the left, I had
the widow and the cloak.
I just can't kill them.
I tried to ruin you, you were just, like, barely outside of
it.
You did good, you did good, bro.
Fuck, close cloak characters, too OP, man.
I don't, what team-ups did they have?
Because they did not freeze there.
It's just Buckyall and, um, tank pull-all, right?
Like, legit.
Yep.
We should say 30 seconds before you- We just follow them
again, but we do the same thing as we just go, uh, go, I
think, right side?
The plain side.
Oh, what do you want to do with D'Rogo?
What do you want to do with D'Rogo?
Um...
Shit, I don't know.
Maybe Widow?
We had to use Widow.
We go Main, Taito.
I don't know.
I'll wait a little bit and try to catch Gambitol, maybe.
I'll try to let you find the- We go Main and we just follow
my camera.
Maybe it was the map.
Don't just super turn around for this tank full.
Like, he's doing like legit nothing behind us.
Just like shooting off.
Yeah, we can't full turn around.
Keep healing each other, but don't like fight towards him or
like shoot him.
Like, I'll shoot him back.
I'm just walking forward.
He's gonna get shot in the face.
Yeah, it's Zotay.
Zotay, Zotay, you can like- myself i'll be fine care tp play
main and fall model they're they're out i don't think they
don't have tp they already used it you're clean get everyone
get everyone look you'll one they're on we'll kill we'll
kill i use all cards i used all cards no cards any help i
need help they're in soup they're wrapped i'm gonna use this
for us i'm gonna use this for us table table table table
table table table table table table table i have a look look
at widow look widow widow widow
wolf yeah she will she will i need help here i need help i
need help two dead two dead i'm gonna be dead i had to run
from the mag ult they only have gambit heals one health i'm
trying get out get out get out get out get out we're gonna
get staggered we're dead ah it's unlucky
Move on top left, move on top left.
We should go left side, low key.
I'm gonna let you heal.
Yeah, we can go left.
We're already right, we should just go.
Yeah, go right, come right.
I'll walk right.
You guys go right, go right.
Move top, move top left, jump.
Yeah, he's playing, he's playing.
Yeah, he's close, he's looking forward.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
We have to wait.
Okay, we didn't see that.
I'm going, I'm going.
I'm going.
I'm backing up all the way.
Backing up all the way.
I'm trying to.
No, I didn't know you.
Sorry I didn't know you're going to spawn.
I have lots down here.
I think we should play in Viz as well.
Is that a Boki?
Okay, I almost have copy though.
Maybe.
The lamps are good for tank as well, though.
I think you can keep it.
I'm walking.
self-patterning us here.
We don't have to right.
We don't have to roll.
We're gonna have to roll.
We're going up.
Look, look at this.
I got pulled here.
I got pulled.
Pull my gambit.
He's one.
He's on match.
Look at me behind.
Look at out.
Oh, I'm trying my best to keep you up.
Remember that.
Bo Igre esta, bo bo.
Wo, po.
Aye.
Ma, Oh, look what's up.
Look what up.
Look on him.
What are you, what?
Oh,ชie.
We're trying to walk up.
They flew out.
He's one.
I'll save it.
Okay, backline.
Go backline.
We need it?
All right.
Can we kill him?
Yeah, yeah, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna die.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Who's that?
We'll die.
Don't die.
I want to kill the mag.
Kill the mag.
I'm gonna let her heal.
You have to heal here.
Kill me, kill me.
Thanks.
Kill the wolf grab, kill the wolf grab coming back.
I'm gonna go with Tala in a sec.
I'm gonna go with Tala.
You ready?
Just wait, just wait, just wait.
Okay, you ready?
Yeah, ready?
One.
Everyone, everyone, look guys.
They all die.
Shoot them.
Oh, I need help here.
Oh.
It was one.
It's your anchor.
This ult is so shit.
No, we just all have to crash out.
Like my support's have to walk up too.
I was walked up, but I got hit by the widow.
Dipping.
Oh, body block.
Body block.
Jump, jump, jump.
Copy.
Carewold.
Okay, don't kill us.
I can help you.
Come back.
I'm in, I'm in it.
Wolf on!
Careful!
I'm just getting harassed by Widow right now.
I'm backing now.
Get out!
Oh, I gotta...
They're...
That's the top right.
I'm killing you.
Got it.
All right.
It's just a whiffer.
When I saw a whiffer.
Yeah, someone needs to call the widow because I get hit when
I don't know where she is.
Okay.
Yeah, potato can mark her now.
It's definitely sue instead of Loki because they have a
wolf.
You as charged up as I am, Eric.
I sure hope so.
I'm trying to reposition, but I feel like nomadic, they're
like, walk up with us.
And I was like, I was!
I've walked up!
And I still got shot by Widdle.
I'm just like, I am walking up, but then the Widdle is still
shooting me.
Just going to take the point?
I should fly shot for the Bucky.
No, I think it could be Widdle.
It could be Widdle if you want.
And you can take angles.
No, I have to play with you guys.
You just need to mark the widow.
Someone has to deal with the widow.
Just shoot her.
Okay, walk left, walk left, left, left, left, left.
Don't get picked by the widow.
Care tank wall.
Shoot the tank wall.
He's beat her.
He's an avatar.
Can we pull the wolf?
Look at this wolf.
Grab a wolf.
I'm all here.
You want to use it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, touch it.
Okay, okay.
Hold on, hold on to the left.
Two pulled, two pulled, two, two, two, two, two.
I got all, I got hit, I got hit, I have nothing, I have
nothing for it.
I need you to keep me, oh, you're dead, sorry.
You really died.
Save your mustache, TGK, good.
No, let's try it.
Walk top left, walk top left.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm good, I'm good.
Wolf right side, wolf right side.
Can we give the team Dedede?
Can we start walking?
Hang on, we're over.
Yeah, I'm offered you.
Careful, just careful.
Wolf coming for us all...
Yes, we're его.
I'm on tank-Bull.
I need care, I need grab one.
I need care, I need the under風.
Just one.
Thankful, thankful one, thankful one.
I'm with you, I'ms here.
Thankfuls out.
Help me, help me, help me, help.
I'm trying, I'm trying to help you.
Well then, we're gonna get everything that we do.
I'm walking up.
Jubito, shoot with us.
Just carry with us.
Oh, I need you all, bro.
Oh, wow.
Grab it.
I think I got the screw off.
Wolf is behind us.
I don't have cards left.
Oh, he got me.
Going blackout.
Yeah.
Hey, nobody's stealing Gambit's chance to win.
I'm just gonna walk off.
Yeah, yeah.
We're careful, we're close, we're close.
I can look to, I'm gonna look to jump there back.
I'm on all team.
We're back.
Okay, I'm gonna go back on in three, two, one.
Hold on, go past this.
Gambit, I'll just...
I can chill a bit.
I need Baron.
We're giving as many resources as possible.
I killed the Gambit.
I killed two.
Yeah,
every game has been super close.
Yeah.
Well, you can't expect to win them all.
It's unfortunate.
I'm like, I want a DPS, but everyone's taking so much
damage.
I feel like, I don't know.
I feel like you might risk DPSing.
Just, do I risk it?
I don't know.
Everyone's taking so much damage, and I'm using my cards to
heal instead of DPSing.
Also, dad is angry.
Why?
No.
no no hey after stream you can demand as much food as you
want it's not even for yet
i don't know i don't know if i should dps more because like
i want to but it's like every time i want to everyone's so
low so i have to keep healing or else we're dead so i'm like
trying to decide if i want to dps or not yeah he can't be
hungry it's like two right now
i don't think for this next game i'm just going to focus
more on dps yeah siki where do you want to go bro
where are we going where am i taking us team uh that's what
comp we want to run bangamba we play like hella hella bucky
see yigs yigs all i like yigs yeah i was gonna say oh my god
we're gonna start on a new map right now
sorry i'm just doing work messages end this tournament at
the same time so it's like
maybe this is it guys maybe it was a map issue you sound
tired i'm muted when you asked me about that i had it was it
was five I woke up at, the tournament started at 11.
Yeah, it's January.
I was muted.
It's my best.
I think next game, I'm just going to focus on DPS.
Cause like I feel like, um, I like, I don't know.
I'm focusing too, like I, I just got to be like, if you die,
you die.
Because even when I'm healing, my team's dying.
So what if I stop healing?
yeah you know it's worth a shot like even my team's healing
everyone is still begging for heals so so the clear plan is
maybe i stop healing and i dps as a support
yeah the best way to heal a team is to kill the enemy team
after all exactly
yeah if i kill them first Um, they can't, yeah, if I killed
them first, they can't kill my team, exactly.
Alright.
Well, they had someone left.
Who left?
One, two, three, four.
Well, I don't know why I'm counting.
I know it's five.
I don't know why I started counting.
I know it's five people.
Um, oh, it's Kaiji.
Cool.
I'm tired.
Well, I'm tired, but not really.
Not really.
Maybe I'll stream some arrivals later today.
I do have a really packed day tomorrow as well.
The panel and meet and greet panel and meet and greets and
walk around.
Like, I'm going to try and see if I can walk around off-cut
and then stream.
So I might do a little, I might practice more on Twitch.
I'll practice more off-stream.
And then when I feel like I want to get funny with it, I'll
practice on-stream.
Where is the friends you made a lot?
I don't think we're seeing...
I don't think anybody on...
Oh, other than, like, people were friends on this.
Hey!
They're on new games.
No!
No, that asked, why?
Wait, why is this not starting?
Is there like...
No.
Someone left.
Hey.
Someone leave.
Hey!
No!
Wait, what armor is crashing at?
She crashed.
That was a clip from the end of that game.
all right sorry he's like being a little bratty i have to
put my foot down sometimes like you can't keep begging for
treats because it's not treat time if it was like four then
maybe it's treat time because usually i get food around like
five or six but like i did feed him around 11 like 10 ish so
i just said had to get the new souskin
yeah bro your win is this game started yeah be sure I can't
always give him food you know
hey guys we got three days to practice the actual tournament
did dad gain weight after it no he's still I keep make sure
he's not a fat when you're dog because because you don't
want a fat when you're dog because it's very bad for their
back and their tiny legs because he already had spine
surgery so he's already had spine surgery so i don't think
he has a second chance anymore you can't i don't know you
guys know how the spine surgery works but like for weiner
dogs or long torso dogs they basically cut a little bit of
the cartilage and i don't think we can keep cutting it like
he barks every stream because Because when I'm not
streaming, I can freely ignore him.
Because, you know, I don't care if he's barking.
But then he found out when I'm streaming, I will feed him to
make sure he's shut up.
Because I can't have him barking all.
I can't have him keep barking during stream.
So he knows whenever I'm streaming because I'm talking.
And he knows he's like, wait, she's talking to people.
That means she's working right now.
So I can disrupt her work so I can get more food.
Yeah.
So he trained Doki, trained Doki very well.
He did.
He really did.
He's learned the strat.
Yeah, no hard feelings.
I like to, it's just, luckily this is seating day.
So, and every game has been super close.
So it's not like a total stop.
It's just, it would just, you have to build chemistry and
synergy.
like synergy and figure out what comp works best for us.
Yeah, let's go.
Let's go.
Ben Gambit first.
I don't want to play against it.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Oh my god, we're finally trying a new map.
Oh my god.
That's what I'm saying.
I was like, how is that our best map?
We've only had one scrim and played on that one map one
time.
There's no way this is our best map.
I think there's no there's no way it's our best map we've we
never had a chance to figure out what our best map is like
we never even had a chance to figure it out I was also not
gonna lie I was also getting tired of that map too and then
we can if they're gonna they They banned Luna last time.
If they banned Luna this time, we can play Sue and it'll be
better for us because...
Yeah, we should play Sue Mantis.
Yeah, because we can pull their venom.
Whatever.
But we're going to play them too, so it doesn't really
matter that much.
I want to play Venom Hello.
I'm going to ban Widow, I just don't play it enough.
Yeah, I fuck with that.
I thought that Widow was a problem.
Oh, perfect.
They banned Luna for us.
okay we could spawn hold on this map um brock i don't know
like sue right am i they gonna play it yeah you could brock
sue like bucky or sue i want to play man just it doesn't
really matter from here on up
no i should be can't play man just loki it's but we can play
triple triple with spawn It's a slokie at him.
It's a slokie at him, smile.
I don't think we haven't...
Bro, we haven't practiced that.
True.
Yeah, we could just play normal.
It's probably better.
I think, um, Strange with a team up would be good for Venom.
Pulling back in.
It is, yeah.
You want to play Strange here?
Oh, good.
Try it out.
Well, if you want to play Strange, we would have to just ban
Mag, which...
with anything I could ban mag I feel like I want to ban cap
though I'm not gonna go play venom mag oh it's true it
doesn't matter what you have it honestly just like it really
doesn't matter it doesn't do anything we have to play mag
bro I mean unless you just want to play I mean unless you
want to play the right heroes could make all the right it's
like hard because if we want to play Hulk it's like we have
to play like uh we just can't play we just can't it's like
you can't do it we have to play mag that character is too ob
this is a bad like this is a bad like dive map for melee so
i'm gonna go ahead if it goes bad i'll swap black cat and we
can dive in life energy rather powerful weapon against evil
better play invis or mantis this i'll go mantis
they shouldn't have buffers room same same team Hey, Variety
streamers, am I right?
Me and Puffer.
Variety streamers, let's go.
But he played PAL World yesterday.
I did it.
There's Strange Fighting?
I don't know if they're playing Spidey, but they're on home.
No, they're just scouting.
They're scouting our comp.
From the window.
Is that an Ultron?
No, please don't play Triple.
Don't be weird.
We're on Bucky.
Oh my god.
Wait, are they actually on Ultron?
Yeah, it's true.
We're gonna be on Ultron.
Jesus Christ.
Holy shit.
We got that.
Shoot him down.
We can win.
I'm gonna- I'm swapping black at ASAP.
I'm gonna get rid of that blood splish again.
That's why I dive.
We have to play really well over our venom hit.
All right.
I'm see- Oh.
Don't die.
Oh.
You gotta chill.
I need heals here.
I need to run.
Shoot venom.
I'm dying.
They're not at least right now.
Venom, Venom, Venom...
Yep.
He's on, he's on, he's on.
The Venom is solid- We're trying right now.
Take care.
Joe's back to you.
Can we walk?
Yeah?
Yeah, we don't have a bat.
I think he's slam though.
Wait a few seconds.
Ultra one, ultra one, ultra one, ultra one!
No embers shield.
Bucky one, Bucky one.
Keep shooting Ultra and keep shooting Ultra.
Don't let this guy walk on the sink.
Upchange.
Upchange, put that.
Yeah, we're not gonna walk for this.
Change one, change one, change one, change one, change one.
I'm 70% here.
I need care, I'm one HP.
Where are you?
Oh.
He's behind us.
Just turn on strange, turn on strange everyone, turn on
strange.
We're TPing, we're TPing.
Yeah, because I'm in touch.
Almost that vault.
No.
Just try not to die.
Can we, can we match triple?
Yeah, I'll match.
Is that possible?
No, no.
I don't think it's, I don't think that's it though.
refighted i i mean yeah yeah i swear we can win on this i'll
swap if we this should be the better compromise really good
the mantis first yeah i'll come out i'll come out why we
can't have them all we can just try and stun it i've been
right here are you guys ready three two one oh you didn't
call it that's quiet i heard yeah mantis mantis mantis kill
her kill her I'm here, gotta call out here.
I heard a yeah, I don't know who called that.
I'll try, I'll try, I'll try, I'll try, I'll try.
Like, I heard a yeah, like...
And I did a countdown too.
He literally said stop when I said one.
Like...
He said yeah, because I...
I just want to...
Let's go, there's three supportals.
They're portaling.
They're going to put a portal as well.
Have to go top left?
Just go top right.
No, no, no, top right.
Top right.
Okay, I'm going.
They border my spine off.
I can't get out of spawn.
We're down.
I can swap farm.
I was looking to dive us.
Oh, wow.
I tried to slow them as possible.
QVN soon.
Well, walk through, walk through troop.
We're, we're just gonna go.
We're out, we're out, we're out, we're out.
I can come here.
I can come to us both and help them.
Yeah, we need help here.
I kind of come off you?
I can't do anything here.
Trying to go mid.
No, I wasn't muted when I did the countdown.
They're going to blame me anyway, but whatever.
I literally heard, yeah, and then I did a countdown, and
they stopped at one.
Leave Maggle.
Let's fight.
This is shameless, bro.
Let's get shameless.
Gotta give me damage.
side they might walk on me two venom two venom off me venom
venom oh my god venom pull venom pull venom we have to trade
venom our venom is gonna die no i'm about venom got poop
high ground that's okay that's okay i'll leave that cross
any heals here yeah you can walk forward you come forward i
don't like each other left let me know what you can do
backline i'll just show it yeah almost back Play slow, play
slow.
I got hooked, I got hooked.
I can hit it.
Nice spell, that's all.
Shoot the Bucky, shoot him back, shoot him back.
Bucky 1, Bucky 1.
Two 1, 2, 1, 2.
I'm 81, I'm 81.
I got Dilder.
Shoot, shot, shot, shot, shot.
Legit 1, legit 1.
I got you, I got you.
I got you.
Ultra 1.
Nice.
Again!
Man is in his room.
No healing on point, no healing on point.
I got it, I got it.
I can all hear?
He doesn't want it...
No, no, no, we're...
We're good.
Wolf guys, Wolf, Wolf, Wolf, Wolf.
Me, Wolf.
We use what we need.
Only what we need.
Strange, strange bit of war.
Strange looking for souls.
Can you help?
I know I'm asleep.
Oh, I'm healing you.
Sleep.
Okay.
Triples.
We can use...
We can use Mantis first.
Mantis first.
Alright.
Three, oh, never mind.
No, no, no, no.
Maybe I don't need, we don't have a.
Don't remember.
When we need, we could use Mantis.
We need you.
I hope Bucky back.
How do you help?
I hope.
All right.
Okay, we might need you.
We might need you.
You trade Bucky.
I'm almost back.
Do you?
I thought we were Mantis.
We are undefeatable.
He's gonna all use, so.
They kill Strange all.
They killed Sticky.
He should not have Venom here.
I'm steaming back then with me.
I'm finding it.
It's fine.
Venom's still behind us.
I don't have sleep.
Shoot the strange on me, please.
Shoot the trench guys.
Range army please.
Shoot this guy.
Hold him in.
Keep going, keep going.
Yep.
Kill his Bucky.
He's late.
Kill the Bucky.
Bucky Bucky.
Bucky, Bucky.
He's high.
Don't die here.
Do not die here.
Okay.
I'm ready.
I'm ready when you hit.
I'm like working out.
Coms are not clear.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, stop Strange, all.
He's looking hardcore.
Yeah, he's looking the side right now.
We can give space.
I'm winning stemming three to...
Yeah, yeah.
Pick your mag.
Go back.
Savi be in the back.
They're all dead.
They're all dead, guys.
I'm holding on.
I'm gonna get ran out by a Doctor Strange in about 2.2
seconds.
I'm gonna die.
I killed two.
I killed the whole team.
I need help.
They're gonna run at me in this room.
I'm helping.
I can't help you over there.
There's a...
Double off, double off, one of two, one.
Two next one, two next.
Okay, I'm resetting, I'm resetting up there.
Just gonna go up there.
Live, they know I'm up here though.
They're going over here.
They're gonna shrink let's take you.
Same spot, Olive.
Yeah, same spot, same spot, yep.
She is strange flying on you, strange flying on you.
Okay, I hope the tanks are flying on.
Yeah, Venom's going well there.
Their entire team is close to you.
Okay, let me know you can slip.
I'm slimmering.
Three, two, one.
I'm dying, Venom died.
I don't know.
I'm running up leaves, I'm running up leaves.
We need help in the back.
Shoot the bucky, Jimmy.
I'm helping you guys, I'm helping you.
Nice.
Benamount, help me live, live, live, live dick, live, live
live...
I can't.
Serve it to the Train, show it to the Trinity.
It's good, Mak, I won't.
Leave it to you to the Venom.
Meet you Venom, meet you, Venom you, Ven.
Back up, we're almost back, we're almost back.
Just live.
I'm all here.
I'm 96, I'm 96!
Lucky one, lucky one, lucky dead.
Winnable, winnable, you trade.
Look strange, look the strange.
Get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get
out, get out, get out, get out, get out, get out.
She's seeping and seeping and seeping and see her.
Can you, can you damage him?
I couldn't.
I was already dead.
I'm looking old here.
Looking old here.
Can you walk me along?
I took venom.
Ventus one, the whole one, the whole one, Loki one, Loki
one.
I mean, I'm resetting.
I'm resetting.
I'm taking a different angle.
Wait, wait, wait.
If the TP.
They use TP, they use TP.
Venom touch, venom touch, stop venom touch.
please please stop venom touch he doesn't make it oh my god
good good i just have to i just have to shoot this venom the
whole game bro dude she did too hard right now there's just
i think the comms is just so messy including which side i
think the comms are way too messy just say just do it when
we need and i thought that's taking your time the comms is
just all yeah bro i'm i don't i'm not confident in talking
anymore because it's like they're gonna contest There's
three call.
Yeah.
And the fact that, because I would ask, do you want it now?
Because they want, they don't mic.
It's like bouncing between micromanage and like, they want
to micromanage, but they don't want to micromanage at the
same time.
I remember half my gold wishes do not register stuff.
Round two.
Give her?
Yeah.
Nothing heals the soul like a bit of gardening.
So like, someone said, yeah.
And then I was like, who said, yeah.
Yeah.
They're gonna like run at me.
Yeah, like they say do it when me.
So they're relying it all on me.
But then if I fuck it up, then it's my...
Just call it when you think you want it.
When they run at me, I need...
I need Olive to slam and then I can look for kills.
And then they're gonna try to run at me.
But I'll just live with it.
That's the thing.
It's just way...
The columns are way too messy.
Just double damage just be top left.
And then Olive goes like...
And then Olive can prove it.
Give me two so I get the full 60 seconds.
Start this castle on strangers, punish her angle.
Oh, she could be.
Whatever you want to do.
Shoot at him off guard.
Shoot at him.
Then we know he's already out.
I can look, okay, I can look to his back line.
You ready?
Yeah, three, two, one.
Walk, walk, walk, shoot the back line, bro.
It was a take.
She's a back line.
Help him.
Yeah, you're out.
Help your hell out.
Okay, I'm out.
I don't have another leave.
I have to get out.
Wait, I didn't kill him.
No.
They have a side lock too.
They're gonna pull my team.
Yeah.
I got the time.
Back up.
It's fine.
We need a backup.
Don't die.
Don't die, don't die.
We're good.
Good lift.
I'm gonna play main now.
I'm gonna play more main.
I'm gonna drop the number.
I'll be caught.
When you're ready to hit backline, that's when we go.
Yeah.
I'm ready whenever.
Bucky.
Just go.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Bucky, I need help here.
She got him out.
I'm no leaves.
Bucky, Bucky in the weed, Bucky in.
Zap him.
I'm already tough right here.
I slept somebody.
Bucky one, Bucky one.
I'm summoning two, three.
Bucky, no, Bucky no way.
Bucky in, Bucky in.
No.
Bucky's coming.
3, 21.
Slamming 3.
I'm on save this.
I'm all first.
Kill the Bucky guys, kill the Bucky.
Kill the Bucky, you're out.
Slamming 3, 2.
I'm 96, I'm 96.
Yeah, I'm 99, 99, 99.
I got- Oh.
Jade.
You one willing to help?
You're taking the binge, today.
You're a liter.
Cage!
I'm gonna go top right.
Can we start walking up?
Yeah.
Can we have strange up?
They have strange, yeah.
I'm gonna go top right.
Can we start walking up?
Yeah, can we damage him, man?
Can we damage him better?
I know.
Oh, we are.
Oh, yeah.
That was it.
Lucky one.
I'm dead out of this one, I'm pretty sure.
Gigi.
Get it right now.
I need help.
I need it.
Venom,
Venom, Venom, Venom, Venom.
Incenting 3, 2, 1.
Half pound, go troll.
Call him.
Walk up, walk up, walk up.
I have both supports on me.
Me to walk.
Help me, help me, help me, help me, help me.
I think I might ask the sub to take over for me on Sunday.
I don't, I don't think, I'm sad.
They've done it.
I'm actually sad now.
Let's down.
Who's to three..
Cradd Occ 거죠 Fabrai with you.
White one, Bucky go back again.
Samuans are just flying on us.
I mean to shoot Venom.
Shoot Venom, shoe Venom, shoot Venom, turn Venom, turn the
Venom.
Binom, Paddy gave that.
Paddy gave, that.
Maddy gave Casem.
We are where we are.
I'm all thinking.
Walk with Venthy.
Walk, walk, walk.
Shoot Venom!
Get a one HP.
Three tolerant.
You don't see that.
I mean, you have to, I mean, I have to give him.
soon i'm gonna keep you up my dog is all so sad
hey no i don't know what we can do
it's okay me and puffer both feel the same me and puffer one
feel the same I just feel bad now I can see I can feel the
passive aggressiveness from sticky and potato and I don't
feel comfortable anymore I I don't feel comfortable anymore
yeah good
the good thing is we could still do better on sunday don't
get get too discouraged leave another i feel like they'd be
happier i think we have yes they'd be happier yeah i just
don't want to let my team down and they were gonna give me a
sub on sunday and i just don't with passive aggressiveness
you guys just want to try the dive full dive Hulk, whatever.
I'm going to ask Bulger.
I think I think we should do it where I do
practice.
I've been practicing, like, I've been spending lots of hours
practicing.
Uh, it's just scheduled, like, scrims wise.
We only got first scrim yesterday.
Um, Yeah, it's just...
Yeah.
I just don't fuck with passive aggressive.
They sent the fucking wall.
They sent the entire army off to you, bro.
And we can't win!
I know, man, I killed one and we still won!
We won the fight.
God damn, we won the fight.
At least we won the fight.
Like, look at Moxie's running into...
They're just running at me.
And then they just start running at me and they...
Yeah, they killed me eventually.
clutter bro it's just impossible i don't know what to do
passive aggressiveness but like mood is down try the the
adam luna i feel like that was our strongest and it's just
yeah i'm trying not to be like too affected by it but it's
just the hey it was the team captain so at the end of the
day it's up to you i'm now sad i honestly felt like i was
doing the most when i was playing we could do adam luna we
could just ban mantis and ban gambit and then play adam luna
like look at this bro Tato, Tato, did you see what I did to
this venom, bro?
Tato.
You have to see this shit.
Look what I was doing to this venom.
Like, hold on.
Look at my screen share.
Bro.
This, they started running at me, and I was just like...
I was legit shitting on them.
There's cod zombies out here.
Like, oh my god.
Like, this guy's just aping my shit.
He lost.
Mother versus son.
Poop versus butt.
What the fuck?
What am I listening to?
Drama maxing.
Yeah.
He's role maxing.
I just feel bad.
Well, that is tough.
I'm not going to cry.
I feel bad.
I just hate.
Because I can tell.
I can feel it.
I can feel all the hate.
So I'm trying not to feel bad.
It's alright.
And then my team feels like they'll be better.
If my sub plays fully on Sunday.
Like that's fine with me too.
i'll be right back one second
he's just joking sorry this the entire mood for this team
has been pretty downer
yeah no everyone stopped laughing
i'm gonna give him a treat now
yeah even during like team canada i was just I was just
vibing during Team Tech Canada.
Um, he finally got what he won.
He got me when I'm...
He got me when I'm already weak, you know?
He's already got me.
He's already...
Yeah, he hit me with the lowest.
Wait, it's the dumb map, by the way.
Yeah, hello?
Am I mudded?
I just muted myself on accident, sir.
I'm there now.
Uh, yeah.
It's the weird Dom map.
It's like the old one.
Who am I gonna banish from this?
Yeah, so they ban Spider-Man, by the way.
Or do I ban gamut?
Maybe if I'm silent, they'll forget I'm on Hulk.
If I ban gamut, if I ban, they're gonna play like triple
support.
Oh my god, no, no.
I also had like a really, during the work message, there was
a really frustrating moment where there was like
miscommunication during my work messages that I had to fix.
Um, so that also, on top of that and this, it was like, wow.
It is like, oh, no.
Yeah, I had to, like, fix.
That's why I was, like, so locked in earlier, because I had
to deal with, uh...
I had to deal with, like, a miscommunication thing that I
had to fix really quick.
Do I have to, like, ban Ultron against these fucking guys?
dudes oh my god they're banning Hulk like this is shameless
they're gonna play ultron shameless they are gonna play
ultron we're just gonna run it oh just ban triple barrel ban
ultron I guess wait we can be even cringier we can play Loki
mantis Luna if we want to be even cringier we can protect
I don't even know no I don't think we play triple yeah it's
just gonna be two to two you can protect like i think mantis
luna you can protect like venom oh yeah venom venom sure
venom it all right listen my theory on the bucky band last
is that the other team doesn't know how to play hella but
wait do they have a dive player do they have like a blackout
player no it's it's newton and j3 on dps right bro they're
just playing like wait if they're gonna Wait, surely I just
met Angela, right?
Big puff for Angela?
I mean, that's where it doesn't matter that much.
Like what else, everything else I've been.
I think there just needs to be like one main shock color.
Go Bucky, go Bucky also.
There's been like...
There's been...
And then...
I'm not judging.
You have to play, yeah.
Yeah.
Your energy is a powerful weapon against evil.
All of you could go Venom or Tankful.
I yeah I was just thankful being good Venom is like first
that's the main issue the comms are way too cluttered like
Penny you're just gonna get destroyed alright now we're
clicking heads Taito we got this bro yeah yeah is this a
good penny map do you think he knows the nest spots and shit
bro I should if he knows the lineups I mean if he knows
lineups on this map he's got it bro I'm just like oh Wendy
tell me too I'm just gonna get my I don't trust my instincts
anymore bro this is for the prediction we have to win this
one for the prediction we actually have to win this one i'm
not trolling okay okay this is our first map win bro like
type shit like got it bro i'm making a lot of mistakes just
play uh play left side i can shoot the oliv can like go give
give a plate to all of you they can like luck right side
hook the back line the battle starts in four two yeah well
we can just shoot the fuck out of them because they're gonna
have like no fucking shield tank yeah just like wait is
Groot open big puff of mag wait we go top right yeah Groot
is open if this doesn't work I mean I'll have do you play
Groot now that penny penny's like false yeah yeah my bad
yeah I do play Groot don't take point bingo left side okay
okay okay yeah help me take left yeah yeah I'm dropping I'm
dropping I'm dropping Go point, play back a point.
Yes, he does have line up.
Care mines, care mines, right underneath you.
Just shoot the fuck out of the venue, bro.
Yeah, yeah.
I hope that leaves anymore.
I need help, I need help!
Help me, help me, help me!
Shoot back, shoot back.
Back up.
Help save, take, bro.
Leave the backup, leave the backup.
Yeah.
You could go Groot.
Yeah, I think you should go Groot.
I'll go Groot.
Oh,
I'm so tired.
Should let me go hide in the penny though.
Yeah, yeah.
Can we even get up there?
I think we have to go.
Yeah, you can all work up.
I'll go.
Buckies, buckies out.
Here, buddy mine's in the chat.
Here mine's close.
Look out.
I'm hit.
He's one, he's one, he's one.
I killed him,
I killed him.
We still hit.
We'll initiate with Mantis.
We have Mantis all up.
We'll initiate with it.
You're hooked.
Mantis is like...
Yeah, you're hooked.
Look down.
Miss.
There's a trap in the Penny mines.
That's the one.
Nice.
Bucky one, Bucky one, Bucky one.
Massive hook massive Shoot match him, could I kill him kill
him kill him kill him?
They're still mines Looking at ult here looking at 3 2 1
It's your big你 It's everyone kill them kill them kill them
kill they kill them I don't really shoot anyone shoot
another I need a 독 I need an Let me help.
Penny, penny, penny, penny.
Penny, penny, penny.
Yeah, I got you.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Nice, we serve, we know.
You can play the choke, my ult.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm coming, everyone.
I got their, uh, oh, I don't know what you, mag out.
Mag out something.
Whenever you need it, whenever you need a mag out.
What do they have?
Nothing.
They have 50 Elsa.
Magret's out.
I'm looking for my Elsa.
I want to do it early.
Can you bump me?
Take?
Yep.
Please?
Oh.
3, 2, 1.
Honestly, it's hard to see you.
I'm bottom.
I'm point.
Okay, I'm backing up then.
Up for Oso.
You got the penny, got the penny.
No, that's bad.
Yeah, I thought you going to stay height.
Yeah, Bucky duck, bucky duck.
Yeah, that's what I was trying.
How can you get him.
We can walk.
Shoot out they all night.
They're all out there.
Knock, shoot them.
Get the maxd.
Chief the max.
Shoot them back.
Shoot them.
Elsa, Elsa.
Wait, I'm all played by myself.
I'm all played by myself.
Elsa, Elsa, Elsa.
Thanks for the love.
Okay, die.
Elsa, Elsa.
Here's a penny turret behind us.
Penny's still here.
Oh, I'll do that.
I got bubbled.
I have bubbled.
I have bubble.
Nice, nice, nice.
Whoa, what?
Elsa, Elsa, Elsa.
Elsa, what?
Look, mantis, mantis.
Look at the support.
Point, point, point, point, point.
We're gonna flip.
We're gonna go back, we're gonna go.
We can't, we can't.
I'm dead to this.
You need to take it back.
Care minds, care minds.
Yeah.
Order of space.
There's a mag alone.
I think they're going high.
They're the same thing.
Can we kill Penny guys?
Yeah, yeah.
They meant so.
I'm gonna have your doll.
Okay, now Penny won!
Penny won!
Oh, we got penny mine.
Awesome, awesome.
Annie ran at me.
You can die on.
We have TP here.
TP, potato, potato.
I have all out.
We make it, we make TP, we make TP.
We can Bucky Groot.
I need the displacement of it.
Jump jump jump jump jump jump.
Taddle for good luck for good luck.
They're bunkering under after they wall.
You guys can walk out.
You guys can all walk out.
We can all walk out.
Just walk out.
Yeah, yeah, walk, walk, walk.
I have a shield in a second.
I need shields.
I pulled the bag.
No, I don't have leaves.
I don't have leaves.
I'm trying to think.
Nothing heals the soul like a bit of gardening.
I mean, it was close.
It was close.
It was pretty close.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, not bad.
It's pretty close.
30 seconds before you attack.
get ready close to we're close to both support alts mantis
first
everything was pretty close yeah i should have
said that he put a target on me chris the content creator
says that all you need to do is capture the mission area got
it Just the right side point.
Set your big wall up.
Try to lift and make space in the next corner.
Updater with you.
And all I'm pending.
Yeah, yeah, he's close.
He's close.
Break it, break it, break it.
It's bad as best.
I have to use to save you.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
Kill through maybe.
We'll pause.
We have second trink.
Countdown.
He's gonna have a train roll.
Walk with them.
I got hit.
One!
I knew her, bro.
I was calling it.
Go there for me and Mimi.
Help Sicky, winnable, winnable, help Sicky, help Sicky.
Also, one behind.
Oh my!
They go?
Nice sticky, nice.
Displey, I call that, if I call out Strange Eye, like I
need, uh, someone to look at that.
Okay, shoot them.
We can wall them when they walk up to this, uh, kind of like
ramping.
Someone's left side.
Yeah.
Behind you, behind you, behind you, behind you, behind you.
Look, I looked, I looked, look at this back.
Look at this back, please.
Help me, help me.
He's up behind.
I'm gonna go shoot the penny, bro.
He's still behind on you, damn it.
I'll just leave the penny.
I was the right side.
I'm running at this guy.
Okay, we're going.
That's the one.
Maybe I'll just kill him.
I don't have all.
Yeah, I don't have all.
Play left side.
Go try to get back to us.
Yo, I need...
Shoot the Bucky, shoot the Bucky.
Bucky 1!
I almost have it!
I'm trying.
I got you!
I just halted fucking Aaron.
I hate my life.
Looking at me with that.
Good bro, I'm in.
I just bolted air and die.
Root Bucky, we should just be able to kill.
Just look for a bad Groot on there.
Yeah, that's real power.
I think they have Cloak, yeah, they have Cloak all.
Yeah, they have Cloak all.
They can definitely kill through though if you hit their...
No more leaves right now.
I'm trying to farm leaves.
Let me know if you're going to go down.
So you're ready to go.
Shoot.
Actually like, shoot.
Walk left, uh, walk right.
You gotta walk into the mines.
Remember Kai?
Also one, else one, else one, else one, nice dude.
Look for a good all.
Just look for a good all.
Or you she got, I slept with Bucky.
Look at the Mantis guys.
Um, I need help.
Oh, no.
Mantis, Mantis, Mantis, Mantis.
Mantis mantis, mantis, Mantis, Mantis, mantis.
I have reset, I have reset.
Penny kill Penny through we can we can kill Penny kill Penny
There's still one the old still one I'm all here Yeah, these
are what we need they have mantis all as well We can we can
kill through their mantis with group You gotta look for it
though.
I see.
You walk into these mines?
Break it, break it, break it.
Walk it, walk it, walk it.
The Fogudo, the Fogudo on their Mantis.
The Fogudo on their Mantis.
I got the, I got the Slip, Mantis.
I need help here.
I second there also.
Oh, I'll try and let you heal.
Okay.
They use both, it's fine.
We're going to get Luno to pull them out.
They're going to have poke soon.
We need to build our Luno.
Take damage.
We have mag ult for like one of their DPS also.
I think they have Bucky all.
You can mag up when he Bucky also and try to kill him.
I was just going right side.
Can we, can we chal that?
Can we chal these guys right side please?
I pulled him.
I pulled him for this guy.
Also, also, also, also, nice.
Nice crew.
Bucky left side.
I'm still on the penny.
He's one.
Yeah, he's out.
Penny's out.
We can win.
They're going left.
Shoot them left.
It's big.
ha- Are you guys still?
Bucky still.
Bucky's still killing.
Look at us!
Fabry, in us, in us, in us, in us, in us, in us.
Cookie, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak,
cloak, cock, cloak.
The back는데 is one of it.
Just hold it.
One, shoot, shoot.
Penny, penny, penny.
Penny, penny.
Penny ,剛剛.
There's a cloak in me, Stiggy, yep.
SPEAKER 2.
Good play.
Nice and nice job.
Yeah.
We mag ult for Whatever DPS ult they use Or whatever
Whatever alt they use In this matchup It's literally just
Zotate You can alt anything Like any ult they use You can
ult They press you You can press it Doesn't matter What alt
it is Except if it's mag ults It's their mag ult You don't
You don't press So they're gonna go first With the DPS ult
Maybe like Eulsault Get ready to react with your ult And
then try to kill the Eulsault Or some shit If you got that
right 30 seconds Try to be able to get Oh my god.
Calls your list.
I've been just...
The altar.
Do it when you feel like it.
I'm sorry.
I don't like that call.
I've been doing it when I feel like it, but...
I don't like that call at all.
I...
He was captured in the mission area.
You got it?
Walk top.
Come on, stay locked in, guys.
We got this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're gonna have cloak.
Stronger than ever.
Close to Mentos.
I actually don't know where to walk on this map.
I'm pretty sure it's better if we just take point and big
wall on point somewhere.
I don't know.
But I'm gonna play top.
I'll drop one on.
I think they're on widow.
They're on widow.
I have the height.
Like, can you guys help me here?
I think we just walk in the back line, no?
I agree.
Yeah.
They're like split.
Can you guys help with me?
They're over here.
Like J3 and R warrior in this fight.
They're on point though.
Broke me, broke me, broke me.
Broke me, broke me.
I'm trying to.
Broke, bro, bro.
He slept, he slept.
He's won.
I got him.
I need help.
All right, you tried me.
Drop, drop, drop, drop.
We need to drop the cloak on point.
Shoot the cloak on point.
Give me, give me, give me, give me, give me, give me care,
need care, need care.
You can magle if we need.
You can magle.
Maybe.
I'm not.
Gotta hit the mantis.
Live.
We need a stable.
Yeah, guys.
I'm just coming back from spawn.
I died first.
Yo, when they split like that, we should just, we need to
run it like the people who are Listen, listen, listen!
They're gonna have Rogue Alt.
Don't get your Alt 8 by the Rogue Alt.
They use both tranks.
Manta's first.
If they Rogue Alt, we can use Manta's and run at them.
They have no tranks here.
We literally just run at them in a straight line.
I hear Rogue to our left.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm gonna go with the stroke.
I'm going, I'm going.
If you Rogue Alt you can react and- Just kill him.
I'm one-shotting him.
Rogue 1.
Rogue 1-1!
Rogue 1!
Like the Souls movies!
Nice, nice.
Okay, that's fine.
Just go.
Going ahead.
He's gone, he's gone.
He's gone.
Oh, I can't even get to you guys.
Back up the point.
Come on, come on, come on.
Don't TP all of them?
We have both supports.
Yeah, I can.
I can all Q and Q.
Oh, I can't.
No, no, no, don't TP.
Oh, no, no, no.
Don't TP.
No TP.
It's just me and Ray.
It would have got absolutely popped.
They still have no drinks.
Mantis first.
Whenever we need, we can just run at them with it.
They're gonna have Maggle and that's it.
And then we have a free Lulule after.
They're gonna die out of the Maggle.
Just don't die out of the Maggle.
That's why we have to care.
Help is here.
Okay.
Don't run at them here.
We can shoot the venom out.
Yeah, I have a trap.
Shoot venom, shoot venom, shoot venom.
This guy dies.
He's so far in us.
He can die.
No, no, no.
He lives.
I saw one.
There's a two left, two left.
He cleanses me.
Walk on their mat.
He's low.
He has no wheels.
Yeah.
Shoot the venom, shoot the venom.
Venom one, venom one.
Where's the widow?
I think she's main.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Time to celebrate.
We still have both trains, I think.
I think they have, uh, Mantis all by now.
I killed that.
Nice.
They should have Mantis all by now.
Hot potato, hot potato.
I don't know.
I want to stay here.
I want to, like, be in that spawn.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sit here.
They have to use something to, they have to use something to
get out.
I'll go Mantis first.
Mantis behind us somewhere.
They might try to, like...
I think the venom is like, I'm on the venom.
I'm on the Venomable point.
You're flipping it.
Oh, they're hard flanking.
I need help.
Yeah, I got you.
I got you.
Walk the potato.
Help me.
I was a widow one.
Widow one.
We still have Luna and Maggle.
Yeah.
The widow and the...
Widow and the message flanking together.
Take care.
Okay.
I'm getting dove by Venom.
I see.
We can loot all.
Luna, we can loot all.
We shielded.
Bubble.
Do bubble.
Nice.
We got him good.
Three, two, one.
Hit that!
Come on, Joe.
Come on, Joe!
Come on, wait!
Where are you?
I see you!
Qmatter, Pull Venom!
Kill Venom!
It's mega!
It's Uganda!
Kill him!
Kill him, kill him!
Venom, no.
Any help, any help!
Mag!
Kill Mag!
Oh my God!
I will controlled them off point.
Okay, yeah, I have alsoladım!
Oh, yeah.
I have also controlled.
They're strange Shade one He slept, he slept He slept Venom,
Venom, Venom, Venom They have no tanks I'm a water runner
now Top right now I'm behind, I'm behind I'm on me, I'm on
me, I'm on I'm one Wait Wait Oh my god Oh my god We think I
actually got a win.
I actually need to pee.
I'll be right.
I need to pee it out Oh god, no, I need to pee this out
guys.
Oh, no, that's lucky.
That's not that's not fair, bro Bucky's cheating Bucky is
cheating.
Bucky's OP.
Good job guys No good shit.
Sticky while playing, bro.
I'm grinning max volume kid.
I'm grinning max volume.
I'm oh my god i don't think i had a single bad bucky all
game no no yeah it was like a that is crazy bro j3 and r
more you ran at me and all spawned you like yeah i know and
i was like i was like holy i was like i was like where are
these guys and then you finally died i was like oh yeah that
that's where they are oh my
god oh my god oh my first p of the day Oh my god.
With J3 selecting the map, we can actually play other maps.
Isn't that wild?
Isn't that fucking wild?
Alright, let's close it out, team.
2-0, 2-0.
First P of the day.
I swear to God, if they pick Hollow T'Challa, I swear, I
swear to fucking God, Please, take me out of that map.
I swear to God.
I cannot play on that map again.
I swear.
Oh, don't take me back to Wakanda.
Please.
I can't.
Please don't take me back to Wakanda.
Please.
Anything but Wakanda.
wait what is happening in craig's team right now
ironship is giving someone like a router tutorial
these guys have been paused for 15 minutes what no hell no
yo area thanks thank you for the two months bro thank you so
much area thanks thank you bro i appreciate you thank you
for the support bro i'd say carry thank you it was inspiring
like what apparently woofles is like lagging It's like
Resolve is router or some shit.
Oh, oh, you're still there.
Okay, I was going to say it.
I, I, I, it's not Tachala.
It's not.
It's guys.
We're out of Wakanda.
We're, we're out of Wakanda.
They say gross when she saw Amuja.
Now she's bad mouthed.
Think Makanda.
We're so back.
Don, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, Arakko?
Yeah!
As long as it's not Wakanda.
I'm fine.
As long as it's not straight out of Wakanda.
Arakko?
Ew.
As long as it's not Wakanda.
No, no, no.
Oh, what side do we want, by the way?
Attack or defense?
This is really rough on me, because I asked if they could
tell me when to ult.
But it's always feel it out.
like a feel for it all it's really rough on me because
sometimes I I'm like I got to feel it you think it's better
to go a tackle defense because they're like a fucking
defense-sided team they want to play triple support with the
fucking bullshit penny that's fine or defense still defense
good defense good defense defense defense I got feel it all
in my bones we want to tilt them we want to holding them
full and yeah holy will they leave bucky open i mean they
have to the thing is in rank i use mantis aggressively
listen listen they've been bucky we've been widow we play
also hella and we just went that's the thing i put i do when
i play mantis i use it aggressively i don't really use it
defensively so i so i realized that they don't want
aggressive mantis assaults because mantis assault
aggressively is is like I realize every time all
aggressively it's like not what they want and I realized
that I'm presuming oh man they give us the bridge out
thinking thank you look so kind of muted that's my that's me
it's okay it's a make-believe lag and a make-believe fantasy
race so yeah yeah I'm just gonna melee one trick so like
yeah that's the defensively because i don't do it
defensively in rank i like when you're on us it's actually
way better
yeah it's weird when you're like dash and elsa you don't
teleport everywhere on ping yeah bro you gotta teleport
around pink bro on bucky you shove and it's like you rub a
band into a different dimension do you want it as a retreat
uh yo do you want to try the thing where you stand invis on
the spot oh we're on defense fuck no no i don't even know
where i know actually i know what you're gonna say yeah you
know what i'm gonna say yeah yeah yeah no we go actually go
bp go bp with the invis team up oh my we're just banning
dive yo guys we just beat you on front to back well they
lost their all right ban um i think your team's just banning
his dad like mantis on ultram in general ban penny sorry i
have to relearn it because scrims we also use mantis all
aggressively so now we're flipping it i think penny i want
to ban penny or i almost couldn't find penny in the like in
the tank area yeah bro because like even in scrims it was
aggressive mantis all so then like i now can flip it no they
don't play they play mantis it's like that okay I want to
proc yeah I want to proc Mantis I want to proc Mantis this
last band this is this is some mastermind shit listen listen
listen yeah Luna band Luna band play soon what we can pull
the Angela
oh oh okay wait hold on thinking but I think they're just
gonna play Mantis Ultron oh yeah Ultron so I think I just
need to ban fucking Ultron because they have a penny
banch wait banch penny i'm too tired do we need a ban ultra
though like how's snake bro like that should op i feel like
our team has every i don't want them i don't want them tired
now all right no we just i'm saying i don't want the jerome
d 'angelo running around with fucking booping everyone up
our captain's tired and he's our dps the right heroes could
make all the difference so we're on what's mad grude again
mad grude again life energy is a powerful weapon against
evil all right here we go here we go i need a job another 35
if we close it out early brain dead twitch viewers yep yeah
didn't this be good here too um visit you said yeah i want
you to go in this yeah i want you to go in visit instead of
luna so we don't get pulled off the map of the energy on
this first point do i swap the mantis or oh yeah yeah wait
yeah yeah you want to get mantis okay oh the great magneto
himself yes that was confusing oh the sun is fucking peering
through my blinds bro it's a good oh yeah i was the only one
shooting nuts you guys know is that my efforts are i'm
nobody recognized the efforts i give to my team yep wait no
they're about to use uh newton using his jump pack
get the grab get the grab bro taking so much damage yeah you
guys are want health and what helps give me a second yeah we
can drop i don't like this drop drop it dropping right i
don't need there angela angela's feeding angela's feeding
okay we can put a big one keep our space look for a wall
tell us when you're walling nice fuck you dead nice we walk
we walk just don't get grabbed just don't get grabbed angie
above angela top right top right yeah yeah i got it going
mid angela you're gonna pull me up there you go trap i know
big one yeah yeah i know i did tp back angela max flank oh
no no i know this next i'm gonna go on that good hook good
hook good hook hook you we should look to kill the elsa at
the right wall big wall mag big wall man and kill him are
you 98.
i just want me this one i couldn't i couldn't Karen, she
pulled.
Karen, she pulled.
I have a trap for her as well.
Put your big one in this room, Olive.
Like, on me.
Yo, do you see my trap?
Yeah, yeah, I know.
You can't get your arm.
Like, I'm talking to you.
Lucky die, must die.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I got hit, I got hit, I got hit, I got hit.
Wait, break it.
Just break it.
Wait, I hooked her and it didn't cancel.
Wait.
Oh, is that how she altered us?
No, no, no.
It's because, no, she just jumped down at all.
Hey, good stall, good stall.
Oh, I just forgot.
We have Bucky Root just right here.
We can med this first for Midi.
I'm not there yet.
Yeah, look for...
Alright, three, two, one, go.
Look for Groot out!
I got like two of them off the map, I think.
And my goal is to hit.
I got Armory off.
They got me.
I cancelled the all.
Buddy for my life, buddy.
Bucky one!
Bucky Bucky Bucky!
On the right!
Ok, down on the left!
I got- I quit, we can see you!
No, just chill, just chill.
It's fine.
That's good, it's good.
I'm gonna stained Broke.
I'm gonna block the Angelo, on top right.
Somebody TP to a right...
Elhsad to the right.
We have chew all, we have chew all, we need.
Oh god.
You got chew all, you get chew all, you got chew all, josh
aphésitez!
He fucked up!
Max on Max on!
Max on my soul Mac is one, Mac is one, Mac is low.
Bucky, Bucky, nice.
That's good.
There's, uh, uh, Mac is asleep behind, Mantis, Mantis, C9!
No, he's one.
I'm not going.
Circle of life.
Nice sleep.
They're top, they're coming top, coming top.
We're down Mantis for like five seconds.
They have Angelo still again.
We don't have Mantis up though.
Oh, stop right.
I saw one.
I saw dead.
Nice, bro.
Someone's in my trap.
Shooting their mag.
Lift her.
Tell me when you're walling so I can...
I have the right side.
Yeah, hook, hook, hook.
I have it.
Angelo right down.
I'm moving.
I'm looking big one mag.
Look at him.
He's looking for Angelo.
Mag, come back, back out.
I need you to get one.
He's shooting.
I must have griddle.
I'm building another griddle.
Kill him.
I got the L.
Nice.
We're good.
They OTPed out.
I got hooked.
They pulled me in.
Come on.
I still got hooked.
They pulled us in through TP.
Got mine.
Yo, yo, final farming.
Actually, final farming.
All right.
We have group Bucky this way.
Don't get it.
You gotta, like, not project it so the mag can't eat it, by
the way.
Yeah, I know.
I thought you didn't have it.
That is fine.
I'm just hoping to get a good old.
He's loud there.
He matters.
Back one.
You gotta try to damage him.
All right, walk top right.
Look for Brutal.
I'm back.
Watch out.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
I'm walking Angela, man.
Missed out, missed out.
Leak a walk.
Look down.
You're walking.
I'm looking to look here.
On your left, on your left.
Brick sleep, Brick sleep.
Oh my god.
You want that?
Yeah.
Care group, care group.
They forgot all that.
I'm looking, looking.
I'm looking.
On ping, on ping.
Mentos in.
They meant to assault you.
No, I can heal her.
Should I get my ult?
Give me if you can.
Oh, trying, trying, trying, trying.
Oh, trying, trying, trying.
Oh, you're being pushed back non-stop.
Reset, reset, reset, reset.
Maybe TP, TP, TP, TP, TP.
Take yes, TP.
I have to put it down now.
It's looking Angela.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's still a chance to stop them.
I live to fight another.
We can we can play their side of the map play their side go
this side
I tried Yeah
Put an engine look at that Yeah, yeah, pull their Oh, we
have to stop on Walk walk walk walk walk I'm on a point.
I'm on point Minus one's dead Mac Mac Mac Mac And you won't.
Hello, man.
Go back, back, back, back, back.
Okay.
Wanna you build all.
Come here, please.
I need assistance.
I'mma trap.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm looking for my old.
Jump, bubble, jump bubble.
Oh.
Yeah, where are you?
We're 92.
It's big, it's big.
I need help.
I got pulled in.
I got a load.
Unable.
Ventus him.
There's someone left side alone.
I'm big walling.
You okay?
I got Razor Gurus.
Unable.
Dodge.
Wait.
Oh no, they can reset.
Yes.
Nothing heals the soul.
I'm trying to build my Bucky up so you can combo with you,
Alex.
Okay.
I need care.
Just don't die now.
Don't die now.
I'm coming back.
We can walk through top right, okay?
Walk through top right.
Be daring.
Are they broke?
I'm trying.
I broke, I broke, I broke.
I broke, I broke.
I'm so low.
No, I'm dead.
Yeah, DP stands on us.
Go ahead.
I'm 84.
It's fine.
They're not pushing the card at all.
They only 30 seconds.
We've won.
We've time for a Bucky group combo.
They're gonna mag ult.
Make sure.
Shut it.
Help out.
Do not get free credit, though.
Yeah, Pippin.
28.
Okay.
Alright, give me one, give me one.
Two damage.
Yeah, walk the one, one.
Yeah, I'm also.
I'm looking good old.
Looking good old.
3, 2, 1.
It's deep, it's deep.
I wouldn't hold that one way, I don't know if that one would
look bad.
I did use a saver, Mag.
And back up, back up!
Back up and back up!
Now, no.
No, fuck it, fuck it.
Fuck it.
Fuck it!
Yeah, put me back here.
I'm just gonna die for one of you, I think.
I don't know why I should just let our Mag die.
They have the Inver shielding, the Elsa is just shooting our
tanks on me as well.
I go run over again.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Match their comp.
Do you play Angela?
Yeah, I do.
Just full match their comp.
I want to see if you do better in a minute.
Is that right?
I don't ult and our mag dies or our ult and then they bucky
ult it.
I was just like, I'll take the gamble.
I don't know.
It felt like the Bucky was just gonna hold it.
We were just playing all chicken.
Yeah, group feels like Ascendavan.
I don't like that character.
Okay.
I don't know if Bucky's good here.
I could go Hella and play left side of this map.
I'm not.
If we're not gonna play...
Widow also open.
Yeah, I'm terrible.
Get ready.
Yeah, that's our worst character, like never really.
Neither was clear.
I'll give it a fight or two on Bucky.
It's no bother me less.
And then I'll swap to Hello if I need to.
Yeah,
I think it's just a difficult situation to be in.
Alright, stay locked.
Let's just go right side.
Can you hear me?
Real quick?
Yeah.
Fuck him in.
Angel is close, Angel is close, right?
I have a trap for you, I have a trap for you.
Looking for Angie, are they bubbles?
I saw him play.
Shoot him, shoot him, shoot him.
Angie, Angie, Angie, Angie, Angie, Angie, Angie!
Oh, it's just a cologne I got.
I'm slept, I'm slept.
In my trap again, in my trap.
Angie, Angie, Angie, Angie.
Angie, Angie, Angie, Angie, Angie, one, two, one, two!
I'm fine.
Come on, pull them off.
I'm behind, I'm behind.
I need heal.
Where are you?
Chill, chill, chill, chill, chill.
You only have...
Should I just...
I just want?
I just want...
I don't have him please, I don't want to use, I don't want
to use, careful.
Get off the lava wall.
Yes.
That was 1000% better.
I think.
I marked that part too.
Potato play made, I'll play that part.
Yeah, yeah, hook.
Cook down.
Try to take the also trap.
Yeah, I got also trap.
Also off.
I'm 95.
I don't care.
It's a background.
I don't.
You can't.
You can use it when you need to work.
Shoot Angelo.
Sure hook, sure hook.
I got it!
Bucky trap.
I'm fine, fine, fine, fine.
Bucky one, Bucky one!
Bucky one!
I know.
IGF, IGF.
Angelo's gonna be there.
Angelo, Angelo, Angelo, Angelo.
Angelo, Angelo, Angelo, Angelo, Angelo.
No, I traded.
Even, even, even.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna have to take an angle top of him.
We can match, we can match, we can match, we can match.
He's got full, we got full, we got full, we got full.
Stay off the map, bro.
Stay off the map.
Fuck you one, fuck you one.
Fuck you dead.
I got it.
Andrew grab it.
Andrew guys, kill Angela and RNG.
I'm going to go save a bit.
It's still injury, injury, injury.
He's still low.
I don't have any more leaves.
What is this about?
I'm going to take a top left angle on them.
Can you damage me?
Yeah.
You know about me.
You're getting R marks.
You come to me, Olive.
Yeah, I got you on.
Grab him to grab him.
Man, just sling man.
I'm looking at him.
I slept right.
They all stuffed bottom right.
I was just close right.
In my trap.
Kill him.
I blocked her.
Grab him.
I need you double.
Kill him.
I don't know.
I have one, I go on, I do one.
We have Anshawa on for now.
I have a lot.
I think we need to load it.
We're here?
It's 12 seconds.
Yeah.
help you or hello woke up woke up i'm trying i gave you my
leaves oh
i had to get a position to go give those leaves someone's
teaching wait you touch that's all i got zero two three i
had to get out of position, too.
That sucks.
Yeah.
I didn't want to push up, but then I didn't want to get
yelled at for not healing, so I went pushed up for it.
I mean, where have we even banned Angela?
Like, I don't know.
There's no winning for me.
We never thought you were playing Gambit into this team.
Is that okay?
Yeah.
Taito, what do you think?
Well, obviously, I think it's, I'm down always.
I think it should be fine.
That sucks.
I was the closest, so I had to go up to heal too.
I gave him my leaves.
I don't know,
we just don't converge.
Like, we killed two and then it's like, no one's, everyone's
lost in the team fight.
Like, no one's talking.
It's like, I feel like the team fight starts and then
everyone's like goes mute yeah i know yeah yeah
uh oh well like damned if i do damn if i don't first of all
but like yeah but like i mean we got a map just I'm out.
Dugues, we banished the first that we just...
It was just like, I was just playing a very bad situation.
Whatever map, Lee.
I gave you my leaves, please respond.
I guess I could have just, I should have just, I could have
just let him die there.
But like, I could have just let him die.
Like I literally, I think gave him like two leaves, right?
Yeah, yeah.
And then like, there was nothing I could do.
So...
Same ban approach.
I want to play for Black Cat Dive.
Because that's...
I want to ban...
I want to ban Elsa second.
Oh, but then they're going to play Penny, bro.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know.
Wait, do we know we don't want to go...
Wait, wait.
Then we don't go to the museum.
It's like Penny map.
Bro, but like...
I swear we don't know.
Angela, dude, that map is an Angela map.
It's just an Angela map.
It was a tough call.
I should just let him die.
Central Park, Central Park.
Oh, it has to be convergence.
Central Park.
wait no de jalia because we're gonna play penny if they're
gonna play penny i don't want to i don't want to play penny
again for penny player what wait a minute yeah okay so we're
gonna play penny also they can't play penny on de jalia like
it's not possible penny on de jalia is like i don't know how
the to spell that if they go penny on de jalia then we can
literally just go full front to back shoot them all right um
the ban phase i want to just play for i'm not gonna say it i
have no idea what to do
i was gonna i'm not gonna say it tons of fun thank you you
can
say r you can say r you can say r wait what does that mean
the gambit band the same and we're gonna ban like we're
gonna play for loki mantis sue a 14 year old kid triple
sport i'll play mantis and then potato on elsa olive on guru
zoteik on mag it should work daniel shouldn't be able to do
anything to us we've lamps and soup all so i was gonna say
we're letting i was gonna say do you have any adults here we
can ban out ban out bucky so they can't play elsa bucky
here's the highest ranked we just here's the highest ranked
though highest rank i can play over yeah but okay high is
ring triumphs over age right and we're gonna play mantis
we're gonna play mantis loki sue i'm gonna be on mantis and
then somebody's gonna be on loki somebody's yeah but i have
the least amount of knowledge i'm just a rank granny i smell
like it's angela bro like we're just losing two and five
five we can just mirror the same comp we can mirror the same
with the Groot and just allows the land to replace you and
pull him.
He is the adult now.
I agree.
Alright, we're ready.
The ping is insane.
Yeah, he's the only Australian.
He's the only player from the Asia side that that's in this
tournament.
And because of that, we don't get balanced latency because
they're...
Let's go!
Alright, click to one.
Click to one.
The Europeans and any players did not want it especially if
they're in east coast me i'm on west so it doesn't matter
for me all right it doesn't really matter for me for ping
wise
like what are our thoughts i want to know what we think um
what if we ban mag and play like strange strange group or
are you confident on strange to take yeah i i kind of want
to play strange group i always lag during ban phases i mean
venom black cats open.
It's okay.
Yeah, but they're gonna go Penny.
Yeah, yeah, we can play for Venom Black Cat.
Okay, okay.
Ben, Ben, give it.
Ben give it first.
You can proc whatever Elsa or Mantis.
Or Black Cat.
I want to get my conflict.
Or Venom.
I don't even know.
They don't know what we're gonna play for.
You could just proc Elsa and we could just last proc.
No, I want to bend.
I want it to bend also.
Okay, uh...
I'll try to also, I can play also, you can play cat.
Hmm.
Yeah.
These are calming.
I think every team is very equal, though.
Ban Angela.
Wait, what?
Okay.
Like, the pennies are going to fuck up the...
Oh, we don't need to play dive anymore.
If they're not going to play Angela, we can...
Okay.
No, Penny's really bad on this map, no?
What do you think about Penny on this map?
It's like decent.
He has the traps.
You need to realize.
If you think so.
We're back in Wakanda.
I was like, wait a minute.
There's a panther here.
There's a floating mask.
Black Black Cat.
Oh my god.
They're gonna play triple.
There are.
It's too many vague cons.
You're gonna play triple?
Lord, my eyes.
Triple's not good in the- No!
A good- the coordinated black guy dies takes triple.
No.
No!
He already had his treat.
What?
He's already had his treat.
He can't have another treat.
Angela is not protecting.
Let me think about this last ban.
Yeah, I had the best of support.
Porter just Angela right like I feel like I just ban Angela
and what about Bucky if he plays Bucky Elsa Bucky Elsa could
be that really likes Wakanda oh no but I feel like I don't
want him all widowed yeah yeah ban Angela
this is kind of fucked because Elsa Bucky's still open the
right heroes could make all the difference that's good for
that life energy is a powerful weapon have to do the triple
surprise yeah whatever we actually got this just damage
boost our dive i thought we're doing triple supply um is
there a take shoot the back alignment team up i give the
living bullet ps everyone come on two snowflake on sticky
yeah yeah do they have a black apple no they don't okay i'll
get no it's just like hey don't take your main damage you
just shoot there yeah i'm they're just gonna shoot this
energy wise war they will be on bucky and they will be on
bucky like in the past i've had um a main shop caller to
tell us micro manage when the alt supports by assaulting
everybody so just because obviously you know they know
better but i think the reason is that since everybody scrims
they're all playing as if like everyone knows um so that's
like the there is a lot of that is like the biggest issue at
the moment is because everybody's playing in a way we're
like oh you should all know what you have to do but because
this is a creator tournament um i don't know what do you see
and the more the more hello no more hello no more yeah hello
no more yeah markey just give them damage just before they
go and i can shoot okay Yeah, I need a game.
I'm gonna dive in, I'm dying his brother.
Can we hit back up?
We kill him more?
I don't want to sleep now.
Alright, hopper mag, careful mag.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, tell the thing.
Go, go, go, go, walk in guys.
Walk in, walk in the down.
I'm trying to help you.
I'm hitting you.
We need help here.
You guys are good.
You guys are good, bro.
Heal me, heal me.
It's a nice deep freeze.
It's good.
He looks like you.
All right, let me know you can hit.
I'm marking the venom out again.
Yeah, I can hit one over.
I'm saving leaves.
I'm out.
He went, he went, he went.
All right, ready, ready, ready?
Yeah, hitting three.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Yo, yo, yo.
I was sleeping the...
The front line, bro.
I'm behind, I'm behind.
Your back line is getting really hard.
Yeah.
I had to throw the sleep on the venom.
What does it take?
Just mock them ag.
Got you good.
Oh, TP?
Yeah, TP.
I don't think we make it.
No, we don't.
Yeah, we don't.
I'm stopping there.
Stop venom.
Nice.
Yeah, I got it.
Oh, we took spawn?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I'm back fast.
Yeah, we should have.
Come in, come in.
Just mock their knife with me.
It's six.
Yep.
Thank you.
There's a venom on me.
I'm working venom out.
All right, let the card move and then we can hit.
I'm gonna move to...
Yep.
All right, ready?
Ready?
Yeah, ready.
3 2 1 on mantas mantas mantas 2 OK, mantas 1 mantas 1 Tap,
get out get out, get out Yeah, I'm out I got you Can you hit
card after Kahlo?
I got mantas first Yeah, I need to Yeah, I can go I can go I
want HP, I want HP I'm just chilling You can hit you I'm
good, I'm heading That's quarter one, that's quarter one We
have Venom on us We look close
I'll let you heal.
I bought this fight.
Mantis first.
They're down the train.
I'm going to try to go first with mine.
We're good.
They have whale.
Just get the new whale.
I think you're just going to whale me.
Are you ready?
I can hit back guys.
Three, two, one.
Mantis, Mantis.
We can Mantis, Mantis, Mantis.
Back up, back up, back up.
We can back up.
Yeah, I'm matching it.
We have Walker Trace.
There's no- No damage on him.
A damage.
We can- we can lose a Nex.
We can lose a Nex.
Yeah, I'm gonna wait for a- Oh, he got a Mag.
All right.
I'm trying to shoot.
I'm gonna name our old bridge.
You had a shield though, huh?
Yeah, I thought- I thought that'd mine.
Okay, they've no Tranc this fight.
We've- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should just- we just have an all three.
We need for a- but I don't solve them now.
Play my trap, play my trap.
Can we shoot the venom out?
I can go.
I slept in my club.
Three, two, one, on mantis.
Actually, I'm just looking.
Mag one, mag one, mag one, mag one, mag one, mag one, mag
one, mag one, mag one.
I need a look.
Someone, someone, someone.
Yeah, I killed my.
Someone's like, we should need the, we shouldn't need all
this.
Good guy, good guy.
Someone, Venus behind us.
Mario Gryom, might be trying this, C9.
You're gonna be like up there all, Let's go.
Let's go.
He's back there.
You went left side.
Just keep playing in my trap.
I see him.
He's bottom.
He's out.
Let him do that.
He damaged me.
Yeah.
All right.
Let me know when we get him back on.
They've stalled a little.
We need Loonol to stall it all right.
When they get behind I see him.
All right.
Look on the star.
We can walk the tick.
We can walk with it.
Okay.
I can get back on you.
Loon him behind.
Start it.
I'm hitting back on three, two, one.
I'm Mantis, I'm Mantis.
I'm Mantis.
Mantis, one, both one.
We killed Mantis.
J3 can die.
Don't die, don't die through.
Don't die through.
They have solid all, guys.
They have solid all, okay?
I don't think I can build it in time.
Just kill, kill them more often.
I'm saving Mantis after, okay?
No, show it, show it, show it, show it.
Oh, show it, show it.
Close one, close one.
You got that.
I slept him, I slept him.
I slept him.
Just play together on top.
We win.
We're pushing up.
Yep, good job, good job.
I almost have abait here.
All for гдеsaw-lord.
They just cloak all.
We have mantis.
We have magic heroes.
We can all forstar.
Yeah, just mantis вос-all or mag Daisy Solid, I guess.
But we need to...
If we mag offer Solid, we need to be able to kite it.
Yeah, we can mag out that.
We'll just shoot them.
Shoot them.
We can mantis if we need.
I gotta kill them, kill them, kill them.
Walk, walk, walk.
We need to walk him now.
Yeah, I'm hitting him.
Nice.
I'm splitting up with you, just in case.
I'm going to die, I'm going to die, but I can't worry about
it.
I got you.
Mag.
Okay.
Hey, I want to, I want to alter earlier on this, on this
hill.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah, they didn't use Ventus.
So yeah, yeah, I want you to heal.
I'll let you heal.
No one.
Guys, play for potato.
He's looking for no deal.
Okay, can you, can you bomb me in a sec?
I feel like I feel like I.
Nice.
Yeah, nice.
I'm ready to hit I think we just let Taito get his ult
someone's playing someone's playing I'm out I slept them too
but I can get back on with my ult yeah yeah I'm ready sick
you're ready three two one multi death we are I'm living I'm
yummy I am the I gave you my leaves oh I just got triple
It's fine.
We have like TP.
Time point, time point, time point.
Time point.
You can live.
Come on.
Wait, Sticky, I think you need to TP, right?
Uh, yeah, I could TP, I guess.
Buddy block, Buddy block.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You won't get killed.
I have also.
Just please can't be my also.
Help me.
Wait, Elsa, Elsa.
Shoot Elsa.
Shoot at him.
In front of the team.
Get him dead.
Shoot.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Bucky.
Help our Elsa.
No.
He's one.
I need you.
He's one, he's one.
Can you touch?
Oh.
That's what I said.
I said winnable.
Help Siggy.
It's just one.
It's just you.
We're gonna have to go.
We're gonna have cloak out.
I just...
I'm gonna do it again.
Oh yeah, like...
Oh, I'm lucky.
You can maybe, um, save also for the end of the cloak ult.
You can do whatever with the light.
Give me time we missed.
He flaked me and went.
I'll go with time.
Oh, yeah, yeah, it's on you.
Okay, let me know.
Live it.
Yeah, I can...
Kerr hook, go down.
All right!
I'm ready, I'm ready.
Yeah, I'm...
Three, two, one.
I'm into some of this.
I'll ult after.
Can you survive, oh.
I gotta get it off.
Yeah.
This is Winnerable because I can ult this!
Okay.
Winnerable, Winnerable, Winnerable.
Okay, yeah, Winnerable.
Okay, mag is full.
Make sure to get me a knight.
Mag 1 on him.
Nice, good throw.
I can try an ult or out.
Care hook, carry hook.
Yeah, I got hooked.
I got hooked.
No, it's bad, it's bad, just chill.
Okay.
We're down like two supports still.
Venom's gonna respawn, he's frozen.
I'm trying to get back.
Oh, if I can hit Demet just when you're ready.
Uh, yeah, I can slam in three, two.
Come on me, I need a bubble, I need a bubble.
Oh, fuck, she got out.
Oh, shit.
Really need help.
I got someone else on.
Okay.
I got boobed.
My bad.
You're good, you're good.
No, it's okay, it's okay.
You like me.
I can hit Paul call ready yeah I can hack in it three two
one look at them guys I think that's just one I just one I
just one I don't know what I'm saying just kill the point
I'll see you kill everyone yes bro I oh that's so unlucky I
went out of 5k bro he booped me so I hit the fucking like
ceiling zero two two two time to switch things up including
which side you're on you'll need a top-notch our offense is
gonna be really hard yeah I'm gonna go top right I'm
existing me and Olive can go top right do what we usually do
so this is why I put the same map over and over again now we
know what to do do first but it's good no i think it won't
work we need the mag bubble no that's the thing about dive
dive is just we leave the supports to fend for themselves
that's the whole thing that's why i hate playing die against
dive and with dive is because i is mostly like whoever kills
the other supports the fastest
yeah i'm gonna tap it great magneto himself it's just it's
just whoever kills the other support the fastest and it's
very miserable i am not surprised there are many who view
mutants it's just trading back lines yeah that's essentially
what dive is you just trade so take you tp behind them like
on the high ground behind them and then i hit their back
line from main i can walk up three can you keep you behind
them like on the high ground everybody go behind everybody
go with your thing everybody all right all right i'm gonna
walk through main olive olive tell me when you get your back
line i can I already know when you can hit.
Don't die instantly.
Play slow out of Pv.
Okay.
All right, let me know you can hit.
Let me know when you can hit.
Where are they supposed to find me?
They're supposed to be playing Mane.
Mane, they're Mane.
Oh, I'm being forced out.
No, I can't.
Let me know, let me know.
I'm ready.
I need healing in here.
Oh, Venom's in our entire team, guys.
We shouldn't be.
Yeah, Venom's on.
He's just playing.
But yeah, I can swim.
I can swim.
You wanna go?
Let me know when you're ready.
I'm not ready.
I can go whenever.
Okay, three, two, one.
That's bad.
Mag one!
I'm dropping down.
Good job.
Yeah, just guys, play together when they TP don't like run
around.
Die!
I don't know how we're gonna die, but don't die.
Just play slow.
Don't die, okay?
I had this out.
We're in my trap.
I'm flying.
I'm ahead of here, too.
Thanks, Nothing.
I'm shooting Venom.
I'm diving.
Get the Venom at first.
Stop that.
We've done him.
One more.
Venom, Venom.
Venom still.
Venom.
Guys, walk now.
Walk now, we're on background.
There's a...
Change one, change one.
It's okay.
That guy's not doing anything.
Don't worry, just keep walking.
That guy's not gonna do anything.
Ya, Ya, ya, ya, ya, ya, ya, ya, ya, ya, y't get me.
There's still the...
I know, I'm sorry.
I low keypeding the wall.
I'm sorry.
I think I just stick I'm gonna stick on yeah you can yeah
they're on triple triple support Mantis Mantis first again
you believe
I'm looking at the Venom's out Venom's out we can go we can
go okay I'm looking Sam three two one i'm deep i'm deep oh
my god oh my oh wow oh they got that julia oh
he won't she's one she's one she's dead she does nice
i mean the ulcer the ulcer three two One.
Yes, Whale.
You got me.
I'm dead here.
No, he'll have Whale next.
Go next.
They use both support ults, guys.
Don't worry.
They use both support ults, Elsa ults.
Don't worry about it.
You want to slam me then I can go for alt?
Yes, sir.
She's both tank ults.
This fight is win.
Just rip it, bro.
Don't worry.
They have like nothing.
They only have emmer grab for you.
They literally jump into their back line with sticky, okay?
I'm ready whenever.
Can you throw a damage ramp on me?
Okay.
Yeah, I'm gonna let me know when you're ready Sicking.
Get no more, I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready.
I'm assuming GB Okay, they've done cloak level, no cloak
over Give me a walk, block, block, block, G1, G1.
They all won, they all one guys.
They all died just walked.
They are all grabbed.
I'm one grab them.
I'm a 1 HP.
Kill them now.
Kill the 향 ma offended.
We have Stranger all, get 3, 3, 3.
They should be able to touch him.
Yeah, 3 on him, 3 on 3 on.
Shoot their venom, guys, when he touches.
We gotta shoot him.
They're done.
I'm already shooting him.
He's my HP.
Shoot him, shoot him, shoot him, shoot him.
He slept, he slept, he slept.
You're going to kill everyone?
He's won, he's won.
You got him, go for him.
Go point, kill point, kill point, kill point.
Elsa, Elsa!
Is she that guy?
Oh, she's dead.
Good job, good job, good job.
Damn Newton, chill on me, bro.
Why'd my mom go Juicy League?
I am not in the sphere.
Come on, Kurt.
I don't know why.
Three, three, three, three.
We win the game with three.
What do we walk into respawn doors for?
Okay.
Also trap, also trap.
No, no, just chill.
Don't die, just don't die.
Can you set up for your die?
Yeah, I'm ready, I'm ready.
I'm letting the DPS walk on him.
Why I boot him?
I kill him, I kill him.
Oh, call, call, call.
We did it, we did it, we did it, we did it.
We did it, we did it, we did it.
We did it.
It took a black eye, what?
Another epic victory.
lagging my fucking bull sack off yeah i know i don't want to
play anymore how bad are lagging we won look guys i did
damage bro from the beginning of today when i woke up i
thought it was gonna be balanced look guys discord and
everyone voted they did a vote i i guys i i did it and we
end on a win we end on a win guys we got a series we got a
series guys that's series that is a series right there we
end on a fucking win i actually could have done so much more
on cat by the way i didn't do enough i could have no i just
did a good job of living i was just making sure i lived so i
could like have the that's all that matters now i can should
talk pizza first time chat that's great no i'm joking i'm
joking why why is our more playing julie like yeah i don't
know now she's like coat swapped vibes are back i have a
bunch of them though but i don't know i feel i don't know i
feel like it might be easier we just put me a stuff and i
don't know i'll talk to boker about it yeah we killed
everyone on bucky and then they banned spider-man they
banned spider-man after this game yeah yeah i don't know and
they won and they won and i was like wait wait and then i
feel like yeah i don't know wakana's no longer Chris, I
know!
We finally did it!
I don't know the philosophy behind the Wakanda!
But while you're here, let's get luck, Golden.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah, honestly, because I've...
I have a really packed in.
I don't want to drag my team down to play around my
schedule.
They want to scrim a lot, because I legitimately can't scrim
until 5.
I want to go to that.
I legit cannot play...
I cannot do scrims until 5 p.m.
And I legitimately...
want to drag my team down because of my schedule i swear i
swear i did it that's all that's all that matters to me bro
i haven't played cat since i like i was born bro yeah not
bad at it cat's just good i think he's staying on i'll raid
you i'll raid you i have to sleep bro the curse is broken I
can organize some shit later but I go to sleep I'm like
fucking losing my mind
Oh dad knows Dad heard the GG's I have to walk him Dad heard
it I walked him really late just because I knew I had a
tournament I knew I couldn't wake up Um
Um Um Um
All right.
Yeah, that knows all the...
I don't know.
We'll see if there's another gorilla stream today on Twitch
for Rivals.
We'll see.
Anyway.
Uh, at least we ended up...
Hey!
Hey, you're gonna get your walkies soon.
All right?
Hey!
Hey.
Your walkies will be done soon.
I didn't give him a treat.
It's real bad because um, and then like everyone was so sad
too I mean everyone became happier, but even then I thought
I thought I expected more happiness You know
I I thought I felt like we're gonna have like a parade of
the parade a celebration so Boop, boop, boop, boop, we did
it!
I was just like, a muted happiness.
Like, you know, not less.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
It was just less depressing.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm happy I ended.
I'm happy we ended on a win.
Yeah.
I'm less sad now.
I'm less sad.
But I was sad.
when the passive aggressiveness hit because I don't fuck
with passive.
I don't know.
I just, you know, I could tell when something is directed at
me and I'm just like, I'm not gonna play better.
You know, I'm, I'm not gonna play better when you're
directing it at me.
I'll talk, I'll ask Burger what he thinks about, yeah,
because I don't, I feel bad.
bad too, because like I said, I can't commit, I can't commit
hours to scrims unless it's at 5 p.m.
It has to be after 5 p.m.
where I can scrim.
Apparently a lot of scrims happen at 3, and I was like, I
legitimately cannot show up at 3 p.m.
You have to like, I have to show up at 5.
Like, yeah.
Yeah.
Um, so it, it, it, just uh but you know i get it like losing
sucks i think for me it's because i've done so many of these
tournaments now i don't let it uh you know i i like let i
bend it out i vent it out to you guys if something happens
um i vent it to you guys if something happens and uh but i
try not to affect the team because i know i know like i know
like you know i don't want to bring the team feeling
frustrated and something um and because i'm so used to you
know there's wins and losses in a tournament and like i know
i was like venting about it but no don't send any hate
towards anyone or anything don't don't like be like it's
just it's a game i mean i won't say it's just a tournament
but it's still a lot of money for the tournament it was just
me venting you know it was just me venting because i was
just like i was frustrated as well because i felt like a
little bit, but they just like, I felt like I was being
pushed into the deep end.
Yeah, it was just a, I think it was just like the lack of
synergy since we didn't play it.
We only did one scrim together.
So it was just like the lack of synergy we had as a team.
And I felt, yeah, I felt like they just pushed me into the
middle of the ocean and like I have no life rack.
And they were like, just feel for it.
yeah vent to your chat not your teammates you know and then
oh yeah when they're like you're fine just walk forward and
then i see i walk forward i see ray fighting for her life
and i was like do i leave you to die like they're like when
it's like where's my heels and i'm like me trying to sleep
the venom and i'm just like oh That caught me off guard
Because I was just like What do you I was I slept I was
sleeping the venom I was fighting We were fighting Our own
war Yeah
The venom Yeah You were I'm sorry I'm fighting I had to
sleep the venom For my Luna Yeah
yeah like it was a different war in the back line um but
like bro's playing like we have our captain's playing with
200 ping he's like trying to fight the future right now he's
he's trying to he's stuck in he's stuck in the jurassic era
wow wow we're like we're like in 3,026 right now and he's
out there in bc yeah he's trying to predict the future which
is like you know a lot of unlucky stuff going on yeah and at
2 in the morning hey I'll finish my story and he just wants
to go to the dog park I've been spoiling him with dog parks
every day and he just wants to he just wants to go to the
dog park so badly you know what sucks dad would like he's
fine when um He's like, he's like, he hates dogs when we're
walking to the dog park, but the moment he's freed from in
the dog park, he doesn't bark at any, he doesn't like
aggress on the other dogs.
It was so fun.
There were two tiny dogs that were barking nonstop barking
at him, and he didn't give a fuck about it.
Yeah, he didn't give a single fuck about it.
He just ignored them and was like, whatever.
But like, if it was any other, if we were, if he was
leashed, whenever he's leashed and I'm walking there, you
would just be like, like, back up.
away back away six feet back away yeah yeah he fucking hate
he just hates dogs when he's leashed up when he's at the
park he's just like yay I love everyone yeah he's on guard
when he's leashed hey guys um I'll see how I feel I just
feel bad like I don't like being the I don't like being the
I don't like being the weakest link.
And I always want to have fun.
And I feel bad because, like I said, my schedule is not as
free as everyone else.
And I don't want to hold my team back.
Like, I put the blame on me because I know they're
frustrated at me because I don't have the game sense.
I don't have the game sense or the game knowledge to play at
the level that my teammates are.
But I'm still trying my best.
And I just, I'm still trying.
I'm still trying my best to catch up with everybody.
And I've been, like I said, I've been playing nonstop the
last couple of days, even with my schedule to like just know
how to play.
But I just, I don't have the scrim knowledge like everyone
else.
So they all assume like, you know, some of these are like
things that is like common knowledge.
And well, maybe I'm not the weakest link, but I am one of
the, I don't know.
I am one of like the, the, like one of players that they can
target because I don't have as much knowledge.
I don't have as much knowledge as the other players.
So I feel bad because I want to, I don't want to be the one
that brings the team down because especially with the lack
of time I can scrim.
And, and, and like I, I, I feel really bad because if they
want to scream at three, I legitimately cannot scream at
three.
But I think I did as well as I could with the situation I
was given because I'm not used to it.
They're like, just alt when you feel like it.
I was like, yeah, the call to alt whenever I feel like it.
Like, if you feel it, like, so because I keep asking, you
want me to alt this now?
know i i ask because in the other tournaments i would always
ask because i i know like these players have more game
knowledge than me so um so i i that's why i always ask in my
previous tournaments there's never been like uh an issue
before and i'll be like just tell me when to alt but then i
feel like i'm not getting that uh calm to so i would just be
like do i alt this because That's why I ask because I don't
know exactly if I should because this is a more high level
play.
Yeah, so yeah.
So that's why I just need more guidance, I think, when it
comes to this tournament.
And I feel really bad because I don't have the game sense
that all these players do because they play this game every
day.
I just play it like, I just go, I play in and out when I
can.
Yeah, I have said that.
I was like, I think the, I think I hate that, like, that one
moment where it's like, do you want me to alt?
And someone said yes.
And I was like, who said yes?
And I gave a count.
I was like, three, two.
And then when I said one, they were like, don't alt.
And I was like, ah!
No one, no one fucking...
Bad, like, no one, what's the word?
Revealed themselves.
No one revealed.
I was like, who said yes?
Who?
No one took accountability.
I was just like, who said yes?
And then no one said anything.
I was like, messed up.
Who told me to all?
Like, yeah.
Yeah.
never stop you before nobody stopped me i was like okay will
the will the will they please say stand up i was like i
swear to god i heard a yes yeah
because like me doing the vibes is what i do in rank but
it's different like my rank what i the feeling it out but
like Yeah.
Yeah, it's just, I don't know.
I'll feel it out today and see how I feel.
I'll feel it.
I just feel bad because I know my teammates are frustrated
with me and I don't want them to be frustrated.
I want to give them a better chance.
I want to give them a better chance in this tournament.
So if I feel like this would give them a better because a
lot of them are strong streamers too.
And that's why I think that's why I feel even worse than
like other tournaments because my team, like I'm the biggest
streamer in my team.
And a lot of the players in my team are also very small
streamers.
And I feel really bad about, you know, they want to do
really well so they can look like, you know, this is like
they're thinking like I said, a lot of these tournaments is
very hard.
these tournaments if you're a small streamer and i feel
really bad about it too because i want to give them a better
chance to shine in this tournament i don't want them to like
feel like oh like you know this is their chance to look good
in front of a lot of people too yeah yeah and i feel like
that's what i want um that's what i also want them to have
and i don't know maybe i'm just too
maybe I'm just too what's it sympathetic empathetic about
the situation because I always want to what's best for
everybody yeah I'm just like I just want what's best for
them as well and the fact I'm on Twitch too I can't give
them a a collab room like a stream to get an option too so
passionate yeah this isn't your Yeah, but I want them,
because like, this is their chance to do, this is their
chance to shine.
And I don't want to take away that chance from them just
because of me not being like, you know, the best player they
could have on their team.
And I just, like I said, I think maybe I just care too much.
Maybe I just, I just care too much.
And so I also stopped talking because I feel like, oh, I'm
not helping.
vocalize what like if I my comms might not be I only talk
when I have to talk yeah um yeah I overthink a lot I'm a
huge overthinker it didn't help that there was a
miscommunication thing in work too that had to clear up
today while like you know how like I'd stopped and was
starting like messaging people and stuff about things there
was miscommunication that had to uh take care of during that
time.
So he was just like, boom, boom, boom, like stacking it
together.
But I'm going to go walk, Dad.
Now, thank you for hanging out with me.
Even though it was a very, very rough start.
I think the games were close, though.
I literally think even my synergy wasn't there.
Like, you know, even if we, not, I won't say wasn't there,
but even if we had like really rough synergy with the team,
I do think like the matches were close.
Like, I don't think like each team was like, better than the
others there's like little mistakes that everyone made um
and um there are little mistakes that everyone made and uh
but like each game seemed really really close where it
didn't seem like a like they weren't spawn camping us at so
i feel like like if the synergy was a lot better i think it
would obviously change the outcome but hey not last though
ha ha ha ha yeah not last in the seating though ha ha yeah
yeah at least the uh like the mistakes were definitely
fixable uh so yeah anyway um thank you for watching for
always cheering me even if like vibes started going down hey
i'm almost done i'm almost you're gonna get your walk you
soon give me five minutes um even like it was a rough start
and i did try to cheer like i did try to make it more
optimistic but i even i was just like everyone's too sad no
one wants to laugh with me um but um like even when the
games were a little rough like thank y'all for coming into
the watch and for supporting the supporting me um i really
appreciate it and i'm still going to do these tournaments
i'm still even if i feel like ah you know i was like ah you
know it's stuff like that but you know this is why i like
just i have to vent like i vent it out and stuff like that
but i have no hard feelings with any of my teammates i have
no hard feelings at all it's just like in the moment where
you know like because i've done so many these tournaments so
i know how to just like i know how to just brush it off a
lot during these types of moments like of these rival
streams i got like you know i got like tilted over
everything and i tilted at my teammates and it was really
bad but like now now i know how to brush it off a lot better
because i'm just like there's always another tournament and
i do these because they're fun well like i like being
competitive i like being competitive and i like the free
money is all i'm not gonna be like free money is nice too
um but i know like for some of these streamers in this
tournament like they might not have their next tournament
their next big tournament might not be like very soon so i
understand why everyone's like super serious super
passionate because they don't know when their next
tournament is and um and um i get it so they don't have a
lot of tournament experience where uh because like create
tournaments they they're just you know yeah like create
tournaments there's so many of them but lot of these
creativist who tend to invite creators who are not
essentially rivals creators.
So that's why like, you know, like the, like, you know,
because they want the eyes on people, eyes on it from people
who don't play normally play rivals.
And that makes sense.
And so, you know, a lot of these players might not be used
to playing creative tournaments because of it.
They're used to playing hardcore tournaments with scrums,
coaches and everything.
Yeah.
So I was very surprised going in when everyone started
screaming right off the bat Because I'm not used to that a
lot of creative tournaments.
They just go straight up.
We play We figure it out live and everyone's getting
coaching and scrims and everything and I try to open up my
schedule for it too Like the only biggest issue was that
when they did the drafting when they did the auction house
where they sold people I'm never gonna let live that down
when they did the auction house to sell people They wanted
to organize a scrim right away while I was in the middle of
my collab.
And that was the one time where I was like, I legitimately
cannot scrim at that time.
I legitimately could not scrim because I was like, Hey, I
have a, I'm literally in the collab right now.
Yeah.
No, I knew it was a serious tournament.
I was just, I wasn't, I knew it was a serious because he
told me it was a serious tournament.
I was very surprised at how committed I guess everyone was
because I'm so used to the creator term is not having that
commitment.
Yeah, so I straight up was like, if it was any other time,
like I could do it later tonight.
I literally told him like after my collab, after my collab,
I can literally do it like later tonight.
And then sadly like people just couldn't, like they couldn't
get a scrim.
So I was like, okay, I'll just practice rank and stuff.
And it was just like, you know, it's just unfortunate timing
because the moment they drafted, the more they drafted,
they, they wanted to scrim during, they wanted to scrim at
the time I was literally in a collab.
Yeah.
Yeah, but I, I took it seriously.
I was just like, everyone's getting coaches.
I even suggested like, oh, do you want like I know these
players, do you want these coaches?
But then they're like, no, we have our own coach.
I was like, all right, cool.
And I even helped out our tank player.
I even connected one of our tank players to one of my
friends who is a pro tank player.
Like I connected him with Madara being like, hey, and trust
me too.
I asked, trust me, hey, can you help coach one of our tank
players?
And I even like connected him.
I even like reached out to like, because our one of our tank
was like, Zoftic was like, hey, I'm really struggling right
now because I'm only, I main Hulk and I'm scared that we
might not, And he was just like, can one of you guys VOD
review me?
And I was like, hey, and I reached out to him personally in
a DM being like, hey, I heard you're struggling.
I can connect you to one of my friends.
And then I even like, I asked like Madara and trust me for a
favor being like, hey, can you like help coach one of my
tanks?
To can you coach help me VOD review and coach one of my
players?
And, you know, I was like, I owe you guys.
And, like, trust me, I was like, I have to pack up, pack for
land, but I can give, like, quick tips.
And, like, he just sent me, like, he just sent me, like, a
couple of tips.
And I sent that to Zyoktik.
And then Madara was like, yeah, I can coach him.
And I was like, oh, cool.
Thank you, Madara.
And I was like, I owe you guys.
I literally was just like, I owe you guys.
Thanks for helping out.
Like, like I said, I did take it seriously.
But, like, I also said, as one of two variety streamers, um,
um, I...
I do have other obligations and I feel bad I couldn't fully
give my 100% to my team.
And that's why I wish I could.
I really, really wish I could give full 100% because they
have to play around my schedule if they want scrims.
And that's what is tearing me up right now.
Because now I'm like, I don't, because like before the
tournament, I'm like, we'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
You know, like before the tournament, I'm like, I think
we'll be fine.
after after the first day I was like will we be fine I'm
just like after the first day I'm like I don't know it will
be fine now like if before I'm like it's fine it's fine that
if scrims have to go around my skills because I feel bad if
they're like we need a 3 p.m.
scrim and I can't be there so like I said I'll think about
it.
I'll make a decision later today, like before the end of the
day to see it.
Just, yeah.
Um, and then I'll, I'll, I'll, cause like, um, so I'll just
think about it, but I do appreciate everybody watching.
Like, you know, some tournaments, there are like sad
moments, but sometimes there are happy moments.
I mean, we didn't end on a loss, and that's great.
That's the best part.
Yeah, P. We didn't end on a loss.
Yay.
hydrated, pause, check it out.
I'm around to get that blood flowing.
You stay up for me.
Head to bed, guys.
You deserve it.
Thank you guys for the support.
I'm sorry.
It looked like the stream seemed a little downer, downer at
first, or like gradually built, because I, you know, like I
told you guys, like passive aggressiveness is where I draw
the line in a lot of things, because I really, I think it's
just trauma.
I think for me, I had like so many instances with passive
aggressiveness that it's just like a trigger for me, and I
have like a lot of like trauma associated with passive
aggressiveness.
So, um, So it hits me really, really hard during those
moments.
And it just grabs a hold of me.
And because of that, I don't do really well with it.
And I know I just like to live with it.
But I just don't do very well with passive aggressiveness at
all.
And I just think I have some trauma associated with it.
And I won't be surprised if that's the case.
so but i i was able to i i tried to reset myself and i think
i i managed to uh reset myself a lot better yeah as it went
on yeah um but thank you guys uh thank you guys again um
we'll see i'll see you guys at tecocon tomorrow is tecocon
guys uh wait i'm counting real fast six seven eight nine ten
one twelve uh tomorrow's tecocon there is a mean and greed
there's a panel if you're going to be at Pennsylvania?
Was it Pennsylvania?
Philadelphia?
The state starts with a P.
I don't remember.
It's either Pennsylvania or Philadelphia.
Which one was it?
I know it's East Coast.
I just remember the state started with a P. I don't...
It's P something.
One of them.
But you got Tekken.
There's exclusive merch there.
I'm doing a...
I have exclusive merch there that are dedicated to the
convention.
Um, and I have meeting greets there.
It's, and everything.
It's in Pittsburgh.
Yeah.
Okay.
Pittsburgh, uh, Philadelphia.
Philadelphia is in Pennsylvania.
All right.
I sort of, all right.
We Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
Is that it?
I don't remember.
Okay, guys, look, uh, I don't remember.
Anyone going to Tekukon?
I'll see you guys there.
Um, and then.
And tomorrow I'll try and see if I can walk.
I'm going to visit some artists at Offkai too tomorrow.
And if you guys see me visiting some artists, I can't stop
too often.
Because I have a very short time window.
A very short time window.
Whenever for me walking around Artist Alley.
So I'm really sorry if you guys do bump into me at Artist
Alley.
If I don't say hi back.
Or we can't do photos.
time window and I want to visit the artist first so I just
want to let you guys know that right now because like I said
I only have like an hour or an half an hour or so doing it
um whose streams we watch for wildcard club that will be on
Sunday at 12 p.m.
and it will be on all our channels for the panel all our
channels will have it um and it's only the post I think it's
Tuesday Tuesday is the post off kite stream that I'ma lean
and when that is going to host it I think it's Tuesday me
and Rin and it's gonna be in the morning I think I have a 10
in the in the morning or something but I think that's that's
it pencil think it was super chat they could thank you no I
usually don't upload panels it's sort of like I someone
usually would record the panel and they'll record it
themselves um it's it's like if there's a dragon there now
that records it um yeah uh just you know they usually upload
it on Twitter or YouTube but it's really up to the dragons
themselves um so that's a q a um and what else oh what about
the q a you mentioned on twitter i want to do it after the
panel i think like it's easier because there's like stuff i
can't say you know like there's if you guys have questions i
feel like after the panel when everything is explained i
might do a q a on monday to explain everything better to
explain everything um clear because i feel there's some
stuff I can't say because they want us to reveal it at the
panel and everything so um the teaser like the announcement
we did was sort of like a teaser announcement for off guy so
that's why and um oh yeah and on and then I have off guy uh
I have um I have like off guy meeting greets on Saturday if
you're at off guy I don't know if you're watching this if
you're at off guy there will uh if you buy any merch at the
nom's cafe booth which also sells my merch um you get to be
entered into a lottery for saturday so any days it could be
like our was saturday yeah it would be like friday or
saturday buying anything anything there's any purchases it
could be something small it could be a dog shirt um you'll
be entered to a lottery on saturday so even you buy on
friday you're still entering the lottery uh to to draw for
meeting greets so i need i heard someone wanting to clear
that up anyway i have to go for real now bye guys i have
some more stuff to do but thank you for hanging out with me
i feel a lot better now I just need to like let everything
out today because I don't want to like take that to another
I don't want to take that to like another stream like I
always want to like take pour all my feelings out because I
have a very I'm a very emotional person I need to like say
everything out in my head because I don't want to keep it
bottled inside and I don't want to take it with me like off
stream or like take it with me to the next um to the next
thing or everything I don't just um i'm glad that in the end
we did win another win and i think we are improving but like
i said i do want my i want what's best for my team you know
i want what's best for my team give them the best
opportunity because they're like i said they're all uh small
streamers and i want to give them the best opportunity
possible um um as like the bigger the biggest stream in here
but anyway guys i'll see you guys next time everybody bye
guys bye